ALL RIGHT LET'S
GET STARTED. GOOD AFTERNOON AND
WELCOME TO THE JOINT
INFORMATIONAL HEARING OF THE
ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS COMMITTEE
AND THE SENATE ELECTIONS AND
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENTS
COMMITTEE ON THE SUBJECT OF
EVALUATING CALIFORNIA'S RECALL
PROCESS BEFORE WE GET TO THE
SUBSTANCE OF THIS HEARING I
HAVE A FEW HOUSEKEEPING
ANNOUNCEMENTS TO MAKE. DUE TO
THE COVERT PANDEMIC WE CONTINUE
TO OPERATE WITH MODIFIED
COMMITTEE PROCEDURES. ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS PRESENT HERE
IN THE COMMITTEE ROOM MUST WEAR
A MASK OVER YOUR MOUTH AND NOSE
AT ALL TIMES. WE ALSO CONTINUE
TO PROVIDE ALTERNATIVE OPTIONS
FOR THE PUBLIC TO TESTIFY IN
THE COMMITTEE. INCLUDING
ALLOWING TESTIMONY AT A REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION ON THE NORTH
STEPS OF THE CAPITOL. AND
ALLOWING TESTIMONY BY PHONE. IN
ORDER TO FACILITATE THE GOAL OF
HEARING AS MUCH FROM THE PUBLIC
WITHIN OUR TIME LIMITS. WE WILL
NOT TOLERATE CONDUCT THAT
DISRUPTS DISTURBS OR OTHERWISE
IMPEDE TO THE ORDERLY CONDUCT
OF THE COMMITTEE'S PROCEEDINGS.
PLEASE BE AWARE THAT VIOLATIONS
OF THESE RULES MAY SUBJECT YOU
TO REMOVAL OR OTHER ENFORCEMENT
ACTIONS. THERE ARE FOUR PANELS
OF SPEAKERS ON TODAY'S AGENDA.
AFTER THE COMMITTEES HERE FROM
THESE EXPERT WITNESSES. THERE
WILL BE TIME FOR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. IN ORDER TO ENSURE
THAT THE COMMITTEES ARE ABLE TO
COMPLETE OUR BUSINESS IN THE
ALLOTTED TIME AND TO HEAR FROM
AS MANY PEOPLE AS POSSIBLE.
PUBLIC TESTIMONY WILL BE
LIMITED AS FOLLOWS. WE'VE SET
ASIDE ONE HOUR FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT. STARTING WITH MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC CORE HERE IN THE
ROOM. EACH PERSON WILL HAVE ONE
MINUTE TO MAKE YOUR REMARKS.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC ARE ALSO
ENCOURAGED TO SUBMIT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO THE COMMITTEES.
THIS WRITTEN TESTIMONY WILL
BECOME PART OF THE OFFICIAL
RECORD OF THE HEARING. FOR
THOSE WHO ARE WATCHING THIS
HEARING REMOTELY AND WHO WISH
TO CALL IN TO SPEAK DURING THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY PORTION. OF
THE HEARING THE CALL IN NUMBER
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN. AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS ONE THREE
ONE. FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO.
YOU CAN ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER
ON THE COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AS
WELL AS ON YOUR TV OR COMPUTER
SCREEN. AND I WILL REPEAT THIS
CALLING INFORMATION ONCE WE GET
TO THE PUBLIC TESTIMONY PORTION
OF THE HEARING. IF YOU'RE
HAVING ANY PROBLEMS WITH THE
MODERATED PHONE SERVICE YOU CAN
CALL THE ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE AT NINE ONE SIX.
THREE ONE NINE TWO ZERO NINE
FOUR. AND MY STAFF WILL BE
THERE TO TRY TO HELP. THANK YOU
FOR HEARING THANK YOU FOR
BEARING WITH US AS WE IMPLEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE EOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WITH
ALL THOSE ANNOUNCEMENTS ON THE
WAY LET'S MOVE ON TO THE TOPIC
OF TODAY'S HEARING. LAST MONTH
STATEWIDE GUBERNATORIAL RECALL
ELECTION RAISE QUESTIONS. ABOUT
WHETHER OUR ONE HUNDRED TEN
YEAR OLD RECALL PROCESS WAS THE
FIFTH HAS. SUFFICIENT CHECKS
AND BALANCES TO ENSURE
DEMOCRATIC AND FAIR ELECTIONS.
WELL I BELIEVE THE RECALL IS AN
IMPORTANT TOOL FOR VOTERS TO
ADDRESS MISCONDUCT BY ELECTED
OFFICIALS. I AM TROUBLED BY THE
FUNDAMENTALLY UNDEMOCRATIC
NATURE OF CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT
RECALL PROCESS. AS I'VE
PREVIOUSLY PREVIOUSLY STATED
CALIFORNIA LAW SHOULD NOT ALLOW
AN ELECTED OFFICIAL TO BE
RECALLED AND REPLACED BY
SOMEONE ELSE WHO RECEIVES FAR
FEWER VOTES. BUT IF LAST
MONTH'S RECALL HAD SUCCEEDED
THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED. IN FACT GOVERNOR
NEWSOM WHO RECEIVED MORE THAN
SEVEN POINT SEVEN MILLION VOTES
IN THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
GUBERNATORIAL ELECTION WOULD
HAVE BEEN REPLACED BY SOMEONE
WHO RECEIVED FEWER THAN THREE
POINT SIX MILLION VOTES. IN THE
RECALL. IN ADDITION TO THE
UNDEMOCRATIC NATURE OF
CALIFORNIA'S CURRENT RECALL
PROCESS MANY PEOPLE HAVE RAISED
CONCERNS THAT THE HYPER
POLARIZATION OF SOCIETY.
COUPLED WITH THE ABNORMALLY LOW
THRESHOLD TO QUALIFY RECALL.
CREATES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
SMALL MINORITIES OF
CALIFORNIANS TO WEAPONIZE THE
RECALL PROCESS TO DISRUPT
GOVERNMENT. I LOOK FORWARD TO
LEARNING MORE ABOUT THE RECALL
PROCESS IN MOST OTHER STATES.
AND WHAT SMALL IMPROVEMENTS WE
MIGHT MAKING CALIFORNIA. AS WE
BEGIN OUR COMMITTEES
EXAMINATION OF CALIFORNIA'S
RECALL PROCESS I GO INTO THESE
HEARINGS WITH AN OPEN MIND. I
HAVE NOT YET MADE DECISIONS
ABOUT SPECIFIC REFORMS THAT I
MIGHT SUPPORT. BUT I HOPE THAT
TODAY'S HEARING WILL BEGIN A
STATE WIDE DISCUSSION ON
CALIFORNIA'S RECALL LAWS. AND
PROCEDURES. THAT WILL HELP
INFORM OUR COMMITTEES FUTURE
CONSIDERATION OF CHANGES TO
THAT PROCESS. AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING FROM OUR
STEAM PANELS OF EXPERTS. ABOUT
POTENTIAL OPTIONS FOR HOW
CALIFORNIA'S RECALL PROCESS
SHOULD BE REFORMED. SO THANK
YOU TO THE WITNESSES THAT ARE
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S
HEARING AND OTHER MEMBERS OF
THE TWO COMMITTEES THAT ARE
HERE TODAY- AND I WILL NOW TURN
IT THINGS OVER TO CHAIR GLAZER.
FOR HIS OPENING REMARKS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU CHAIR BERMAN
WELCOME EVERYONE. I AM PLEASED
THAT OUR TWO COMMITTEES ARE
HOLDING THESE JOINT HEARINGS ON
THE RECALL PROCESS. I THANK MY
COUNTERPART IN THE ASSEMBLY FOR
HIS PARTNERSHIP IN THIS.
IMPORTANT EFFORT. I DO SUPPORT
THE RECALL PROVISIONS OF OUR
CONSTITUTION. AS AN IMPORTANT
TOOL. TO ENSURE THAT LEADERS
REMAIN ACCOUNTABLE. TO THE
ELECTORATE. HOWEVER AS CHAIR
BERMAN HAS INDICATED IT'S BEEN
A HUNDRED TEN YEARS SINCE THE
VOTERS ADDED THIS PROCEDURE TO
OUR STATE CONSTITUTION. AND IT
IS CLEAR TO ME THAT THE MANNER
IN WHICH RECALLS ARE CONDUCTED
IN THE STATE DO NEED TO BE
REVISITED. AND POTENTIALLY
REFORM ACT. THE RECALL IS NOT
INTENDED AND MUST NOT
BECOME A BACK DOOR FOR THE
LOSING SIDE OF AN ELECTION TO
RE LITIGATE THOSE RESULTS. NOW
RECALLS WHILE POTENTIALLY
POSITIVE ARE DISRUPTIVE TO
GOVERNANCE CAN EXACERBATE
PARTISAN POLARIZATION. AND ARE
TREMENDOUSLY EXPENSIVE. THE
LAST GUBERNATORIAL RECALL COST
TAXPAYERS OVER A QUARTER OF A
BILLION DOLLARS TO PRODUCE
ESSENTIALLY THE SAME OUTCOME IN
TERMS OF VOTE PERCENTAGE IS THE
TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN. ALEXION
THIS IS MONEY THAT CALIFORNIANS
OVERWHELMINGLY AGREE COULD HAVE
BEEN BETTER SPENT ON MORE
PRESSING CONCERNS LIKE
ADDRESSING HOMELESSNESS PUBLIC
HEALTH EDUCATION AND PUBLIC
SAFETY. NOW WE'VE ALL HEARD OF
ANY VIEWS ABOUT THE RECALL AND
HOW IT CAN BE FIXED WHICH WE
APPRECIATE IN THE PUBLIC AROUND
AND WE'LL HEAR MORE DURING THIS
AND FUTURE HEARINGS. BUT NO
MATTER WHAT WE DO. REFORMING
THE RECALL SHOULD NOT BE A
PARTISAN ISSUE IT SHOULD BE
ABOUT GOOD GOVERNMENT. I LOOK
FORWARD TO HEARING OUR EXPERTS.
THAT OUR COLLEAGUES- ON THIS
TOPIC AS WE PROCEED WITH THESE
HEARINGS HERE BERMAN. THANK YOU
CHAIR GLAZER IN L. WANT TO GIVE
AN OPPORTUNITY THAT TO. MIKE MY
COLLEAGUES WHO ARE HERE EITHER
FROM THE ASSEMBLY OR FOR THE
SENATE IF ANYBODY WANTS TO MAKE
ANY OPENING COMMENTS- HAPPY TO
START WITH- DOES ANYBODY WANNA
MAKE ANY OPENING COMMENTS. SO
IS IT A VENTURE VICE. YEAH
PLEASE AS A YEAH I WANT TO
THANK YOU ALL FOR HAVING THIS
HEARING I'M ALL FOR OF ANY TYPE
OF IMPROVEMENTS THAT WE CAN
MAKE TO ANY OF OUR PROCESS
HE'S- HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND-
I'M ANXIOUS TO HEAR WHAT SOME
OF THE EXPERTS THAT HAVE DONE
SOME REAL RESEARCH ON THE
SUBJECT. MATTER HAVE TO SAY.
BECAUSE THIS IS THE LAST
BASTION OF CHECKS AND BALANCES
THAT WE OFFER- FOR THE FOR THE
VOTERS AND- IF WE'RE GOING DOWN
A PATH WHERE WE MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT. FOR THEM TO- ACCESS
THAT- YOU KNOW BUT I HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THAT. BUT AT THE
SAME TIME IF THEY WERE- WAYS OF
DOING IT- IN A MORE EFFICIENT
OR A BETTER MANNER THAT WE HAVE
BETTER OUTCOMES- AND THEN- I'M
OPEN TO HEARING THESE THINGS.
BUT SOME OF THE THINGS I I'VE
READ IN THE- LAST FEW WEEKS OF
CONCERN TO ME. ABOUT MAKING
THIS PROCESS HARDER AND- SOME
OF THE SOME OF THE THINGS I'VE
SEEN CAN HAVE THAT BUT THAT
CHILLING EFFECT ON- ACCESS FOR
VOTERS. TO- TO ENACT. OF
SOMETHING THAT WILL- IT I GUESS
FOR THE BETTER OF FOR LACK OF A
BETTER TERM JUST IF SOMEBODY
HAS MAKING AND MADE A MISTAKE
AND THEY'VE THEY REALIZE THAT
THE PERSON THAT THEY ELECTED IS
NOT WHO THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE-
THEY SHOULD HAVE A RECALL
PROCESS FOR THAT CHECKS AND
BALANCES AND SO I LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING PEOPLE'S REMARKS-
LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING THE
EXPERTS THAT HAVE STUDIED THIS.
AND SEEING IF THERE IS A WAY
THAT WE CAN MAKE A BETTER
PROCESS THANK YOU THANK YOU BYE
SERVICES ARTURO AND AT VICE
YOU'RE NIELSEN THANKS SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US WE ARE READY TO
HAPPEN TO HAVE ANY OPENING
REMARKS FROM YOU OR IF YOU WANT
A MINUTE WE CAN GO TO DESIGNER
MULLIN WHICHEVER YOU PREFER.
YES. IT'S GOING TO BE A TODAY
AND I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO IT
I'VE ALREADY BEEN TWO HEARINGS
ALREADY WITH THE LITTLE HOOVER
COMMISSION ON THE SUBJECT
MATTER I WANT TO MAKE IT.
COUPLE OF OBSERVATIONS. NUMBER
ONE I THINK THERE IS A VALID
QUESTION. OF THE MERIT. IN A
CHANGE. IN THE PROCESS AND
THAT'S BY VIRTUE OF THE FACT
THAT IT HAS BEEN SO SELDOM USED.
AND ONLY TWICE SIX ROUGHLY. AT
THE GUBERNATORIAL LEVEL. I WANT
TO PREFACE MY REMARKS AND NOT
LIMITLESS THIS IS NOT WORKING.
I GOT I'VE TRIED GET. GET IT
GET A THAT STAY UP ME HERE. NO
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE LET'S
START OFF WITH POLLING I KNOW
THERE'S BEEN PULLING OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME. ON THIS ISSUE.
BUT I'VE ASKED THE QUESTION.
HAS THAT POLLING INCLUDED IN
THE QUESTION. THE LACK OF
SUCCESS AND THE FREQUENCY OVER
A HUNDRED YEARS. I THINK THAT'S
NOT THE CASE THAT IF IT IS ANY
FUTURE POLLING MUST INCLUDE.
THAT REFERENCE FOR CONTEXT. IN
WHETHER OR NOT. AND I THINK
THAT WOULD BE A FAILING OF PAST.
POLLING FURTHER. JUST THE
AVALANCHE OF HISTORY IN
CALIFORNIA. ONE OF LATE IS
BROKEN SO BADLY. CAN THERE BE
SOME CHANGES YES I THINK THERE
CAN BE AND I'M HAPPY TO
ENTERTAIN THAT. BUT SIGNIFICANT
CHANGES I DON'T THINK SO. THE
INITIATIVE AND THE REFERENDUM
THE RECALL A VERY SACRED DIRECT
DEMOCRACY OPPORTUNITIES REALLY
PERFECTED IN THE STATE. AND
UNLIKE THE C. NOT TRIVIALIZE
THOSE. AND THERE'S ONE ISSUE
THAT I'D LIKE TO ADD TO THE
CONSIDERATION TODAY. AND THAT
IS CAMPAIGN FUNDING LIMITS. FOR
ALL PARTIES. THAT IS NOT NOW
THE CASE. THEN WE'VE SEEN VERY
DISPROPORTIONATE CONTRIBUTION.
SO WHAT I'M GOING TO SUGGEST
CARES THANK YOU FOR HAVING THE
HEARING IT'S IMPORTANT TO
CONTINUE THIS DISCUSSION. BUT
I'M GOING TO BE VERY RELUCTANT.
TO DO ANYTHING THAT
COMPROMISES. THE CITIZENS RIGHT
TO DIRECTLY AFFECT THEIR
FUTURES. AND WE DO NEED TO PAY
HEED TOM DEGREE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT I DO NOT SEE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT FOLKS MUCH
REPRESENTED HERE. AND NOR DO I
FIND SOME. TRADITIONAL
ORGANIZATIONS THAT DO NOT
SUPPORT THE TAMPERING OR THE
CHANGES THE RECALL PROCESS IT
WOULD APPEAR TO ME THAT MOST
WITNESSES OR AT LEAST DISPOSED
MORE TOWARDS. CHANGE THEN
OPPOSED TO CHANGE. AND THAT
CONCERN THANK YOU MR THANK YOU
MR VICE CHAIR AND JUST A QUICK
NOTE WE- AGREE WITH YOU ON ON
CONCERNS AROUND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND IN THE RECALL
PROCESS AT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT
LEVEL THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE-
PLAN TO LOOK AT A FUTURE
HEARING- SO SOME MORE TO COME.
ON THAT CAN THANK YOU- NOW
WE'RE JUST ON OUR MULLIN AS
YOU'D LIKE TO MAKE SOME OPENING
REMARKS. JUST VERY BRIEFLY.
MISTER CHAIR AND MISTER CHAIR.
OF THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
PROVIDING THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HEAR FROM SOME EXPERTS. I THINK
IT'S ABUNDANTLY CLEAR. SOME FOR
REFORM IS NEEDED I'M INTERESTED
IN HEARING THE IDEAS TODAY BUT
ULTIMATELY WHATEVER CHANGES
PROPOSED HAS TO PASS MUSTER
WITH THE VOTERS. I THINK VERY
CLEARLY WANT TO MAINTAIN. A
RECALL PROCESS BUT IF THERE'S A
WAY TO SIMPLIFY. THE PROCESS
MAKE IT'LL ACTUALLY LOOK MORE.
CLEAR FOR FOLKS TO UNDERSTAND
I'D I'D BE. OPEN TO THAT I BE
PREDISPOSED TO THAT I AM MOST
INTRIGUED I WOULD SAY- BY THE
SIMPLICITY OF A LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR SENDING TO THE
GOVERNORSHIP. UPON A RECALL-
YET SOME CONCERNS HAVE BEEN
RAISED. ABOUT SOME PERVERSE
INCENTIVES LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
OF A DIFFERENT PARTY PERHAPS-
WORKING TO A WORKING WITH
RECALL PROPONENTS TO HAVE A
GOVERNOR RECALL SO THAT
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR COULD
ASCEND. ALL ONE WAY TO ADDRESS
THAT IS IF WE JOIN THE TWENTY
SIX. OTHER STATES WHERE THE
GOVERNOR AND LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR ARE A TICKET. THEY ARE
THE SAME ADMINISTRATION OF THE
SAME PARTY SO IF THERE IS A
REMOVAL OF THE GOVERNOR. UPON
RECALL THE RESIGNATION THERE'S
A CLEAR LINE OF SUCCESSION
THERE'S CONTINUITY OF
GOVERNMENT THEY ARE PART OF THE
SAME ADMINISTRATION. WE SAW AN
EXAMPLE IN NEW YORK NOT A
RECALL. ABOUT A RESIGNATION BUT
A LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR. OF IT OF
THE SAME TICKET OF THE SAME
PARTY OF THE SAME
ADMINISTRATION ASCENDED TO THE
GOVERNORSHIP SO THERE'S A WAY
TO LOOK AT THE LINE OF
SUCCESSION. ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT
DIRECTLY RELATED TO RECALL
REFORM IT'S ABSOLUTELY RELEVANT
TO- CREATING A STRUCTURE. OF
THAT MAKE SENSE IN THE RARE
OCCURRENCE OF A- OF A GOVERNOR
BEING RECALL BUT I LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING ALL THE IDEAS IN
FACT MR STERN BOB STERN IS
GOING TO BE ADDRESSING THOSE
HAD GOVERNOR QUESTION.
UNFORTUNATELY I WON'T BE IN THE
ROOM I BELIEVE WHEN HE IS HERE.
BUT I'LL BE LISTENING AND
FOLLOWING THE HEARING AND LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH OUR
RESPECTIVE CHAIRS. ON UP ON
FUTURE REFORMS. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU MA'AM YOUR THOUGHT-
COMMENTS WE'RE NOW MOVED OUR
FIRST THE SPEAKER. PER THEIR
PER. ON WHY CHANGE THE RECALL
PROCESS. WE HAVE FOUR
DISTINGUISHED WITNESSES
STARTING OFF WITH OUR SECRETARY
OF STATE. DR SHIRLEY WEBER. LED
BY SUPERVISOR BRUCE MCPHERSON
FORMER US SENATOR MARTHA
SECUNIA AND FORMER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JIM CONVENE. OUR
FIRST SPEAKER IS OUR CURRENT
SECRETARY OF STATE- DOCTOR
WEBER SERVED IN THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE FROM TWO THOUSAND
TWELVE UNTIL HER APPOINTMENT.
AS SECRETARY OF STATE IN
JANUARY OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
DURING HER TIME IN THE
LEGISLATURE DR WEBER SERVED AS
CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET
COMMITTEE THE ASSEMBLY
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
COMMITTEE. AND THE BUDGET SUB
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
PLEASED TO WELCOME SECRETARY
WEBER WITH US THIS AFTERNOON
SECRETARY WEBER. WELCOME TO A
BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY. WELL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- TO THE
TWO CHAIRS OF THE ELECTION
COMMITTEE FROM THE ASSEMBLY-
LISTED BERMAN AND FROM THE
STATE AND FROM THE SENATE. I
REALLY THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO BE WITH YOU-
REMOTELY- TO DISCUSS THE ISSUE
OF RECALL AND I KNOW WE HAVE A
VERY LIMITED AMOUNT OF TIME. OF
THE TWO NEED TO KNOW THAT- I
TOO HAVE BEEN CONSULTING WITH
THE DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS
BECAUSE I THINK THE DECISION
THAT WE MAKE IF THERE IS A
DECISION HAS TO HAVE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. ALSO THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA ARE PROTECTED
REGARDLESS OF THE PARTY THAT
THEY'RE IN- JUST SOME GENERAL
INFORMATION I'M HERE TODAY TO
REALLY CHAT WITH YOU ABOUT THE
PROCESS THE RECALL THE TO
PLACE- IT WAS INTERESTING TO ME
AND BASICALLY HAVING TAKEN
OFFICE IN PROBABLY THREE OR
FOUR MONTHS THAT I WAS.
IMMEDIATELY THRUST IN THE MIDST
OF A RECALL AND- AND ALL THE
CHALLENGES AND ALL OF THE
ISSUES SURROUNDING THE RECALL
MOST y
DOORSTEP- AS WELL AS THIS LIST
UP THE GROUND LEGAL COUNSEL AND
WE SPENT A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
TIME. IN LITIGATION AROUND THE
WHOLE ISSUE OF RECALL SO I HAVE
FIRST HAND KNOWLEDGE OF LOOKING
AT THE RECALL PROCESS IN RECALL
LEGISLATION IN TERMS OF WHAT
REALLY- WHAT WORKED AND WHAT
MAKE PEOPLE CONFUSED. AND THE
FACT THAT THERE MAY BE A NEED
FOR SOME CHANGE IN THE RECALL
PROCESS. OF THE RECALL COST US-OUT ALMOST THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS AND THAT
DOESN'T COUNT ALL OF THEM THE
RESOURCES THAT WENT INTO IT NOT
ONLY JUST IN TERMS OF THE
STATE. BUT IF YOU ADD IN THE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT WAS
PAID OUT IN OUR CAMPAIGN-
INDIVIDUALS AND THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS I MEAN IT'S AN EXTREMELY
EXPENSIVE PROCESS THAT SHOULD
NEVER BE INTO THE INTO THE
LIKELY- BECAUSE OF THE
CONSEQUENCES THAT WILL HAVE NOT
ONLY FINANCIALLY. BUT
CONSEQUENCES TO PEOPLE'S LIVES
WE MAILED OUT BALLOTS TO EVERY
REGISTERED VOTER IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF THE LEGISLATION THAT
WAS GIVEN TO US. BY THE
ASSEMBLY IN THE SENATE. TO SEND
A BALLOT EVERY CALIFORNIA.
WHICH MADE THE TURN OUT MUCH
GREATER TURNOUT TO HAVE BEEN IN
FACT. NEARLY 50% OF ALL THE
RAGE VOTER. UP IN JUST A- IN
THIS PARTICULAR RECALL. WAS ON
YOUR ALL THIRTY MILLION.
CALIFORNIANS IN THE PAST
ELECTION OF THUS FAR AS WE HAVE
TO FIND A CLOSE THE BOOKS. ARE
62% OF THE PROTEST. VOTED NO ON
THE RECALL AND ROUGHLY 38%
VOTED YES. I IT'S IMPORTANT NOT
TO FORGET HOW QUICKLY THIS
RECALL ELECTION HAPPEN IT WAS
CONDUCTED IN IN IN IN IN A MERE
SEVENTY FIVE DAYS. AFTER
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR STATUS THE
ELECTION DATE. WITH THE RESULTS
NOW CERTIFIED- FROM THE FROM
THE DATE THAT THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR GAVE US THE PROCESS
ITSELF WAS COMPLETED IN UNDER
FOUR MONTHS. WHICH IS A WITH
VOICE STATE THE SIZE IT IS
DIFFICULT TO RUN SUCH ELECTION.
WITH ALL OF THE ISSUES OF ALL
THE CONCERNS- IN THAT SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME. SOME OF YOU
KNOW THAT EVEN DOWN TO SOME OF
THE SMALLEST DETAILS WHICH IS
ACTUALLY THE DETAILS. OF
FINDING PAPER ADEQUATE PAPER TO
RUN THE BALLOTS ON AND TO SEND
OUT THE- THE INFORMATION WAS A
WAS A MAJOR CHALLENGE- THAT
FORTUNATELY BECAUSE THOSE WHO
HAVE DONE THIS BEFORE NEW ABOUT
IT. BEGIN WORKING EARLY- FOR
FEAR THAT THERE WOULD BE A
RECALL AND THEREFORE WE WERE
ABLE TO SECURE SOME VENDORS TO
BE ABLE TO PROVIDE THAT. THE
RECALL LISTEN- WAS ESTABLISHED
A PROCESS IN NINETEEN ELEVEN
IT'S IN AND HOLDING TEN YEARS
IN THE AND REMARKABLY THERE'S
ONLY. MINOR CHANGES IN THE
RECALL ELECTION PROCESS. ARE WE
LIVING IN SOMEONE HISTORIC TIME
SINCE THE RECENT RECALL
ELECTION. IS ONLY THE SECOND
TIME IN CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY
THE STATEWIDE RECALL HAS
QUALIFIED AND RESULTED IN AN
ELECTION. THE FIRST WAS IN TWO
THOUSAND AND THREE AND WITH THE
RESULT OF GOVERNOR GRAY DAVIS.
I THINK THIS GIVES US AN
OPPORTUNITY ASK PEOPLE HAD SAID
THEY WOULD DO IN TWO THOUSAND
THREE TO REFLECT ON HOW THE
PROCESS WORKS. AND WHETHER THAT
WORKS WELL FOR CALIFORNIA. IT
GIVES US THAT AND THE PUBLIC IN
THE LEGISLATURE AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REVIEW. AND CHANGE OR REFINE
THE PROCESS THERE. I DON'T
THINK WE NECESSARY HAVE ALL THE
IN. THAT FAR AND OF ASKED ME
TO. DO THEM WHAT I WE SHOULD DO
AND I STILL. CA TO THE FACT
THAT IT SHOULD BE A
CONVERSATION WATER JUST MY- IT
SHOULD BE A COME. AMONG AND
THAT SO WE SHOULD BE ASKING
SOME CRITICAL QUESTIONS ABOUT
THE PROCESS ITSELF- IS IT FAIR
TO THE PUBLIC YOU KNOW IS IT
FAIR TO THE PUBLIC SECTOR THAT
WE ARE BASICALLY. ENGAGED IN
THIS PROCESS AFTER THE PUBLIC
IS DECIDED WHO THEY WANTED TO
BE ELECTED. AND WE'RE ABLE TO
BASICALLY MAKE A CHANGE WITH A
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF INDIVIDUALS
WILL RAISE THE ISSUE- IS IT. AS
A SAID IS IT FAIR TO ALL VOTERS
NOT JUST THE PUBLIC BUT THOSE
WHO ACTUALLY THOUGHT. I HAD
MANY VOTERS CONTACTED MY OFFICE
SAYING THAT THEY DIDN'T THINK
IT WAS FAIR THEY WANT TO KNOW
WHY WE'RE DOING THIS. IT WAS
JUST A SMALL PERCENTAGE OF
PEOPLE WHO REALLY WANTED THIS
AND WHY WE ENGAGE IN THIS
PROCESS IN CALIFORNIA- IS A
GOOD FOR THE PROPONENTS ALSO
WANT TO RECALL. ARE YOU KNOW
SOMEONE ARGUED THAT THEY MADE
THAT THEY ALSO WANT TO RECALL
AND REALLY THEY ALSO HAVE ALL
THE RESOURCES. TO MAKE THE
RECALL HAPPENED THAT THE WHOLE
IDEA OF DIRECT GOVERNMENT. THAT
THIS IS THE DESIGN TO DO TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PUBLIC HAD A
VOICE. BUT THAT VOICE NOW IS
BEING DRIVEN BY MONEY MUCH MORE
THAN ANY OTHER THING WITH
REGARDS TO THE INITIATIVE TO
GET TO THE BALLOT. AND THE
RECALL IS ONE OF THOSE- WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT THE FAIRNESS OF THE
SUBJECT ITSELF IT'S A FAIR TO
ACTUALLY RECALL OF AN
INDIVIDUAL WHO HAS BEEN ALREADY
ELECTRIC. AND THERE ISN'T AN
OUTPOURING OF INDIVIDUALS TO
MAKE THAT CHANGE AND IS IT FAIR
TO THE ELECTED OFFICIALS. WHO
CAN ACTUALLY BE RECALL FOR ANY
REASON- AND I SOMETIMES WITHOUT
REASON BECAUSE CONSISTENTLY I
WAS ASKED. TELL CAN YOU TELL ME
THE SPECIFIC REASONS THAT THE
LAW THAT THIS PERSON BROKE.
THAT THE PROBLEMS THAT THEY
CREATED WHAT ARE THAT YOU KNOW
WHAT WHAT LOST BECAUSE PEOPLE
YOU KNOW PEOPLE ARE CUSTOM THE
FACT. THAT THERE IS SOMETHING
THAT YOU DID WRONG THAT THERE
WAS SOMEHOW YOU VIOLATED. YOUR
CODE OF CONDUCT YOUR YOUR YOUR
THE CODE OF CONDUCT OR THE LAWS
THAT WERE IN PLACE WHAT LAW WAS
BROKEN. AND IT WAS DIFFICULT TO
ANSWER THAT QUESTION BE BECAUSE
IT WOULDN'T APPLY. BROKEN AND
IT SAYS IN A LOW THAT YOU CAN
RECALL PERSON. YOU CAN. THE
REASONS WITH THOSE THREE. CAN
NOW BE LIVING. HE NEVER READ
THAT. BY ANYONE ELSE AND SO
THEREFORE. YOU'RE TO DO THAT SO
IT MAY WAYS WE LOOK AT THE- AND
WE START AS A C. CLAUS. WAS A
CALL. KA IN. DO EIGHT RECALL
ELECTION- THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLAR AND I WOULDN'T. ARGUE
THAT THE MARK. HAS A COST TO IT
BECAUSE FAIRNESS IN THE BAR.
HAS NO. AND IT'S WORTH THE-
LEVEL PAY. TO MAKE. IT BUT WHEN
WE ASKED SOME THE OTHER- IT FOR
THE WEB WITH THE GUY. TO THE
MID. OF THE COUNTY. OFFICIALS
TO. THE IN THE- THAT WILL.
DEALING WITH A LOT OF THE YES.
THAT FROM. US BECAUSEMANY OF
THEM HAVE NOT BEEN ADEQUATELY.
IT HAD NOT BEEN ADEQUATELY. ARE
HANDLED IN THE IN THE COURTS OR
EVEN IN THE LEGISLATION THAT
EXISTENCE ITSELF. THIS PRODUCED
A TREMENDOUS NUMBER OF LAWSUITS
FOR US. IN OUR OFFICE IN FACT
WE STILL HAVE SOME THAT REMAIN
TODAY. UP IN THE MIDDLE SCHOOL-
WHO MEDICAID IT WANTED TO
DISCUSS THE RECALL AND WHETHER
NOT THIS. THIS WAS A FAIR AND
JUST PROCESS. MY ONLY CONCERN
WITH A LOT OF THEM WAS THAT WHY
DID YOU TELL ME THIS IN
ADVANCE. IF YOU HAVE SOME
CONSTITUTIONAL REASONS.%
CONCERNING RECALLS THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD HAVE
HAD LOTS OF US. AND HAVE THE
COURTS WEIGH IN ON IT SO EVEN
WITH GOOD REASONS AND GOOD
RECOMMENDATIONS THAT CAME
BEFORE US. THE TIME FRAME WAS
SO SHORT. THAT WE COULD NOT
SPEND OUR TIME BATTLING THIS
PIECE OF LET LEGISLATION WITH
THIS LOSS OF THAT WAS THERE. MY
PRIMARILY BECAUSE OF THE FACT
WE DIDN'T HAVE MUCH TIME TO GET
IT DONE. AND WE HAVE TAKEN THE
NORMAL PROCESS. OF LITIGATION
IT WOULD HAVE BEEN FAR BEYOND
THE DATE FOR THE RECALL FAR
BEYOND EVEN THE PRIMARY THAT WE
WERE ENGAGED. AND SO I
APPRECIATED MANY OF THE-
SCHOLARS IN THE FIELD AND CAME
UP WITH WONDERFUL DISCUSSIONS.
ABOUT WHETHER THAT IS
CONSTITUTIONAL. CAN WE ACTUALLY
DO THERE'S A THERE'S A VIOLATE
THE BASIC. ALL PERCENTAGE OF
THE VOTES. THOSE A WONDERFUL
DISCUSSIONS BUT THERE WAS NO
TIME FOR IT. THERE WAS NO
OPPORTUNITY FOR AND I WISH
THOSE. WHO HAVE SAID IN TWO
THOUSAND THREE. WHEN WE HAD
MANY OF THE CASES DECADES FOR
THE BURDEN VERSUS SHELLEY CASE.
I WISH THEY HAD BASICALLY TO
FOLLOW THROUGH WITH IT. IN TWO
THOUSAND AND TWO THOUSAND FOUR
FIVE OR SIX. SO THAT WE COULD
THEN HAVE BETTER GUIDANCE WITH
REGARDS TO IT SO. WE COULD NOT
HAVE A TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF
GUIDANCE BECAUSE OF THE-
LEGISLATION ITSELF AS TO WHAT
IS REQUIRED- WE COULD WE HAD TO
TEAT THIS GENERAL ELECTION-
AND THAT REALLY WAS ALMOST LIKE
A PRIMARY. I COULD DO ELECTION.
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO SECOND
ELECTION TO BE HELD IN SO ALL
OF THESE THINGS. CREATED
DIFFICULTY FOR THOSE WHO WERE.
TRYING TO EXPLAIN THE PROCESS
THOSE MUSCLE IMPLEMENTING IT.
AND THEN THOSE SCHOLARS WHO
BELIEVE SO STRONGLY IN THE
WHOLE CONCEPT. OF THAT THERE
SHOULD BE A MAJORITY VOTE IN
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS. ARE WE
HAD A NUMBER OF RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT CAME FORWARD TO US ALL OF
THEM. YOU HAVE INDICATED IN
YOUR OWN. A MATERIAL THAT YOU
PUT OUT IN TERMS OF. WHAT IS
APPROPRIATE AND INAPPROPRIATE
AND WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING.
KEEP IN MIND THAT MOST OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS AS ONE THAT WAS
JUST MENTIONED A MINUTE AGO.
REQUIRE MAJOR CHANGE. BECAUSE
WE'VE GROWN FROM ARLINGTON A
GOVERNOR THAT SHE IS NOT WHO
DOESN'T WANT TO BE THAT. THE
PERSON STEPS IN AND- OUT BUT AT
THE SAME TIME- WHAT HAPPENS IF
THERE IS TWO PARTIES IN THE AND
THE DIFFICULTY THAT MIGHT
EXIST. BETWEEN THE DIFFERENT
PARTIES THAT REQUIRES US TO
REALLY LOOK VERY CAREFULLY AT
OUR PROCESS. AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT- OF. THE ACT WE ARE
WILLING TO GO THE FULL WAY IN
TERMS OF MAKING A CHANGE THAT
WOULD THAT WOULD BE CORRECTIVE
SO. WE'RE TALKING ABOUT MAJOR
CONSTITUTIONAL CHANGES. IF WE
START DOWN THIS PATH WITHOUT
REALLY GIVING CAREFUL THOUGHT.
THE OUTCOMES OF EVERY ACTION
THAT WE TAKE. ARM HOLDING A
STATE YOU KNOW LOOKING AT. AND
HOW WE'VE BEEN STANDING UP TO
ELECTIONS AND- AND AFTER THAT
COUNTIES WILL BE A STRONG AND A
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES CAME
THROUGH WITH THAT. BASICALLY
OPERATED OF ELECTION IN A VERY
SHORT PERIOD OF TIME. BUT ALL
OF US HAD GREAT CONCERNS ABOUT
QUALIFICATIONS OF. OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE RUNNING
THE QUALIFICATIONS OF. SIMPLE
BUT THERE WERE NO BETTER
PROCESS THAT WAS NO. NO FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ACTUALLY HEAR THE IN
THE- TO SEE WHAT THEY WERE.
WITH THE FIFTH LARGE ECONOMY IN
THE- IN WILL. AT CHANGE THE
DUMP. WITH SOMEONE COULD HAPPEN
LITTLE AS- FIRST. OF THAT IN
AND THE ONLY WE KNOW SURE. THAT
MOST FOLKS OVER THE- THAT IF WE
REMOVE THIS GOT. IT IS CLEAR WE
WILL HAVE A GOVERNOR WHO DOES
NOT HAVE TO WITHDRAW. VOTE ARE
BECAUSE THERE WAS NO WAY GIVEN
ALL THE THINGS THAT WERE TAKING
PLACE IN THE SHORT TIME FRAME.
WOULD REPAIR THAT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO IT. SO THERE
ARE OTHER OPTIONS AND WE MUST
CONSIDER I THINK IT IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. THAT WE
LOOK AT THE STATE. THAT WE LOOK
AT- THE WHOLE ISSUE OF TWO
SEPARATE ELECTIONS AND SOME
PEOPLE TALK WITH THAT IS.
SPREAD OUT OVER MORE TIME IN
TERMS OF DOING RECALL ELECTED
TO SELECT A REPLACEMENT. ALL
THESE THINGS HAVE TO BE THOUGHT
OUT AND THOUGHT ABOUT IT IN THE
TIME FRAME BECAUSE KEEP IN
MIND. OUR ELECTED OFFICIALS A
CERTAIN FROM FOR YEARS. SO BY
THE TIME WE GET TO THE POINT OF
RECALLS. THERE'S NOT A WHOLE
LOT OF TIME LEFT IN THEIR IN
THEIR OFFICE AND THAT WAS ONE
OF THE CONCERNS PEOPLE REYES.
SAID WE'RE GOING TO HAVE A
RECALL ELECTION SB IN
SEPTEMBER. THEY WERE GOING TO
BASICALLY. THAT ONCE AGAIN HAVE
ANOTHER ELECTION CONCERNING
THIS PERSON IN ANOTHER NINE
MONTHS AND WATER. WELL LET'S
PEOPLE SAID WHAT A WASTE OF
RESOURCES. NONETHELESS IT IS
WHAT WE HAVE TO DO BECAUSE WE
DON'T WITH THE ISSUE SO. LET ME
SAY THAT IN CLOSING I KNOW MY
TIME IS UP- THAT THERE ARE MANY
THINGS THAT WE HAVE TO DO THAT
WITH REGARDS TO THIS THAT WE
COOK. IT IS CLEAR THE
CALIFORNIANS WANT A PROCESS OF
ENGAGEMENT LIKE RECALL OR OR OR
HAVING PETITIONS BUT- AND THIS
IS PUT ON BALLOTS THEY THEY
WANT THIS PROCESS. EVEN NO
MATTER HOW FLAWED IT IS THAT
THEY WANT. BUT IT CAN'T BE A
WHOLE LOT EASIER AND I THINK
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT
THE FACT THAT IT HAS TO HAVE.
MORE TEETH TO- THERE HAS TO BE
MORE DIRECTION TO WHAT. I
PERSONALLY CONSULTING WITH A
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE
CONSTITUTIONAL. ATTORNEYS AS
WELL AS THOSE WHO BEEN IN
POLITICAL OFFICE ON BOTH SIDES
OF. THE AISLE TO ASK THEM
QUESTIONS ABOUT WHAT WE SHOULD
BE DOING CONCERNED. WE CALL.
AND WE WILL. AB HOPEFULLY WE IN
WITH YOUR REGULAR. CONCERNING
WHAT WE SEE. AS THOSE WORDS. OF
THE ELECT. AND NOT JUST MYSELF.
BUT THE RED STROBE. UP AND- THE
STATE. AS TO WHAT WOULD MAKE IT
A FAIR. CLEAR ACROSS. SINCE
PEOPLE. PURCHASE IN. AND TO DO
THIS. KEEP IN MIND THAT. THOUGH
WE ONLY SEEN A FEW. IN TERMS OF
THE- PLEASE. WE ARE SEEING A-
OF RECALL ACROSS THE STATE AND
YOU NEED TO UNDERSTAND. THAT
THAT WERE WE TO SEE IT. NOW AND
THEN. WE STILL WE HAVE I THINK
FIVE SIX SEVEN OF THOSE THIS
YEAR. WE HAVE ANOTHER FORTY
YEARS UP TO GOAL. ARE WE WOULD
HAVE ANOTHER ISSUE THAT WILL BE
COMING IN AND WE HAVE RECALLS
PREPARE FOR TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
VERSUS COUNTY VERSES. OF VERSUS
STATE IN TERMS OF
QUALIFICATIONS FOR BALLOTS.
ASKED WITH FINDING THAT PEOPLE
HAVE DONE. SIX SIX MONTHS IN
OFFICE AND IMMEDIATELY PEOPLE
WANT TO RECALL THEM. AND THE
PEOPLE WANT TO CALL THEM OF THE
SAME PEOPLE WHO VOTE. WITHIN
BOTH OF THEM IN THE FIRST
PLACE. SO THIS IS BECOME AN
ISSUE. AND IT GOES ON AND ON
AND I'VE SEEN FOLKS WITH TWO
DIFFERENT RECALL PETITIONS
AGAINST THEM. ALREADY AND SO IT
HAS BECOME. A GREAT CONCERN IN
MY MIND SIMPLY BECAUSE THE
PEOPLE ARE USING THIS. TO GET
AROUND THE PROCESS THAT
IMMEDIATELY. THEY THEY GO TO
RECALL. AND IF AND IF THE
RESOURCE IS A RIGHT IN TERMS OF
THE MONEY TO. FOR THOSE WHO CAN
COLLECT PETITIONS. ASSIGNED
POSITIONS AND WHAT HAVE YOU. WE
DISCOVER THAT RECALLS ARE
OCCURRING SO I AM CONCERNED.
THAT MANY RECALLS ARE CURRENT
SCHOOL BOARD'S BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS CITY COUNCILS. OF
SEVERAL IN MY CITY OF SAN
DIEGO. HE WAS ADOPTED FOR
RECALLS THAT THEY NEVER WOULD
HAVE TAKEN OUT SOME YEARS AGO.
SO NOW WE GOT TO ASK OURSELVES
THE QUESTION. THAT THIS THING
THAT WAS ONCE A VERY RARE. AND
UNUSUAL IS BECOMING THE NORM.
AND WE WANTED TO BECOME THE
NORM. BECAUSE IF WE DEAL THEN
WAS SOMEHOW THE CONSTANTLY.
ATTACKING IN INVALIDATING
ELECTIONS THAT HAVE OCCURRED.
ONLY BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE DECIDE
THEY DON'T LIKE A DECISION THAT
WAS MADE. WE DON'T HAVE A
REASON FOR. MY OFTENTIMES
PEOPLE ARE SAYING TO ME
CONSISTENTLY. YOU'VE ALSO GOT A
PROCESS WHERE PEOPLE HAVE TO
BRING THE CHARGES. IN CONCERNS.
ARE AND- AND THEN AS BASED ON
THAT ARE NOT TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH THE PURCHASE. OF THAT
TAKES TIME TO. AND BUT
NONETHELESS FOLKS FEEL THAT
MAYBE. BECAUSE IT IS AN
EXPLANATION AS TO WHAT HAPPEN
THIS RECALL. SO ONCE AGAIN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND-
PREPARED AS ANYONE HAS A
QUESTION- I DON'T HAVE. THE
ANSWER TO. THESE QUESTIONS BUT
I DO KNOW. THAT THERE ARE A LOT
OF CONCERNS ABOUT OUR RECALL
PROCESS AND WHILE PEOPLE ARE
THINKING ABOUT IT. WE NEED TO
MOVE FORWARD WITH MAKING SOME
OF THE NATION'S UNLIKE WE DID
IN TWO THOUSAND AND THREE.
SECRETARY WEBER. THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
THERE MAY BE SOME QUESTIONS IF
YOU COULD STAND BY. LET ME JUST
NOTE DOLLAR PRECIADO SHOULD.
FOR THE DEEP BUT CONSUL TATIAN
THAT YOU ARE ENGAGED IN A WE
LOOK FOR TO GETTING YOUR
FEEDBACK. THROUGHOUT DELIVERED
PROCESS. AND APPRECIATE THAT.
AND LET ME JUST TAKE THE PRAGUE
OF THE FOR JUST A- AND THANK
YOU TO YOU. FOR THE- X.
ADVENTIST. OF THIS. THE UNDER.
TO TIMES. AS YOU SO NOTED. NOT
JUST YOUR OFFICE. AND YOUR
LEADERSHIP BUT TO THE FIFTY
EIGHT THE CLERKS AND REGISTRARS
AROUND THE STATE. WHO REALLY
HAD TO WORK VERY VERY HARD TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE ELECTION.
WAS DONE APPROPRIATELY AND IT
WAS DONE FAIRLY. HONESTLY AND
APPROPRIATELY AND WE'RE VERY
VERY GRATEFUL. COLLEAGUES WANT
TO SEE. QUESTIONS FOR THE
SECRETARY BEFORE WE LET HER GO-
NUMBERS ANY QUESTIONS. NOW YES
SIR OKAY- SECTOR WEBER YOU AND
TALKED ABOUT THE AMOUNT OF
RECALLS THAT ARE ARE HAPPENING
AND SOME RESEARCH INDICATES I
WE HAD A HUNDRED AND SEVENTY
NINE ATTEMPTS SINCE NINETEEN
THIRTEEN THANKS CORRECT. STE
YES I THINK SO YES OKAY AND OF
THOSE ATTEMPTS. ELEVEN
QUALIFIED FOR BALLOT. RIGHT SO
TAKING OUT PAPERS TO DO A
RECALL DOESN'T TRANSLATE INTO A
RECALL EFFORT AND IT DOESN'T
TRANSLATE INTO THE COSTS THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT MUCH OF
WHICH IS THERE ARE A LOT OF
WHICH IS THE MAILIN BALLOTS- I
BELIEVE THOSE ARE WHAT THREE
DOLLARS APIECE TO SEND OUT. AND
GET BACK. YES YEAH. SO WHAT WE
HAVE 51% TURNOUT THAT MEANS 49%
OF THOSE BALLOTS- WERE
ESSENTIALLY NOT USED. IN
ANOTHER 58% TURNOUT FIFTY EIGHT
PERCENT. NOW INCLUDES 42% OF
THOSE WEREN'T USED WHICH IS
ADDING TO THE COST SO I SHARE
YOUR CONCERNS ABOUT HAVING TO-
TWO SEPARATE ELECTIONS BECAUSE
THAT'S JUST DOUBLING THE AMOUNT
OF. OF COSTLY HABIT SOME OF
THAT IS SELF INFLICTED. SOME OF
THOSE- THEY QUALIFIED ABOUT TWO
OF THEM WERE FOR GOVERNOR
CORRECT. YES SO THOSE TO MISTER
DAVIS BACK GOVERNOR DAVIS AND
THEN THIS ONE. AND THIS ONE
PROBABLY WOULD NOT HAVE
QUALIFIED IF THE JUDICIARY
SYSTEM DIDN'T REQUIRE AN
ADDITIONAL. I THINK IT WAS FOR
THREE MONTHS- HELP YEAH TWENTY
DAYS. YES SO THIS ONE WOULDN'T
QUALIFY TO DOESN'T SOUND LIKE
IT'S AN EASY PROCESS AT ALL. IT
SOUNDS LIKE IT'S A VERY
DIFFICULT PROCESS. I WOULD
NEVER SAY IT YOU'RE RIGHT
YOU'RE CORRECT I NEVER SAY THAT
THAT THE INITIATIVE PROCESS IS
EASY IT IS MADE EASIER BY THOSE
WHO CAN HIRE PEOPLE TO COLLECT
SIGNATURES IS NO QUESTION ABOUT
THAT ALL BUT IT'S NOT AN EASY
PROCESS BECAUSE YOU STILL HAVE
TO COLLECT THE SIGNATURES AND
IT'S EXPENSIVE TO COLLECT
SIGNATURES YES AND IT LOOKS
LIKE ELEVEN ELEVEN TIMES IN A
HUNDRED YEARS. THAT HAPPENED
THEY WERE ABLE TO COLLECT
ENOUGH SIGNATURES SO THAT'S
RIGHT BUT KEEP IT OPEN WE SEE
THE PROLIFERATION OF FOLKS
TAKING OUT A BALLOTS NOW OR
TAKING UP POSITIONS NOW RECALL
MUCH MORE THAN THAT HE SAID YOU
HAD A HUNDRED AND SOME LOT OR
ALMOST A HUNDRED YEARS. THAT
NUMBER IS BEING IT IS
INCREASING- RIGHT NOW AS WE
SPEAK WITH THE NUMBER OF
RECALLS THAT ARE THAT THE
PETITIONS ARE BEING TAKEN OUT
NO QUESTION RULES I THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE YOUR- YOUR EXPERTISE
ON THE SITUATION THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY. RATA AT YOUR BERMAN
WITH A FOLLOW UP QUESTION
THANKS JUST SPEAKING OF THE
PROLIFERATION OF THIS OF
RECALLS QUALIFYING DUTCH WEBER
ALL RIGHT THAT THAT JOY LEVIN
HAVE QUALIFIED IN IN A HUNDRED
AND TEN YEARS BUT BUT THREE OF
THOSE QUALIFIED IN IN THE FIRST
FEW YEARS THAT THE RECALL
EXISTED- AND THEN EIGHT OF THE
ELEVEN HAVE QUALIFIED IN THE
LAST TWENTY. SEVEN YEARS. IS
THAT CORRECT SO WE- THREE
RECALLS. IN THE FIRST EIGHTY SO
ODD YEAR- BUT EIGHT. QUALIFY IN
THE LAST TWENTY SEVEN YEARS.
RIGHT SO WE'RE DEFINITELY
SUCCEED LIKE YOU WERE SAYING
SEEING AN INCREASE IN THE
QUALIFICATION NOT AN INCREASE
IN THE IN THE UTILIZATION OF
THIS TACTIC- BYE BYE FOLKS- IN
IN STATEWIDE AND ALSO IN
CERTAIN COMMUNITIES ACROSS THE
STATE. RIGHT WE HAVE AND WE
HAVE RECALLS THAT WOULD BETTER
QUALIFIED TO THIS YEAR WELL
THAT RECALLS IN TWENTY TWENTY
TWO ARE READY FOR THEM QUALIFY.
AND WE CURRENTLY HAVE FORTY
UNDERWAY RIGHT NOW IN THE STATE
IN TERMS OF PEOPLE COLLECTING
SIGNATURES AGAINST LOCAL
OFFICIALS SO WE ARE WE'RE
SAYING TO INCREASE OF UP AS AS
I TALK TO BRIDGE TROUBLED TO
SEE AN INCREASE IN PEOPLE
COMING IN TO TAKE APPLICATIONS.
ARE AND THOSE AND OBVIOUSLY IF
YOU LOOK AT THE HUNDRED YEARS
YOU SAY OKAY YEAH HUNDRED
SOMETHING IN A HUNDRED YEARS
IT'S PROBABLY A ONCE A YEAR
BUT- YOU'RE HAVING MUCH MORE
THAN THAT RIGHT NOW. THANKS ARE
DUE OVER SIX ALL RIGHT I THANK
EACH YEAR BERMAN- ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FOR THE SECRETARY.
ALL RIGHT SEE NOT SECRETARY
WEBER AGAIN OUR THANKS FOR. ALL
THAT YOU DO IN YOUR TESTIMONY
TODAY AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH YOU. IN THE MONTHS
AHEAD THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK
YOU YOU TAKE HERE HAVE A GOOD
MEETING OKAY SO WE'RE- GONNA.
TO OUR NEXT WITH. US MICK FEAR.
A SUPER. MCPHERSON WAS FIRST
ELECTED TO THE SANTA CRUZ
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE. REELECTED
IN 200-016-2000 TWENTY. HE
CURRENTLY SERVES AS CHAIR OF
THE BOARD. HE PERMIT PREVIOUSLY
SERVED TWO TERMS IN THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY. AND
TO TERMS AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE. BEFORE BEING
NAMED BY GOVERNOR
SCHWARZENEGGER AS CALIFORNIA'S.
SECRETARY OF STATE. I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US
SUPERVISOR. MCPHERSON AND WE
WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY TODAY. I
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TO
PARTICIPATE IN TODAY'S-
INFORMATIONAL HEARING ON OUR-
STATE PROCEDURE FOR RECALL
INDIVIDUALS. WHETHER IT'S
ACCEPTABLE NOW WERE AND WHAT IF
ANY CHANGES SHOULD BE MADE TO
APPROVE SYSTEM. OXEN HONORED TO
BE HERE WITH SECRETARY OF STATE
ARCHERY WEBER. I WANT MY TWO OF
MY FORMER LEGISLATIVE COLLEAGUE
STYLE SENATOR WHAT'S GOOD YEAH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM KINNEY.
AFTER GRADUATIONS CHIU THE
SENATE AND SOME ELECTIONS
COMMITTEE STAFF TO PARTICULAR
QUALITY OVERVIEW OF THE RECALL
PROCESS. WORKS VERY WELL DONE-
I'M GOING TO BE FOCUSING ON
THAT YEP THE OFFICE OF
GOVERNOR- AND REALIZED THAT
THAT THERE ARE SEVERAL OTHER
LOCAL RACES THAT ARE UP. FOR
GRABS SO TO SPEAK- SUBJECT TO
RECALL- BACK THROUGH THE MOST
OFTEN SUGGESTED CHANGES IN
TODAY'S SYSTEM. ARE TO INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF SIGNATURES TO
QUALIFY THE RECALL FOR THE
BALLOT SHORTEN THE TIME FRAME.
TO ACQUIRE THOSE SIGNATURES. OR
SOMEHOW REDUCE THE COST TO THE
PUBLIC. TO CARRY OUT THE RECALL
PROCESS. I DO BELIEVE THAT-
THOSE WHO WANT TO. THE SHOULD
IT. THE OTHER END OF THE- THERE
SHOULD BE SOME SOLID EVIDENCE
OF MALFEASANCE OF THE- WHICH
AFFECTED THE RECALL. BEFORE THE
PROCESS START- ONLY SB NO ONLY
TO RECALL HIM AGAIN I'M
FOCUSING ON THE GOVERNOR OF
QUALIFIED NOT PASSED HUNDRED
YEARS. ONE SITUATED AND ONE
DIDN'T AND EVEN IN THE
SUCCESSFUL ONE THE REPLACEMENT
DIDN'T GET A MAJORITY OF THE
VOTE. A REAL SHORTFALL I THINK
IN TODAY'S SYSTEM IS THAT AN
OPPONENT RUNNING TO REPLACE
INCUMBENT. MAY ONLY GET A
FRACTION OF THE VOTE COMPARED
TO THE ONE WHO WAS RECALL.
RECALL VOTE MAYBE FIFTY POINT
ONE PERCENT. AND THE NEW
GOVERNOR ONE OF THIRTY FORTY
FIFTY PEOPLE WHO WANT TO SEE
HER NAME ON THE BALLOT- THEY-
THEY BECOME THE WINNING OPTIONS
SO TO SPEAK WITH TWENTY OR 30%
OF THE VOTE. A CORRECTION TO
THIS COULD BE TO HAVE. TO SEE
ELECTION PROCESS IN WHICH THE
RECALL INCUMBENT RUNS AGAINST
THE TOP VOTE GETTER OF THE
CHALLENGERS ANY SUBSEQUENT
ELECTION. THAT'S MORE TIME MORE
COST. OF I'M NOT SUGGESTING
THIS- JUST TRYING TO THINK. OF
THE BIG PROBLEMS THAT WERE
PROCESS. FROM THE PUBLIC- WHO
REALLY. ARE PRESUMABLY WANTS
CHANGES. BACK TO RECALL. THE
JURY ORDERS FOR THE RECALL AND-
INDISCRIMINATE DATA PUBLIC
THAT'S ALSO RUNNING OUT OF
PATIENCE. I'M OPTION BE ROUGHLY
BE ALLOW THE BRIEF. I'VE GOT TO
APPEAR ON A SECOND QUESTION ON
THE RECALL BALLOT. IF YOU'RE C.
GETS THE MOST VOTES ON THE
SECOND QUESTION HERE SHE STAYS
IN OFFICE- ANOTHER SUGGESTION.
SPEAKING IN TERMS OF THE
GUBERNATORIAL RECALL IS TO HAVE
THE GOVERNOR AND THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR REQUESTED CHECK IT IN
THE FIRST PLACE IT'S BEEN
SUGGESTED- IF THE GOVERNOR'S
RECALLED. GOVERNOR BECOMES
GOVERNOR. BUT THAT MISSES THE
POINT THAT IF THE CONTENT
GOVERNOR'S SAME PARTY AS THE
RECALL ELECTED NEW GOVERNOR
MUCH OF THE- PUBLIC WILL SAY
THIS CONTINUES THE SAME. POLICY
AS GOVERNOR WHO WAS JUST
RECALLED. THE GOAL SHOULD BE TO
ENCOURAGE VOTERS TO SAVE THE
RECALL FOR CRIMINAL ACTIVITY OR
MALFEASANCE RATHER THAN BECAUSE
OF. OPPOSITION S. DIRECTLY
ATTENDED GOVERNOR'S CALIFORNIA
GET VERY LITTLE ATTENTION FROM
THE GOVERNOR DEMOCRAT OR
REPUBLICAN SOMETIMES. I EVEN
BEING IN DIFFERENT PARTIES AND
THE GENERAL PUBLIC HAS VERY
LITTLE KNOWLEDGE KNOWLEDGE OF
WHETHER THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
YES OF THE STATE ON THE SAME
PAGE AS THE GOVERNOR ON
CRITICAL ISSUES OF THE DAY. AND
FINALLY COST ABOUT HOW TO SAVE
ELECTION CROSS YEAH IT WAS
UNBELIEVABLE THREE HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS WERE SPENT ON
THIS- BUT THAT'S THE PROCESS WE
HAPPENED WHAT WHAT BE SURE WHAT
WHAT IT TAKES TO GET SOMETHING.
ON THE BALLOT THE SYSTEM AS WE
KNOW IT TODAY TO TAKE PLACE.
BUT IF A RECALL IS APPROVED. AB
ONE TEN A COVER BECOME THE
INTERIM GOVERNOR. SUBSEQUENT
ELECTION FOR GOVERNOR WOULD BE
REQUIRED NOT PERMITTED AS IN
STATE LAW NOW REQUIRED IN THE
NEXT REGULARLY SCHEDULED
GENERAL ELECTION. THE PROBLEM
MY DATA PUBLIC HAS A PATIENTS
AGAIN TO WAIT FOR THE NEXT
GENERAL ELECTION TO ELECT A NEW
GOVERNMENT. SO I'M JUST BRIEFLY
AND WRAP IT UP I DON'T BELIEVE
THE CURRENT RECALL. PROCESS IS
PERFECT BUT I THE VOICE OF THE
VOTING PUBLIC. SHOULD BE HEARD
AND THEY HAVE A TRUE GOD AND
BELIEVE IT'S ABOUT THE
ACTIVITIES OF THE INCUMBENT.
THEY SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO GO
THROUGH A RECALL PRESS PROCESS.
I HAVEN'T SEEN AS WAS MENTIONED
BY SECRETARY WEBER. THE GROUP
OPTION TO DATE RECALL PROCESS
THAT WOULD BE ACCEPTABLE AND
ACCEPTABLE. TO WHAT WE HAVE
TODAY. I DO BELIEVE THAT ANY
CHANGES SHOULD BE- HAVE
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. BY THE
PUBLIC ONCE THAT THE AND THIS
THIS ISSUE DESERVES THAT. UNDER
THE CIRCUMSTANCES ANSWER AND
CERTAINLY IF WE DO PUT
SOMETHING ON THE- BALLOT AND
THE BALLOT TO CHANGE ITS
CONSTITUTION. KEEP IT SIMPLE
AND FRANKLY I DON'T KNOW HOW
YOU'RE GONNA DO THAT IT'S GOING
TO BE GREAT DIFFICULT. BUT IT'S
GREAT FORWARD SO PEOPLE THINK
THEY'RE UNSURE AREN'T OUT THERE
YOU PROBABLY GET A VOTE NO.
THAT'S JUST THE HISTORY OF THE
BOAT. SO THAT'S A REAL QUICK
SUMMARY OF MARKET- OVERVIEW AND
I'M JUST AS I SAID POSTING ON
THE GOVERNOR. THE OFFICE OF
GOVERNOR- UP BUT DIED BECAUSE
THAT WAS WITH THE MOST RECENT
RECALL WEEK REPORTS WE HAD TO
GO THROUGH BUT THERE'S SOME
SEVERAL PENDING. I THINK THIS
IS SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
ADDRESSED AND- IT'S A
PARTICULARLY IN EFFORT TO GET
IT RIGHT AND I WISH EVERYONE
THE BEST AND THAT WOULD BE GLAD
TO. PARTICIPATE NAY OF POSSIBLE
SOLUTIONS THAT I CAN HELP IN
ANY WAY THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU SUPERVISOR MCPHERSON
AND- CERTAINLY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SERVICES- ISAAC AS
CALIFORNIA SECRETARY OF STATE-
I WANT TO. ALL LACK. THAT NOTE
THAT YOU. A DOLLAR ONE OF THE
EXCELLENT ANALYSIS THAT WAS PER
BY A STAFF THANK YOU TO BOTH
STAFF AND THE SIDES AND UP TO
THE MEMBERS OF PUBLIC- CAN HAVE
ACCESS TO THAT AND THE DATA AND
FACT THAT IT PROVIDES CERTAINLY
FROM OUR WEBSITE IN THE
ASSEMBLY OR THE SENATE
APPRECIATE YOU POINTING THAT
OUT. I ALSO APPRECIATE YOU
POINTING OUT THAT YOUR DESIRE
TO. SEARCH FOR A BI PARTISAN
SOLUTION. THAT THAT THERE'S
WAYS TO MAKE THIS PROCESS
BETTER. AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
SUGGESTIONS. YOU DID NOT SPEAK
TO THE SIGNATURE REQUIREMENT
THAT'S CURRENTLY AT LAW IS
THERE ANY COMMENT YOU HAVE ON
THAT. FOR ME- I YEAH I THINK
YOU'RE GREAT THE ONLY WAY TO UP
SHOWN MORE RECALLS FROM TAKING
PLACES TO INCREASE THE NUMBER
THAT REQUIRE OUT FROM FROM THE
TESTING LAW- THERE ARE TO BE A
REASON FOR THAT- I THINK IT
MAYBE TO. LOOK AT HOW MANY
VOTES ARE- MADE FOR RECALL AND
KEEPER AN OFFICER UP THERE IN
THIS CASE THE GOVERNOR IN
OFFICE COMPARED TO THE RECENT
PAST OF PROBABLY HALF THE VOTER
LAST OF THOSE WHO WOULD TAKE
THAT THAT- GOVERNOR'S. PLACE I
THINK THAT. WE SHOULD IT. DOUBT
PEOPLE TO I WELL I WOULDN'T THE
ID OF REDUCING THE NUMBER OF.
REQUIRED I THINK THAT WOULD
GIVE MORE. IT'S NOT EASY TO DO
SO NOW BUT I DO I DO BELIEVE
THAT- THAT WOULD BE. A LOGICAL
WAY TO- SHE WAS A TONE DOWN THE
RECALL PROCESS BUT AGAIN I WHAT
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE. THAT WITH
A FOCUS BE ON SOME OF.
MALFEASANCE OFFICE OF SOME TYPE
OR PERSON IS RECALL THAT'S
GONNA BE HARD TO DETERMINE
PROBABLY HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
COURT PROCESS. TRAFFIC ON TO
SEE IF THAT COLLEAGUES HAVE ANY
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS. I'M A GOOD
QUESTION ONLY NUMBER SIR ON
YOUR YOUR COMMENT ABOUT
MALFEASANCE. YEAH IS THAT LEGAL
MALFEASANCE OR IS THAT ETHICAL
MALFEASANCE BECAUSE MALFEASANCE
CAN BE WOULD MEAN ONE THING TO
THE LEGAL COMMUNITY BETTER CAN
MEAN AN ENTIRELY DIFFERENT
THING TO CITIZENS OUT THERE WHO
FEEL LIKE THEY'RE THEY'RE
REPRESENTATIVES NOT ACTING IN
THEIR BEST INTEREST ANYMORE TO
THEM THAT'S MALFEASANCE SO WHAT
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT LEGAL.
DEFINITION WELL I THINK IN
LEGAL I'M ONLY I'VE BEEN IN THE
NEWSPAPER BUSINESS AND I'VE
BEEN IN POLITICS I'M NOT A
LAWYER BUT I WOULD DOUBT. I
WILL TAKE THAT INTO
CONSIDERATION THAT WOULD HAVE
TO GO THROUGH A LEGAL PROCESS
TO SOME TYPE BOB BUT NOW AGAIN
THAT TIME AND- WE'RE TALKING
SOMETHING WE WANT TO GET
RESOLVED- WITHIN YOU KNOW BOB.
THREE TO SIX MONTHS AT THE MOST
UNDER CONDITIONS I'D MENTION
ABOUT LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
TAKING COVERED SPOT AND THEN
HAVING THAT SUBSEQUENT ELECTION
POSSIBLY BUT- I THINK THAT THAT
THERE WOULD HAVE TO BE SOME
PROOF OF MALFEASANCE- JENNIFER.
OKAY THANK YOU TERRIFIC ANY
FURTHER. FOR SUPERVISOR
MCPHERSON. ALL RIGHT SEEN
UNSUPERVISED MACPHERSON THANK
YOU FOR PARTICIPATING IN OUR
HEARING TODAY I KNOW CENTER
NIELSEN AND I BOTH LOVE IT WHEN
FORMER CENTERS COME BACK- LOOK
TO THE RED CARPET ALTHOUGH WE
HAVE GREEN CARPET HERE IN THIS
ROOM. TO SHARE THEIR EXPERTISE
AND- AND WISDOM WITH US SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH WE REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. OKAY ALL RIGHT
SO WE'RE GOING TO MOVE FORWARD
WITH OUR NEXT WITNESS- IT'S
FORMER SENATOR MARTHA STUDIA. A
SENATOR ESTUDIOS CURRENTLY VICE
PRESIDENT FOR GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA POSITION
SHE'S HELD SINCE TWO THOUSAND
THIRTEEN- PRIOR TO SIZE SERVING
AS A- AT U. S. C. SHE WAS A
PARTNER AT THE SENATORS A LAW
AND CONSULTING FIRM SHE CO
FOUNDED. CENTER STUDIO IS A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
SENATE FROM NINETEEN NINETY
EIGHT TO TWO THOUSAND SIX
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY FROM NINETEEN NINETY
TWO TO NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT.
WAS THE FIRST WOMAN CHAIR OF
BOTH THE ASSEMBLY AND THE
SENATE JUDICIARY COMMITTEES
SENATOR A STUDIO WELCOME. TO
OUR JOINT HEARING AND WE
WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS MIKE THIS
COULD BE AND IT REALLY IS A
PLEASURE TO BE BACK HERE- BACK
AT LEAST YOU KNOW THROUGH.
KNOWN TO BE BACK IN THAT
BEAUTIFUL. ROOM AND OF COURSE
FOR ME IT'S WONDERFUL TO EVEN
SEEING. MY FORMER COLLEAGUES
BRUCE BRUCE AND JIMMY- IT'S
JUST A PLEASURE TO SEE THEM-
THIS IS A VERY INTERESTING
QUESTION THAT I WAS ASKED TO.
GIVE MY PERSONAL OPINION NOT
USC'S OPINION MY PERSONAL
OPINION. AND I'M TAKING IT
RATHER SERIOUSLY AS A LAWYER.
THAT'S THE FORMER CHAIR OF THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE'S. AND THAT
IS YOU KNOW- WHY THE RECALL.
AND I SPEAK FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF HAVING BEEN
THROUGH A PREVIOUS RECALL. WHEN
GOVERNOR DAVIS WAS RECALL. AND
THEN OBVIOUSLY NOW AS A CITIZEN
I WANT ANOTHER RECALL WHEN THE
WITH ATTEMPT TO RECALL GOVERNOR
NEWSOM. BUT I ALWAYS ASK WHY
THE RECALL SO WHEN I DID MY
RESEARCH ON THE REASONS WHY THE
PROPONENTS. FILED A RECALL
PETITION AGAINST GOVERNOR
NEWSOM. IN FEBRUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY. I REMEMBER THAT WAS
QUITE GOOD FOR THE ECONOMY THE
ECONOMY SHUT DOWN. BECAUSE THE
COBIT. BUT AS THE FAVORITE
TWENTY TWENTY THE REASONS
ASSERTED AND I'M GOING TO JUST.
YOU KNOW MENTION SOME OF THEM
WAS THEM. THAT THE GOVERNOR HAS
IMPLEMENTED LAWS. WHICH ARE
DETRIMENTAL TO THE CITIZENS OF
THIS STATE AND OUR WAY OF LIFE.
THAT LAWS THAT HE ENDORSED. A
COUNTRY ILLEGALLY. OVER THAT OF
OUR OWN CITIZENS- THAT HE
UNILATERALLY OVERRULE THE WILL
OF THE PEOPLE WITH REGARD TO
THE DEATH PENALTY. AND HE ALSO
IMPOSE ADDITIONAL BURDENS ON
OUR STATE. BY REMOVING
PROTECTIONS OF PROP THIRTEEN.
RATIONING WATER USE- AS WELL AS
THEM THE CLEARING- IMPOSING A
CENTURY STATE STATUS. ON
CALIFORNIA. AND IT GOES FURTHER
ON- SO. ATTENTION TO THE YOU
KNOW BECAUSE WHEN I THAT. TO ME
IT SOUNDS LIKE A- TO. WITH A
DULY ELECTED OFFICER A DULY
ELECTED GOVERNOR. BUT
ULTIMATELY THE QUESTION IS
WHETHER THAT IS EIGHT RECALL
ADULTS OFFENSE. AND WHAT STATUS
DO WE HAVE RIGHT NOW US POLICY
MAKERS AND EVEN US AS CITIZENS
WHAT STATUS DO WE HAVE TO GUIDE
US. AS TO WHAT IS A RECALL
OFFENSE. AND FROM THE INITIAL
RESEARCH THAT I HAVE DONE- I
REALLY HAVEN'T FOUND MUCH
INFORMATION. SO I STARTED
LOOKING AT DIFFERENT SCENARIOS
AND RIGHT AWAY I LOOKED AT THE-
THE STATUTORY SCHEME FOR THE
REMOVAL OF FEDERAL JUDGES. NOW
GRANTED FEDERAL JUDGES ARE
APPOINTED GRANTED THEIR
APPOINTED FOR LIFE AND GRANTED
WE HAVE TO ENSURE THEIR
IMPARTIALITY. BUT THE STANDARD
TO REMOVE A FEDERAL JUDGE IS
VERY HIGH IT BASICALLY AMOUNTS.
TO- EIGHT AM. GET A BASICALLY
THIS EIGHT DISAVOWAL WITH YOU
KNOW THE TREASON PART OF
BRIBERY AND OTHER HIGH CRIMES
AND MISDEMEANORS. BUT
UNFORTUNATELY I OUR OWN U. S.
CONSTITUTION IS SILENT AS TO
HOW YOU WOULD DEFINE ESPECIALLY
HIGH CRIMES. HIGH CRIMES AND
MISDEMEANORS IT'S NOT VERY
CLEAR WHAT'S INTERESTING IS
THAT WHEN I WAS DOING RESEARCH
ON THE REMOVAL OF FEDERAL
JUDGES IT TURNS OUT THAT I
FOUND OUT THAT FORMER CHIEF
JUSTICE. WILLIAM REHNQUIST
ACTUALLY WROTE A BOOK ABOUT THE
REMOVAL OF FEDERAL JUDGES. AND
HE CONCLUDED THAT THE EARLY
USES OF IMPEACHMENT TO REMOVE
FEDERAL JUDGES. HAVE
ESTABLISHED A NOR. THE NORM
BEING THAT JUDICIAL ACTS THAT
THE LEGAL RULINGS FROM THE
BENCH WILL NEVER BE A BASIS FOR
REMOVAL FROM OFFICE. SO
BASICALLY THAT MEANS THAT IF
LITIGANTS ARE NOT HAPPY WITH
THE OUTCOME OF THE CASE. THOSE
WOULD NOT BE THE GROUNDS TO
REMOVE A UDGE THE ONLY OPTION
IS TO APPEAL THE DECISION. SO
IN THE RECALL SITUATION THAT WE
ARE DISCUSSING RIGHT NOW. IF
THE RECALL PROPONENTS WERE
UNHAPPY WITH THE LAWS THAT
GOVERN A NUISANCE SIGN THEM THE
PROPER REMEDY WOULD BE TO GO TO
COURT. TO SEEK AN INJUNCTION
AND TO BASICALLY STOP THOSE
LAWS FROM TAKING EFFECT THAT'S
THE PROPER REAP A REMEDY. SO
BASICALLY WHAT I'M GOING TO
SUGGEST HONORABLE MEMBERS IS
KIND OF FOLLOWING UP ON WHAT MY
DEAR FRIEND BRUCE MCPHERSON
MENTION WHICH IT HAS TO BE SOME
TYPE OF MALFEASANCE AND GRANTED
THERE'S FRANKLY NOT DEFINITION
OF TO HELP MALFEASANCE- IS
DESCRIBE WHAT'S WHAT'S THE
CHECKLIST. SO WHAT I STARTED
DOING WAS IDENTIFY STATES. THAT
HAVE RECALL STATUTES BUT ONLY
FOR CLAUSE. AND I THINK THERE'S
ABOUT ELEVEN ELEVEN OF THEM IN
THE COUNTRY OF WHICH ONE OF.
THEM IS THE STATE OF GEORGIA.
NOW THE STATUS OF DRAW SAYS
GROUNDS FOR RE IN. THAT THE
OFFICIAL HAS COME AND- OF
MALFEASANCE WHILE IN OFFICE. TO
THE OFFICIAL VIOLATED THE OATH
OF OFFICE. THREE THE OFFICIAL
HAS COMMITTED AN ACT OF
MISCONDUCT IN OFFICE. FOR THE
OFFICIALS GUILTY OF THE FAILURE
TO PERFORM DUTIES PRESCRIBED BY
LAW. AND FIVE THE OFFICIAL HAS
WILLFULLY WILLFULLY MISCUES
CONVERTED OR MISAPPROPRIATED
WITHOUT AUTHORITY PUBLIC
PROPERTY OR PUBLIC FUNDS
ENTRUSTED TO THAT OFFICIAL. NOW
THE GREAT THING ABOUT THIS.
ABOUT THIS FOR COST REQUIREMENT
IN GEORGIA IS THAT IT ALSO HAS
AN INTERMEDIATE INTERMEDIATE
PROCESS AND THAT IS THAT
THERE'S GOT TO BE A LEGAL
ADJUDICATION BY A JUDGE. AS TO
WHETHER COST DOES EXIST IN THIS
DIVISIONAL ADJUDICATION OF COST
FOR A RECALL WHICH I REALLY
THINK IT'S A WORTHY IDEA TO
ALSO INCLUDE YOUR IN YOUR
DISCUSSIONS. IT WOULD BASICALLY
ALLOW THE JUDGE. WHICH I TRULY
THAT IT SUMPAH. I'M GRANTED%
SOME PEOPLE MAY ARGUE THAT
POLITICAL BUT YOU KNOW WHAT YOU
KNOW ALMOST VERYTHING IN LIFE
IS POLITICAL BUT I HAVE BIG
BELIEF IN THE JUDICIARY. I'M IF
WE HAVE JUDICIAL EDUCATION
EDUCATION AS TO WHETHER BECAUSE
EXISTS. THEN IT BASICALLY
PROVIDES GUARDRAILS TO THE
WHOLE CONCEPT OF RECALL I DON'T
THINK ANYONE IS HEE TO SAY WE
DON'T LIKE RECALLS I DON'T
THINK ANYONE IS HERE TO STAY.
LET'S DESTROY THIS VERSION OF
DIRECT DEMOCRACY BUT I THINK
PEOPLE ARE HERE TO SAY THAT
LET'S PUT SOME SOME GUARD
RAILS. AROUNDTHIS. EXERCISE IN
DIRECT DEMOCRACY SO THAT RECALL
INSTEAD BE A REMEDY THAT IS
JUDICIOUSLY USED. NOT ****
NILLY BUT RATHER JUDICIOUSLY
USED PREFERABLY FOR BECAUSE THE
HAS BEEN ADJUDICATED. BY A
JUDGE FINALLY I'M SECRETARY
STATE YOU KNOW OBVIOUSLY
MENTION THE COSTS. OF A RECALL
AND THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION
DOLLARS TO ME IS JUST AMAZING
BECAUSE OF CALIFORNIA IS
ENGAGING IN A RECOVERY IT'S
STILL VERY MUCH A LOPSIDED
RECORD ECONOMIC RECOVERY. OF
THE HAS A RECOVERING VERY
NICELY BUT THE HAVE NOTS ARE
STILL SUFFERING FROM JOB
INSECURITY EDUCATIONAL
LEGALIZATION BROADBAND
MARGINALIZATION SO THE IMAGINE
WHAT WE COULD HAVE DONE IT THE
STATE WITH THREE HUNDRED
MILLION AND I KNOW THAT YOU.
ESTATE LAWMAKERS HAD PLENTY OF
MONEY THIS LAST BUDGET SEASON
AND I KNOW THERE'S PLENTY OF
MONEY ANTICIPATED FOR THE NEXT
BUDGET SEASON BUT GUESS WHAT
THE MONEY IS NOT GOING TO LAST
FOREVER. AND I SPEAK FROM
EXPERIENCE BECAUSE I WENT
THROUGH THE- THE VERY LEAN
BUDGET TIMES. IN A IN
SACRAMENTO AND THEY'RE NOT
THEY'RE NOT GOOD TIMES TRIPPED
OUT TRUST ME. THEIR NECK WITH.
SO THE ECONOMIC COST OR ARE HE-
THERE'S ALSO WHAT I CALL THE-
OF THE- LET'S BE HONEST WE'RE
ALL HUMAN. THE GOVERNOR WAS
DISTRACTED AND SO WAS THE
LEGISLATURE DISTRACTED DIST
DIST DISTRACTED BY THAT THE
RECALL- I WILL ALSO ADD TO THAT
THE COST OF CONFUSION. YOU KNOW
VOTERS YOU KNOW ARE SAYING WAIT
A MINUTE I THOUGHT WE JUST
ELECTED A GOVERNOR A YEAR AND A
HALF AGO. STILL THERE IS THE
COST OF CONFUSION AND WHEN
VOTERS ARE CONFUSED YOU KNOW
PARTICIPANTS PARTICIPATORY
DEMOCRACY SUFFERS. AND LASTLY
I'M GONNA SPLIT SOMETHING THAT
PERHAPS PEOPLE MY SALE MIGHT
THERE BE TO BRUTALLY HONEST BUT
THAT'S MY STYLE. AND AT. AND
THE OTHER THE BEST COST I'M
TALKING ABOUT IS THE COST OF
AVOIDANCE. AND THAT IS THAT
EVERY IS BIG. YOU KNOW YOU'RE
UNDER A CLOUD OF A RECALL AND
EVERYBODY'S UNDER THAT CLOUD
NOT ONLY THE GOVERNOR BUT SO IS
THE LEGISLATURE. WHAT I MEAN BY
COST AVOIDANCE IS THAT THERE'S
GONNA BE SOME HUGE HUGE ISSUE
WITH WHICH ONLY BE ADDRESSED.
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO BE
BASICALLY FUNNELLED THROUGH
WHAT AT ALL A PRISM OF RECALL
POLITICS. I'M BEING REALLY
HONEST AND THAT'S THE BARE
BONES TRUTH AND WE'RE ALL
GUILTY OF IT AS REPUBLICANS OR
DEMOCRATS. WE ALWAYS TRY TO
GET. THE BIG ISSUES. BUT THAT
THANK YOU THAT MIGHT CUSTOMER
IS OVER WELL IF YOU COULD WRAP
UP CENTERS. PRITCHETT ALL YOUR
SITE. I JUST BASICALLY ONE TO
SAY THAT. THAT IT TAKES A LOT
OF COURAGE TO DO. SAY FOR
EXAMPLE LEGISLATION ON BEHALF
OF UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS IT
TAKES A LOT OF COURAGE TO DO
THAT. WITH THEIR UNDER RECALL
CONDITIONS OR NOT THEY DO EVEN
MORE SO IN A POLITICAL
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THE BAR IS SO
LOW. TO IN ORDER TO ALLOW A
RECALL. AND WHEREAS A JUDGE A
FEDERAL JUDGE CANNOT BE
IMPEACHED FOR UNPOPULAR LEGAL
RULINGS. I STRONGLY BELIEVE
THAT THE SAME PROTECTION SHOULD
BE GIVEN TO A SITTING GOVERNOR.
AND THAT PROTECTION SHOULD
INCLUDE A COST ELEMENT FOR
RECALL THANK YOU SO MUCH
MEMBERS TERRIFIC THANK YOU
SENATOR STUDIO LET ME SEE IF
COLLEAGUES HAVE QUESTIONS
BEFORE WE LET YOU GO.
COLLEAGUES ANY QUESTIONS JERRY
BERMAN IS CENTER STUDIO THE
YEAH THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY AND IN PARTICULAR I
LOVE THE- THE COST OF
DISTRACTION IN THE COST OF
AVOIDANCE- KIND OF POINTS THAT
YOU MADE THAT. I'M KIND OF
STRUGGLE TO EXPLAIN TO PEOPLE
EXACTLY THE IMPACT THAT HAS ON
ON GOVERNING AND THE GOVERNING
PROCESS AND THE IMPACT OF THAT
HAD. OVER THIS PAST NINE MONTHS
AND YEAH I THINK YOU'RE SPOT ON
AND SAYING THAT IT IMPACTED YOU
KNOW THE GOVERNOR IT ALSO
IMPACTED THE LEGISLATURE- AND
THAT'S NOT GOOD. FOR CALIFORNIA
THAT'S NOT GOOD FOR THE FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA YOU KNOW ALSO
APPRECIATE YOU AND- FORMER
SENATOR NOW SUPERVISOR
MCPHERSON'S POINTS KIND OF
ABOUT. WHAT SHOULD WE USE
RECALL FOR VERSUS WHAT SHOULD
BE THE POINT OF REELECTION
CAMPAIGNS- IN YOU KNOW ELECTION
CAMPAIGNS. I THINK A LOT OF
PEOPLE WOULD ARGUE SHOULD BE
FOR DISAGREEMENTS IN POLICY-
AND THAT'S THE AT THE
OPPORTUNITY THAT THE PUBLIC HAS
TO. SAY WE DISAGREE WITH THE
POLICIES THAT YOU ENACTED WE
DISAGREE WITH THE POLICIES. YOU
SUPPORTED AND THEREFORE WE'RE
GONNA VOTE YOU OUT OF OFFICE.
VERSUS MAYBE IT SHOULD BE THIS
HIGHER BAR FOR A RECALL. LIKE
YOU SAID WITH WITH YOU KNOW
SUCH AS SOME- YOU KNOW IT'S-
SOMETHING THAT THAT THE. THE
OTHER COURTS WOULD IDENTIFY IS
AS- EXTRA MELFI- TO GET A RAISE
TO THE- OF. WARRANTING RECALL-
SO JUST JUST REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR- YOUR POINTS ON THAT AND
THEN IT SEEMS LIKE YOU. AGREED
WITH YOUR YOUR YOU KNOW FORMER
COLLEAGUE FROM THE OPPOSITE
SIDE OF THE AISLE. A ABOUT
THAT- YOU CAN GO AHEAD. I WILL
I AM VERY BIASED MY FAVORITE
REPUBLICAN WAS ALWAYS CHRISTMAS
HERE'S AN ENGINE YOU CAN NAME.
BUT I MEAN YOU KNOW BROUGH
SPEAKS THE TRUTH AND HE'S A
SITTING EMBER OF AN ELECTED
BODY RIGHT NOW AND HE SPEAKS
THE TRUTH WHEN HE SAYS THAT WE
HAVE TO HAVE A HIGHER BURDEN OF
PROOF. AS TO WHAT TO RECALL OF
OFFENSE AND IT'S OBVIOUSLY IT
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE STATUTES
THAT USE THE WORD MALFEASANCE
GRANTED THE WORD IS CONFUSING
THERE'S NOT REALLY CLEAR CUT
DEFINITIONS FOR THAT BUT YOU
KNOW WHAT YOU ARE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE
WHY DON'T YOU AK A QUESTION OF
THE CALIFORNIA JUDICIAL
COUNCIL. MADE UP OF THE CHIEF
JUSTICE OF THE SUPREME COURT
AND A LOT OF JUDGES UP AND DOWN
THE STATE AND LET'S SEE IF THEY
COULD COME UP WITH A DEFINITION
TO THE WORD MALFEASANCE TO
GUIDE YOU AS YOU GO THROUGH
THESE THEM. THE JUSTICE
SUGGESTED IDEAS THANK FOUNDER
GREAT THANK YOU CHAIR BURKE
BERMAN- LOOKING AT MY
COLLEAGUES THEY SEE NO FURTHER
QUESTIONS. SENATOR STUDIO SO
GREAT TO HAVE YOU BACK WITH US
WE APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTFUL
TESTIMONY CERTAINLY THE
CONCRETE EXAMPLES YOU GAVE IN
THE STATE OF FLORIDA. FOR THOSE
KINDS A DEFINITION QUESTION. J.
YOUR- THIS IS. ALL RIGHT OR THE
FLORIDA ON JULY. GEORGIA I KNOW
IF IT IS A DIFFERENCE OKAY. AND
ANYWAY OKAY ALL RIGHT SO THANK
YOU. SENATOR WE LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR IN. AND WITH US GOING
FORWARD THANK YOU SO. OUR FINAL
SPEAKER IN THIS FIRST PANEL IS
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER JIM
COONEY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CONVENE
IS A PARTNER AT CALIFORNIA
STRATEGIES A PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CONSULTING FIRM- HE JOINED IN
TWO THOUSAND SEVEN TO OVERSEE
THE FIRM'S OFFICE AND SILICON
VALLEY- THE REGION WHERE HE
GREW UP AND LATER REPRESENTED
IN THE LEGISLATURE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KUNEEN. REPRESENTED THE
TWENTY FOURTH DISTRICT IN THE
STATE ASSEMBLY FROM NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR TO TWO THOUSAND
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CLEANING
WELCOME TO OUR JOINT HEARING.
AND WE WELCOME YOUR TESTING NOW.
YOUR NAME IS MY VOICE. CAN YOU
HEAR ME WE CAN HEAR YOU FINE.
CHAIRPERSON NOT A GLAZER AND
BERMAN MEMBERS OF THE JOINT
COMMITTEE AND BY A STEEP.
FORMER COLLEAGUE CENTER SCHOOLS
YEAH THAT SOME WOMEN NOW BUT
FIRST THAT NOW SUPER. AT A
GREAT ON AND I LEARNED SO MUCH
LISTENING BOTH OF YOU AGAIN
THINKING TO THOSE TIMES IN
THINKING THAT. MAYBE THINGS ARE
BETTER WHEN WE WERE IN CHARGE.
IT YEAH- IDNR CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION THAT VOTERS HAVE A
RIGHT TO RECALL- IS MERITORIOUS
IN MY MIND AND- I WANT TO BE A
STAR IMAGE DEFENDER OF THE
RIGHT TO RECALL AS A TOOL FOR
OUR CITIZENS. I WANT TO GIVE
SOME CONTEXT ABOUT AS WE TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THESE IDEAS FROM
BY WAY OF BACKGROUND I WAS
ELECTED THREE TIMES TO THE
LEGISLATURE UP. AND WAS THE
NOMINEE OF MY POLITICAL PARTY
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY AND VERY
PROUD TO HAVE BEEN MANY YEARS
AGO- FOR UNITED STATES CONGRESS
THAT. I'M NO LONGER REPUBLICAN
AND NEVER A DEMOCRAT BUT I. M.
NATIONALLY AND INDEPENDENT I
HAD A MEMBER OF THE NEW
CALIFORNIA COMMONSENSE PARTY-
BUT THE VIEWS I'M EXPRESSING
TODAY- ARE MY OWN- AND NONE OF
MY NEW CARD. IN OUR NATION ON
IN OUR REPUBLIC OVERALL-
PROMOTING STABLE GOVERNMENTS.
WHILE PROTECTING MINORITY
VOICES. THROUGH SUCH TOOLS AS
SUPERMAJORITY VOTES JUDICIAL
DECISIONS AND DON'T NECESSARILY
REFLECT THE MAJORITY WILL IN
ANY GIVEN MOMENT OR IN SOME
STATES- RECALLING THE EXECUTIVE
OR LEGISLATOR SEEMS TO BE
PRAISED IN MY MIND. EACH OF
HESE IS INTENDED TO PROMOTE
ACCOUNTABILITY- AND STABLE
GOVERNANCE. SO FOR PURPOSES OF
COMPARISON IN MY CASE SO
SUPERMAJORITY VOTES THE CORE
PRINCIPLE FOR ME ANYWAY IS THAT
A FAIR MAJORITY VOTE. JUST
ISN'T ENOUGH SOMETIMES. YES
IT'S LEGITIMATE TO DEBATE. WHAT
CONSTITUTES. NUMBER BOTH. ANY
GIVE CERTAIN. IS IT TOO THIRDS
IS IT 5% DIFFERENCE HAS BEEN IN
ENACT IN SOME AREAS WHOPPERS
THE NOTION- BACK MORE THAN A
MAJORITY IS NECESSARY IN SOME
CASES. COMING TO ON THE ISSUE
OF THE RECALL THE MATTER IN
HAND MODIFYING THE
QUALIFICATIONS OF SUCH A
DRAMATIC ACTION IS REQUIRED
DISCUSSION. I'M NOT ADVOCATING
READY IN THE RECALL NOR
NARROWING THERE'S SOMETHING
INSIDE OF OUR TALK ABOUT-
NERIMA FLORAL SO NARROW THAT NO
RECALL CAN QUALIFY- BUT
ENSURING PROPER USE WHEN
NECESSARY. AND NOT WITH NEARLY-
POSSIBLE BACKED UP WHETHER A
PARTY OR A GROUP OF INDIVIDUALS
MAY RECALL- DOESN'T MEAN IT'S
WISE TO DO SO. AND HERE'S WHY I
BELIEVE RECALL EFFORT SIR A
FRESH. VOTERS MORE IN MY MIND A
CRUSHING. READ ELECTION JUST
MONTHS GOING TO PRIMARY. WAS
UNNECESSARILY DISRUPTIVE I
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUES ON
THAT POINT BASED ON MERIT
POLICY DISAGREEMENTS AND
COSTLY. AS I WROTE RECENTLY. I
AM TWENTY A POLICY QUARRELS
WITH GOVERNOR KNEW SOMETHING I
DESPERATELY WISH SHE'D SUPPORT
MORE WATER STORAGE LOWER TAXES
REMOVE ON REASONABLE REGULATORY
BURDENS STOP UNDERMINING
PROPOSITION THIRTEEN. CEASE
TRYING TO HINDER PUBLIC CHARTER
SCHOOLS JUST TO NAME A FEW.
HOWEVER GOVERNOR NEWSOM
CAMPAIGN FOR GOVERNOR WITH
POLICY PRESCRIPTIONS QUITE
DIFFERENT FROM MY OWN ON THESE
MATTERS AND ONE ELECTION BY A
LANDSLIDE. EARS AGO. AT THE
TIME OF THE RECALL HE WAS
SCHEDULED TO STAND FOR RE
ELECTION IN JUST A HANDFUL OF
MONTHS. IT WOULD BE IMPRACTICAL
FOR SOMEONE NEW TO FORM A
GOVERNMENT. THOUSANDS OF
APPOINTMENTS THAT WOULD BE
NECESSARY DEVELOPMENT
LEGISLATIVE STRATEGY AND RUN IN
THE NEXT OPEN PRIMARY A FEW
MONTHS LATER. CONSIDER THAT
ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER HAD THREE
YEARS TO DO SO. THERE ARE SO
MANY IDEAS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION BY I LIKE TO
MENTION JUST A FEW HERE ARE AND
QUALIFY A FEW HERE- AND SOME OF
OUR FILES TO BE SEMI PROCESSED
AFTER ALL FOR LEGISLATORS-
FIRST- I THINK ONE WAY TO
CALIBRATE THIS TENSION BETWEEN-
NOT WANTING TO MAKE. A BAR SO
DIFFICULT IS TO CONSIDER
RAISING THE SIGNATURES REQUIRED
FOR QUALIFICATION. COMMITTEE
HAS BEEN PROVIDED WITH DATA
FROM THE STAFF REGARDING- THE
PERCENT OF SIGNATURES REQUIRED
FOR RECALL IN A MODEST HIGHER
THRESHOLD- WOULD DEMAND GOING
BEYOND MERE POLICY DIFFERENCES
IN MY MIND. YOU DON'T WANT TO
MAKE IT TOO HIGH. BUT I THINK
TODAY IT'S TOO LOW. SECOND I
LIKE THE IDEA OF ELEVATING THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR FOLLOWING
THE SUCCESSFUL RECALL TO AVOID
THE CARTOONISH LIST OF DOZENS
OF REPLACEMENTS. BECAUSE THEY
GREATLY DIMINISHES. YES
REFLECTION ON WHO SHOULD WIENER
STATE. I THINK IT'S HARD TO
CALIBRATE BUT I DON'T AGREE
WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER- MULLIN-
I'M A VERY THOUGHTFUL
LEGISLATOR- ON SEPARATE OREGON
RUNNING AS A TICKET I LIKE THE
IDEA OF BEING SEPARATE EVEN IF
IT IS AN OPPOSITE PARTY FOR
SOME OF THE REASONS EVEN-
SUPERVISOR MCPHERSON TO. ABOUT
AND- DENNIS WILL TAKE MUCH MORE
EXTENSIVE TO CALIBRATE RIGHT
AND I JUST HEARD A CENTER
STUDIO AND HER BRILLIANT LEGAL
MIND BUT I DO THINK THAT WE
SHOULD CONSIDER- AND WE EVEN
TALK ABOUT IT MUCH HERE LOOTING
THE TIME FRAME FROM WHICH A
RECALL PETITION CAN QUALIFY. A
RECALL SO LATE IN THE
GOVERNOR'S TERM DOES NOT
PROMOTE STABLE GOVERNMENT BUT
INSTEAD PROVED RATHER HAZARD IN
THIS CASE THAT THE LIMITING A
RECALL DOING HER MAYBE NOT JUST
QUALIFY TWELVE MONTHS PRIOR TO
THE REGULAR OPEN PRIMARY- A
REGULAR ELECTION SHOULD BE
CONSIDERED. I'M OPEN TO MANY OF
THE OTHER IDEAS DISCUSSED AS
WELL BUT I JUST WANT TO
CONCLUDE BY SAYING I'M A
FRUSTRATED- INDEPENDENT DROPPED
FROM MY OWN CENTER. RIGHT
PERSPECTIVE- I TELL YOU WHAT WE
STILL GOT AND I WILL TO. FIND
THE RIGHT BALANCE I WON TO HAVE
THE TO READ. AND I'M TO HAVE A
TWO USED IN A CONCERT MAN- I
DON'T I'M ALONE IN THAT- AND I
THINK CAN DO ABOUT. SO WITHOUT
OKAY INCLUDING HOW THE ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUES IF THEY'D LIKE TO
I'VE BEEN. TERRIFIC THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. J. YEARS AFTER.
AGUIAR-CURRY HAS FOLLOWED QUEST.
IS THANKS SO MUCH IN A COMMUNAL
IS A GREAT TO SEE YOU I'VE GOT
A QUESTION I'M COMPANY ON THE
SPOT SO I APOLOGIZE FOR THAT-
BUT THIS ONE THERE'S ANOTHER
KIND OF PART OF THE PROCESS
WHICH IS. THE- THE- KIND OF ITS
SIGNATURES THAT NEED TO BE
COLLECTED OR OR OR THE- IT
PROCESS JUST TO PULL PAPERS.
JUST IT TO START THE RECALL
PROCESS AND I KNOW I'VE- SPOKEN
WITH SOME LOCAL GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS WHO HAVE BEEN
FRUSTRATED TO SAY. YOU KNOW ALL
IT HAS TO HAPPEN I THINK IT'S-
FOR THE GOVERNOR IT'S- TWENTY
SIGNATURES SIXTY FIVE SIXTY. SO
DID TO START A RECALL PROCESS
FOR RECALLING THE GOVERNOR. YOU
JUST NEED TO SUBMIT SIXTY FIVE
SIGNATURES- AND AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL I CAN BE AS LITTLE AS TEN
SIGNATURES- TO START A RECALL
PROCESS. WHICH DOESN'T
NECESSARILY SHOW A REAL BRIGHT
THIRD DEPTH OF SUPPORT FOR THAT
RECALL. AND WOULD YOU THINK
THAT YOU KNOW EVEN BEFORE THE
SIGNATURES TO QUALIFY AND PUT
ON THE BALLOT. IS THE
SIGNATURES TO JUST START THAT
PROCESS SIMPLE PAPERS. DO YOU
THINK THAT'S AN AREA THAT MAYBE
WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT AS
WELL- AS AS A AREA FOR
POSSIBLE. REFORM OF THE RECALL
PROCESS. THAT IS SOMETHING THAT
CAN BE LOOKED AT IN YOUR-
LEGISLATORS. YOU KNOW SO YOU
REALLY WANT TO HAVE. USED TO
BIGELOW BERMAN. I'M AND IS IT.
TOO EASY NOW ON- YOU KNOW OUR
PASSIONS ARE NOT IN CHECK IN SO
WE CALL THOSE PAPERS AND HAVE
SO FEW SIGNATURES- NUMBER- OF
WHAT IT SHOULD REQUIRE BUT- UP-
I DO THINK IN THE INSTANCE IT
IS FEELS TO- AS WELL RIGHT NOW.
BUT I DO THINK THAT A SMALL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE SOMETIMES CAN
TAP INTO A LARGER MOMENT- SO I
WOULD NOT ACT- SUPPORT- MAKING
THAT BURDEN SO CRUSHING. MAKES
SENSE IN A SENSE IT'S. A VERY
GOOD OTHER QUESTIONS FROM NOT
MEMBERS. ALL RIGHT A C. NINE AS
MEMBER THANK YOU FOR YOUR VERY
TESTIMONY THINGS YOU THINK WE
SHOULD CONSIDER RAISING THE
SIGNATURE REQUIREMENT- SO IT
GOES BEYOND A MERE POLICY
DIFFERENCES- YOUR SUPPORT FOR
ELEVATING LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
IS ONE ALTERNATIVE- LIMITING
THE TIME FRAME FOR RECALL
TWELVE MONTHS PRIOR TO A
PRIMARY ALL THOSE THINGS UP
SERIOUS MINDED. AND THOUGHTFUL
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR INPUT TO
OUR DELIBERATIONS SO THANK YOU
SO MUCH SIR. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT WE'RE GONNA TURN IT OVER
TO CHAIR BERMAN. THANK YOU
THEATER GLAZER- SO. WE WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT PORTION OF%
THE AGENDA WE WILL HEAR ABOUT
RECALL PROCEDURES IN OTHER
STATES- AND THIS WAS ALLUDED TO
BY SOME OF THE AB PRIOR
TESTIMONY THAT WE JUST HEARD
JOINING US FOR THIS PART OF THE
AGENDA IS BEN WILLIAMS A
PROGRAM PRINCIPLE IN THE
ELECTIONS AND REDISTRICTING
PROGRAM AT THE NATIONAL
CONFERENCE OF STATE
LEGISLATORS- STATE
LEGISLATURES. ALONG WITH THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR HE MANAGES AND
CSL IS REDISTRICTING AND STATE
PARTISAN COMPOSITION AT
PORTFOLIOS- NOW AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT MR WILLIAMS HAS
A POWER POINT PRESENTATION- FOR
US- IF WE CAN GET THE POWER
POINT PRESENTATION UP ON THE
SCREEN. I WILL WAIT A SECOND
FOR THAT TO HAPPEN- AND THEN
MISTER WILLIAMS THANK YOU FOR
JONING US. AND YOU MAY BEGIN
AS SOON AS THE POWER POINT IS
READY AND IT'S UP. SO WE ARE
READY FOR YOU MISTER WILLIAMS.
I WONDERFUL THANK YOU SO MUCH-
CHAIRMANSHIP GLAZER MEMBERS
BEFORE ADDING IT TODAY I'M
GONNA TALK BRIEFLY ABOUT NOT
RECALL. PROCEDURES THAT EXIST
NATIONWIDE A LOT OF THIS WAS
COVERED IN THE- VICTORY GO THE
NUMBER THAT WAS WRITTEN BY YOUR
STAFF- AND- LEADING UP INTO
THIS HEARING SO SOME OF THIS
MAY. NOT BE NEW A LOT OF A
STRONG TOMORROW RESOURCES AS
WELL- BUT IT'S HELPFUL I MEAN
JUST LOOK AT IT THROUGH A- STEP
BY STEP TO SEE DIFFERENT THINGS
THAT IS ON TRACK. NATION ON
RECALL ELECTIONS TO PUT
CALIFORNIA. IN JUST WHERE
CALIFORNIANS SIMILAR TO ITS
PEERS AND WHERE IT'S DIFFERENT.
SO THE FIRST POINT I WANTED TO
MAKE WAS THAT IT'S ALL IT'S A
BIPARTISAN ORGANIZATION THAT
SERVES THE NEEDS OF ALL STATE
LEGISLATORS NATIONWIDE ALL
SEVEN THOUSAND THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTY THREE LEGISLATORS IN THE
UNITED STATES ARE MEMBERS OF
THE NCSL AS ARE ALL TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND PLUS LEGISLATIVE
STAFF. THAT'S A BIG GROUP OF
PEOPLE WITH A LOT OF DIVERSE
POLITICAL OPINIONS AND THAT'S
RECALL NCSL RECOMMENDATIONS ON
POLICY SO YOU WANT YOUR BEATS
IT'S SAYING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOT COULD NOT. ANY
PARTICULAR PROCEDURE OR
PRACTICE WHAT I WILL DO IS LET
OUT INFORMATION AS IT EXISTS
NATIONWIDE SO THAT YOU WILL BE
BETTER INFORMED FOR THE
DECISIONS THAT YOU WILL BE
PICKING. AS. YOU CONTINUE ON
THIS PROCESS MOVING FORWARD. SO
THE FIRST POINT IS UP DOESN'T
TAKE FROM IT RECALLS A STATE IF
AT ALL. AND IN THIS CASE TWENTY
IS AND MIGHT BE IN THAT IT DOES
RECALLS. THERE ARE NINETEEN
STATES THAT PREVENT RECALL
ELECTIONS. US THE
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICERS STATE
ELECTED OFFICIALS THAT THE
TERMINOLOGY VERY STATE STATE
YOU GET THE IDEA. IF YOU CAN'T
AGREE STATES ON THE SLIDE
YOU'LL NOTICE TWENTY STATES
HIGHLIGHTED NOT NINETEEN AND
THAT'S BECAUSE- UP FOR NEXT
WEEK A CROSS I RECALL PROCESS
SO IN VIRGINIA. AND THERE'S A
SIGNATURE GATHERING EFFORT AS
EXIST IN THE OTHER RECALL
STATES BUT IF ENOUGH SIGNATURES
ARE GATHERED TO TRIGGER THE
RECALL THE RECALL PROCEDURE IS
A JUDICIAL TRIAL. NOT AN
ELECTION IN A TRIAL WAS HELD TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT ONE OF
THE PRE DETERMINED BECAUSE IT'S
LAID OUT OF VIRGINIA STATE LAW
EXIST. FOR AN EIGHT OFFICER OF
THE STATE TO BE REMOTE. SO THAT
IS ONE UNIQUE EXAMPLE. BUT
YOU'LL NOTICE AS I GO THROUGH
THE REST OF PRESENTATION.
REFERENCE NINETEEN STATES NOT
TWENTY. SO THE FOR ISSUES THAT
NCSL TRACKS OFF FOR RECALLS ARE
THE REASON. SO CAN IT BE FOR
ANY REASON OR TO SAY BECAUSE
NECESSARY TO. TRIGGER A RECALL
ELECTION THAT'S BEEN REFERENCED
BY THE PREVIOUS SPEAKERS. THE
SIGNATURES HOW MANY ARE NEEDED
TO QUALIFY FOR THE BALLOT. THE
GATHERING HOW LONG IS THE
SIGNATURE GATHERING BOB BY
WHICH TIME ABOUT THE PETITION
GATHERS NEED TO SUBMIT THOSE
SIGNATURES FOR THE STATE FOUR.
OPERABLE OR REJECTION. AND THEN
THE REPLACEMENT NAKED. HOW IS
THE REPLACEMENT SELECTED YES
THE MEASURE DOES QUALIFY FOR
THE BALLOT. SO THE FIRST OF
THOSE FOR. US IS A RECALLS ARE
PERMITTED CALIFORNIA IS IN THE
JORDY POSITION. MAKES A RECALL
FOR ANY REASON THERE ARE TWELVE
STATES THAT PERMIT A RECALL FOR
ANY REASON E. EIGHTY STATES
THAT. ONLY REQUIRED FOR CALLS
ONE OF THOSE IS VIRGINIA JUST
ALL STATE NOTAN ACTUAL
ELECTION SO THERE ARE ONLY
SEVEN STATES THAT REQUIRE A
CLAUSE FOR A RECALL ELECTION-
TO BE HELD. IN TERMS OF THE
NUMBERS WHICH IS NEEDED TO
TRIGGER RECALL CALIFORNIA IS
ONE OF THE MOST PERMITS STATES
IN THE COUNTRY THERE'S ONLY ONE
STATE MONTANA NEVER IS A LOWER
PERCENTAGE OF SIGNATURES TO
QUALIFY FOR THE BALLOT ALL OF
THE OTHER STATES HAVE A FIRE
ALTERCATION HOWEVER I WILL NOTE
THAT MONTANA IN CALIFORNIA DO
DIFFER ON ONE KEY POINT WHICH
IS THAT MONTANA. ALL THE
PERCENTAGE WHICH IS 10%
CALIFORNIA'S 12% MONTANA'S 10%
OF REGISTERED VOTERS WORST
CALIFORNIA'S 12% OF THE NUMBER
OF VOTES CAST FOR THAT
PARTICULAR OFFICE IN THE MOST
RECENT ELECTION SO YOU COULD
SEE A CIRCUMSTANCE IN WHICH
CALIFORNIA HAS THE LOWEST
SIGNATURE PERCENTAGE THRESHOLD.
IN THE COUNTRY. AND HERE'S
ANOTHER SLIDE TO LAY OUT WHAT
THOSE STATES ARE- CALIFORNIA SO
YOU CAN SEE EXAMPLES ADEQUATE
FOR THE SLACK IS THE LOWEST.
AND THEN THE MAJORITY OF STATES
HAVE A 25% OR GREATER SPECIALTY
MOST OF THE STATES IN THAT
CATEGORY ARE AT 25% BUT THERE
ARE A FEW THAT HAVE. SPECIAL TO
ELEVATE IT BEYOND THAT I WILL
NOTE THAT A LOT OF THINGS TO
HAVE DIFFERENT THRESHOLDS FOR
STATE AND LOCAL OFFICES ROB
THIS PRESENTATION I'M REFERRING
ONLY TO STATEWIDE OFFICES.
THERE'S A RAGING FACTOR IS THE
LENGTH OF THESE THINGS TOGETHER.
AGAIN CALIFORNIA IS ONE OF THE
MOST PERMISSIVE STATES IN THE
COUNTRY ALTHOUGH IT'S NOT AS
EXTREME AS THE MOST RECENT
EXAMPLE OF CALIFORNIA. IT'S A
RECALL. ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
DATE OTHER ONLY THREE THAT HAVE
LONG WINDOWS THOSE ARE
LOUISIANA HEARD IN EIGHTY DAYS
NEW JERSEY THREE HUNDRED TWENTY
TO ONE SIXTY DEPENDING ON THE
OFFICE AND WASHINGTON STATE TWO
HUNDRED SEVENTY OR ONE HUNDRED
AND HE TAKES. A DEPENDING ON
THE OFFICE EVERYONE ELSE IS
SHORTER YOU WILL SEE AT THE
BOTTOM OF THE SCREEN ALASKA AND
WHAT'S IT CODE DO NOT SPECIFY
THE LENGTH OF THE PERIOD AND
LOSS THAT'S DECIDED TO- AT THE
MOMENT OF THE RECALL HELLO THAT.
WILL BE. AND SO YOU CAN SEE IT
AGAIN BROKE INTO THE START OF
THE MAJORITY OF STATES EITHER
STAY UP TO NINETY DAYS FOR
THREE MONTHS OCT TENTH OCTOBER
TENTH. NOT TO THE NUMBER OF
DAYS. FOR EASE OF ALL ITS
INFORMATION ONCE LINE A
COMBINED THIS KIND OF WORKS.
ANOTHER ONLY TWO STATES THAT
HAVE EIGHT INTERMEDIATE LENGTH
OF TIME ARIZONA AND WHATNOT. SO
THE LAST CATEGORY IS OUR THE
RECALL CANDIDATE IS REPLACED
AND YOU CAN SEE HERE IS MORE
EVEN SPLIT BETWEEN THE STATE'S
CALVET IT IS IN THE FIRST
CATEGORY WHERE THE RECALL AND
REPLACEMENT ELECTIONS ARE HELD
SIMULTANEOUSLY. SECOND CATEGORY
WHERE THERE'S A SPECIAL
ELECTION AFTER THE SUCCESSFUL
RECALL TO APPOINT THE SUCCESSOR
SO WE HAVE TWO SEPARATE
ELECTIONS THAT OCCUR AND THEN
AND THERE IN FIVE STATES THE
SUCCESSOR. SUCCESSOR IS NOT. ON
ELECTED BY PEOPLE OF THE STATE-
A COUPLE OF INTERESTING CARRY
OUT YOUR CALIFORNIA COLORADO
THE ONLY STATE THAT I HAVE THE
ELECTION- SIMULTANEOUSLY WITH
TWO SEPARATE. QUESTIONS ANY
OTHER STATES. THE WAIT I'D BE
EASIEST WAY FOR ME TO THINK
ABOUT. THE SUCCESS OF THE
MISSION OF THE RECALL PETITION
ACTS AS THE RECALL ITSELF
THAT'S SIMPLE TO CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST QUESTION RIGHT THE
OFFICER IS FUNCTIONALLY RECALL
THAT. THE DIFFERENCE IS THE
RECALL OFFICERS PERMITTED TO
RUN REPLACEMENT BALLOTS SO THEY
CAN ESSENTIALLY BE REELECTED
BACK INTO THE OFFICE THAT THEY
HELL DON'T REMOVED DURING THAT.
PERIOD SO IT'S NOT EXACT SAME
THE SAME THE RECALL BUT FOR
PURPOSES OF CONCEPTUALIZING
ACTION PROCESS. THAT'S THE BEST
ANALOGY I CAN GIVE TO
CALIFORNIA. I IN FOR THOSE FIVE
STATES THAT ARE IN CALIFORNIA'S
CATEGORIES THAT ARE NOT
CALIFORNIA COLORADO. THE
CURRENT OFFICE HOLDERS
AUTOMATICALLY PLACED ON THE
BALLOT UNLESS THEY RESIGN FROM
OFFICE SO THERE IS AN AUTOMATIC
MECHANISM FOR PUTTING THE MECCA
ONLY NEVADA. REQUIRES THE
CURRENT OFFICE HOLDER TO
ACTUALLY SIGN BACK ON. TO GET
ON TO THE PLACE OUT. JUST A
FINAL TO. THAT I THINK ARE
INTERESTING OF THE THREE
STATES. THAT THREE OF THE FIVE
STATES THAT HAVE THE- APPOINTED
REPLACEMENT IDAHO KANSAS AND
WASHINGTON REQUIRED AT THEIR
PLACE TO BE FROM THE SAME
POLITICAL ARE USED TO BE CALLED
CANADA. THEY HAVE DIFFERENT
MECHANISMS FOR SELECTING THAT
PERSON SOMETIMES IT'S- THE
STATE SECOND COMMITTEE OF THE
PARTY SUBMITS NAMES AND THAT'S
CHOSEN SOMETIMES IT. OUT
SOMEONE ELSE IN THE PARKING. A
SOME OTHER STATE ELECTED
OFFICER WHO WAS OF THE SAME
PARTY BUT THEY HAVE TO BE ON
THE SAME POLITICAL PARTY. AND
IN CALIFORNIA GEORGIA LOUISIANA
MONTANA AND WASHINGTON ARE UP
TO FIVE STATES THAT HAVE
DIFFERENT SIGNATURE THRESHOLDS
FOR DIFFERENT OFFICES SO YOU
MAY HAVE A DIFFERENT SIGNATURE
THRESHOLD- AND SOME OF THE
STATE'S FOR. US SENATE OR FOR
GOVERNOR THAT HE WOULD FOR ME
SECRETARY OF STATE TREASURER.
DIFFERENT. STATEWIDE
CONSTITUTIONAL OFFICES. AND
WITH THAT I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR HAVING ME TODAY AND I'M
HAPPY TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
WILLIAMS REALLY APPRECIATE-
THAT THAT VERY CLEAR AND EASY
TO FOLLOW PRESENTATION. ONE
OPEN UP THAT TO COLLEAGUES SEE
IF ANYBODY HAS ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS PRESSURES THE ART OF
QUESTION. SIR MY QUESTION BET
MISTER WILLIAMS MY OTHER
QUESTION IS ON YOUR SLIDE ABOUT
THE LENGTH OF SIGNATURE
GATHERING PERIOD BY STATE. DID
YOU TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION.
YOU KNOW BECAUSE THERE IS A-
VERY. A AN EFFORT THAT HAS TO
BE PUT TOGETHER TO BE ABLE TO
COLLECT SIGNATURES IN
CALIFORNIA HAS A HUGE
POPULATION. AND SO RIGHT NOW AT
LEAST I THINK THE LAST ELECTION
THERE THIS THIS PREVIOUS
ELECTION IT WAS ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION SIGNATURES THEY HAD
COLLECTED WHEREAS SAY MONTANA.
PROBABLY WOULDN'T HAVE TO HAVE
THAT MANY AND IT WOULD TAKE
THEM A LOT LESS TIME AND THAT
MAY BE WHY THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE DO YOU THINK THAT
DIFFERENCE. IS CORRELATED TO
THE POPULATION THE DIFFICULTY
IT WOULD TAKE TO BE ABLE TO
ORGANIZE AN EFFORT TO TRY TO
GET THOSE OBTAINED OBTAIN
SIGNATURES TO HAVE A- GET IT.
THAT RECALL ON THE BALLOT. NOT
SURE CERTAIN I EXCITED THAT I
SHOULD DID NOT CONTROL FOR
POPULATION DIFFERENCES SO IT'S
HIGHLY POSSIBLE THAT THERE CAN
BE REASONS TO COMMITTED BY
LEGISLATORS FOR THE LENGTH OF
THEIR TIMELINES I'M NOT
FAMILIAR WITH THE LEGISLATIVE
HISTORY BEHIND WHY CALIFORNIA
SELECT X. WHEN DID IT YEAH- SO
I DON'T WANT TO COMMENT ON
WHETHER OR NOT WHAT YOU SAID IS
TRUE IT DEFINITELY SEEMS
REASONABLE TO ME. I UNDERSTAND
AND THAT'S JUST ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS I HAVE IS MAYBE THOSE
LONGER TIME PERIODS ARE BECAUSE
OF THE POPULATION DIFFERENCE
WHEN YOU LOOK AT COLORADO IDAHO
KANSAS MONTANA COMPARED TO
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION I THINK
WE MIGHT HAVE MORE THAN ALSO
PUT TOGETHER SO- SO ANYWAY. AT
THAT CLARIFICATION. FOR THE
YOU'RE GLAZER YEAH- MISTER
WILLIAMS THANK YOU FOR AGAIN
YEARS TO SANCTION AND CLEAR
TESTIMONY SOMETIMES I WORRY WE
AVOID THE OBVIOUS IN THESE
KINDS THE DEBATE SO I WANT TO
ASK A QUESTION THAT- MAY BE
OBVIOUS TO SOME OF US BUT IT
WOULD BE GOOD TO HAVE YOUR
CLARIFICATION IT WILL JUST WANT
TO RECALL THE ATMOSPHERICS OF
IT ALL WAS THAT IT WAS A
PARTISAN ISSUE ONE PARTY WAS
NOT HAPPY ANOTHER PARTY WAS IN
POWER- AND YOU BROKE DOWN THE
STATE'S THOSE WHO DON'T HAVE
ANY RECALL. AND THOSE THAT DO
IS THERE ANY KIND OF PARTISAN-
BREAK IN AND THAT DATA THAT
WOULD SUGGEST TO YOU THAT ONE
PARTY OR THE OTHER I FELT THAT
IT WAS A MORE IMPORTANT ARE
DOMINATING OPTION. THAN THE
OTHER. CHECK JUST TAKE A QUICK
LOOK AT THAT SLIDE AGAIN THAT'S
A AYE WILL THAT WAS. NOT
SOMETHING THAT I'M AT. THROUGH
THAT LENS COMING INTO THIS- THE
ONE THING THAT ARE STAND OUT TO
ME VERY CLEARLY IS THAT THE- US
STATES THAT PERMITS THE RECALL.
SO TO BE THE STATE'S THAT ALSO
PERMITS CITIZENS INITIATIVES
OUT MEASURES THAT HAVE MORE
DIRECT DEMOCRACY MECHANISMS
THAT OTHERS THAT HAS A WESTERN
BIAS. TO BE MORE STATES IN THE
WESTERN UNITED STATES THAT
PROCEDURE SO I'M SEEING THAT
TRAIN ON THE MAP THAT DOESN'T
SURPRISE ME AT ALL. I'M LOOKING
AT MY SCREEN JUST. ANALYZE IT
D. R. SEVERAL STATES THAT HAVE.
NOT DEMOCRATIC CONTROL BUT
THERE. ARE SEVERAL THAT HAVE
REPUBLICAN CONTROLS WELL. TEN
OUT NORTH. SCOTT SAID. WELL WE
SEE AND I CAN. SO THERE THERE'S
A IT'S A PRETTY EVEN. IN TERMS
OF HEAT RECALL ELECTIONS
THEMSELVES SO THERE'S A PRICE
THAT ELECTIONS ARE PARTISAN AND
THAT ELECTIONS- INFLAMED
PARTISAN EMOTIONS. IT'S THE.
THE JOB OF THE PEOPLE WHO ARE.
YOU KNOW SEVEN ELECTION
PROCEDURES TO MAKE THEIR RUN
ACCORDING TO THE PROCEDURES
THAT ARE SET IN PLACE AT THAT
TIME AND SO- THAT'S ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I LOVE COMING TO
TESTIFY. LIKE YOU IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE I GET TO SEE THAT WORK
OF ELECTION ADMINISTRATION
ELECTION MANAGEMENT. BUT THANK
YOU AND BUT LOOKING AT IT FROM
A PARTISAN POINT OF VIEW WHEN
YOU LOOK AT THOSE WHO DON'T
PERMIT A RECALL. AND YOU SEE ON
THE SAME PAGE TEXAS. WITH NEW
YORK. AND MISSISSIPPI AND
FLORIDA. AND OHIO THAT'S WHAT
THEY DOESN'T COME ACROSS AS A
PARTISAN SPLIT DOES IT TO YOU.
NO NO NOT PARTICULARLY I MEAN.
IT'S AT LEAST NOT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT A
LOT OF THESE LOSSES DR DECADES
DECADES AGO SO THE. NOW BUT AS
I LOOK AT THIS NOW IT DOESN'T
STRIKE ME THAT ALL THE STATES
ARE OF ONE PARTY IN ALL THE
STATES THAT DON'T PERMIT
RECALLS ARE OF THE OTHER PARTY
GREAT AND FINALLY SEEMS LIKE A
RELATIVELY MIXED UP BACK IN
EXACTLY EXACTLY AND FINALLY OF
THOSE THAT DO ALLOW RECALL
WHICH AGAIN YOU'RE COMBINING
LOOKING AT NORTH DAKOTA AND
MONTANA ALONG WITH ARIZONA IN
CALIFORNIA ONCE AGAIN DOESN'T
SEEM TO BE A PARTISAN SPLIT IN
TERMS OF DOMINANCE BY ONE PARTY
THE OTHER IN TERMS OF HOW. AND
WHAT THEY ALLOW IN THEIR STATE.
YEAH I AM I. WOULDN'T TAKE ANY
ON BRIDGE WITH THAT ASSESSMENT
GOOD THANK YOU SIR. FRAZIER
GLAZER- VESTER NELSON OUT OF
YOU. HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR
THIS RAIMES SO I DID MISS
RAIMES THANK YOU AT YEAH I'VE I
REALLY APPRECIATED THIS
PRESENTATION AND THE SLIDE DECK
AND I ASSUME WE'LL MAKE THIS.
AVAILABLE ON THE WEBSITE FOR
THE PUBLIC. I THINK IT REALLY
STARKLY SHOWS HOW MUCH OF AN
OUT LIAR CALIFORNIA IS WHEN IT
COMES TO OUR RECALL PROCESS
SEES- AND I THINK IT THE BAR
GRAPHS. THAT YOU PROVIDED
REALLY STARKLY ILLUSTRATE HOW
MUCH OF AN OUT LIAR CALIFORNIA
IS YOU KNOW THE BAR GRAPH ON ON
PAGE SIX OF THE SLIDE DECK.
WHERE WE SEE THAT WE HAVE- YOU
KNOW THERE'S ONE OTHER STATE
THAT THAT. HAS A LOWER
PERCENTAGE OF SIGNATURES NOT
NECESSARY BUT THAT STATE IT'S A
PERCENTAGE OF. REGISTERED
VOTERS NOT A PERCENTAGE OF THE
VOTER TURNOUT FROM THE PRIOR
GUBERNATORIAL ELECTION- AND
THEN IF THAT'S MONTANA. AND
THEN WE SEE. THAT CALIFORNIA
HAS ONE OF THE LONGEST PERIODS
TO COLLECT THE SIGNATURES SO
WE'VE GOT. THE LOWEST
PERCENTAGE OF SIGNATURES THAT
YOU NEED TO COLLECT. THE
LONGEST ONE OF THE LONGEST
TIMES TO COLLECT THE
SIGNATURES. THAT WAS CURIOUS OR
MONTANA YOU KNOW MAYBE THEY'VE
GOT A LOT LOWER SIGNATURE
THRESHOLDS- DEPENDING ON ON THE
ELECTION AND THE YEAR. BUT THEY
ONLY ALLOW UP TO NINETY DAYS.
TO COLLECT THOSE SIGNATURES
WILL CALIFORNIA ALLOWS ALMOST
TWICE THAT AMOUNT OF TIME A
HUNDRED AND SIXTY DAYS SO. YOU
KNOW IT JUST CLEARLY SHOWS THAT
THERE IS A BROAD RANGE. OF
PROCESS THESE THERE'S A BROAD
RANGE OF- THRESHOLDS AND TIME
TO MEET THOSE THRESHOLDS. IN
THAT CALIFORNIA IS AWAY ON THE
LOW END ON ONE AND WAY ON THE
HIGHWAY AND ON ANOTHER. AND
THERE'S A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY-
TO YOU KNOW TWEAK THINGS TO
MAYBE MAKE IT A LITTLE MORE
APPROPRIATE. AND MAKE IT MORE
ALIGNED WITH A MAJORITY OF TE
STATES THAT EVEN HAVE A RECALL
PROCESS. AND IT'S IMPORTANT TO
NOTE THAT IT'S A MINORITY OF
STATES THAT EVEN HAVE A RECALL
PROCESS NOW YOU'RE ONLY
NINETEEN STATES- OR TWENTY IF
YOU INCLUDE VIRGINIA WHICH IS A
DIFFERENT MODEL SO. YOU DON'T
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WAY YOU
LAY THIS OUT AND I ENJOYED THE
REASON SIGNATURE GATHERING
REPLACEMENT I MEAN THAT REALLY
HELPS KIND OF PINPOINT. THE
FOUR AREAS OF OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO. BE DISCUSSING. YOUR
POSSIBLE REFORMS HERE IN
CALIFORNIA- SO NOT A QUESTION
THERE REALLY JUST A COMMENT-
BUT APPRECIATE THE WAY YOU LAY
THIS OUT I THINK IT'S REALLY
HELPFUL FOR US. AS WE EVALUATE
HOW WE- STACK UP AGAINST OTHER
STATES PROCESSES- AND WITH THAT.
I'LL TURN IT BACK OVER THANK
YOU MISTER WILLIAMS REALLY
APPRECIATE IT. AT TWENTY SEVEN
THANKS YOUR BROWSER I THANK
EACH YEAR BERMAN WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE TO OUR PANEL NUMBER THREE.
THE QUESTION BEING PUT FORWARD
TO THE SIGNATURE THRESHOLD TO
QUALIFY A RECALL AND THE TIME
FOR COLLECTING THOSE SIGNATURES
BE CHANGED. I WANT TO WELCOME
TO OF THE OUR SPEAKERS
PROFESSOR DAVE CARILLO WHO WILL
BE SPEAKING FIRST FOLLOWED BY
HOOVER INSTITUTE FELLOW BILL
WHALEN- AND SINCE WE HAVE TWO
SPEAKERS ON THIS PANEL. I'M
GONNA SUGGEST THAT WE SAVE OUR
MEMBER QUESTIONS UNTIL BOTH
HAVE FINISHED THEIR TESTIMONY.
FIRST WILL BEGIN WITH PROFESSOR
CARILLO- PROFESSOR CORREOS A
LECTURE IN RESIDENTS AN
EXECUTOR RECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION CENTER.
AT BERKELEY LAW SINCE TWO
THOUSAND TWELVE CO AUTHOR OF
THE CASEBOOK CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW. BEFORE
JOINING THE ACADEMY DR CARILLO
PRACTICE LAW FOR SIXTEEN YEARS.
MOST RECENTLY AS A DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE. HE HAS SERVED ON
SEVERAL STATE AND LOCAL
COMMISSIONS INCLUDING THE
CALIFORNIA LAW REVISION
COMMISSION. THE JUDICIAL
NOMINEES EVALUATION COMMISSION
AND THE COMMITTEE OF BAR
EXAMINERS PROFESSOR CARILLO
WELCOME TO THE JOINT HEARING
AND WE- WELCOME YOUR TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU HAS MY AUDIO.
TERRIFIC GREAT MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE MY NAME'S DAVID
CARILLO DURING MY ACADEMIC
CAPACITY TO DISCUSS THE
SIGNATURE REQUIREMENT AND TIME
TO GATHER FOR QUALIFYING STATE
OFFICER RECALLS AGAIN A MOMENT
REMARKS TO STATE OFFICER
RECALLS NOT LOCAL OFFICE
RECALLS IN THIS ANSWER EXCLUDES
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE SUCH
AS YOURSELVES. SO THESE ISSUES
THE SIGNATURE REQUIREMENT THE
TIME TOGETHER THE TWO SIDES OF
THE SAME COIN DOES DIRECTLY
AFFECT HOW DIFFICULT IT IS TO
CLARIFY RECALL. CHANGING JUST
ONE OF THOSE FACTORS WILL
INCREASE OR DECREASE THE
DIFFICULTY MORE SIGNATURES ARE
HARDER TO GATHER. GATHERING THE
SAME NUMBER OF SIGNATURES AND
SHORTER TIME SMARTER EITHER
INCREASING THE NUMBER WILL
SHORTEN THE TIME CAN BE MORE
COSTLY. CHANGING BOTH THE
NUMBER AND THE TIME IN THE SAME
MANNER MAGNIFIES THE EFFECT
FEWER SIGNATURES WITH LONGER TO
GATHER AS MUCH EASIER. MORE
SIGNATURES IN A SHORTER TIME.
IS VASTLY MORE DIFFICULT AND
EXPENSIVE. BROWN'S IN OPPOSITE
WAY. COMMUTER KANSEN CHU AFFECT
PERMITS MATCHING THESE IN
DIFFICULT. SO GREATLY
INCREASING THE SIGNATURES
MODESTLY INCREASING THE TIME TO
GATHER RESULTS IN A SMALLER
OVER AN INCREASE IN DIFFICULTY.
FIRST OF A SPECIFIC
CONSEQUENCES OF HIGHER
SIGNATURE REQUIREMENT IT
DIRECTLY TRANSLATES TO
INCREASED COST. IT WAS LIKE A
PRESS PER SENATE-ROOM WAS
BETWEEN FIVE AND TEN DOLLARS
FOR THE SEVEN DOLLAR AVERAGE
FOR EXAMPLE TO CALIFORNIA
MISSION IS THAT LIKE THE RECALL
ALSO RECEIVED EXTENSIONS. BUT
IT'S REPORTED COSTA BETWEEN
FIVE AND SEVEN DOLLARS PER
SIGNATURE. THAT'S VERY
EXPENSIVE THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE
QUICKLY PROPONENTS NEEDED ABOUT
ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
SIGNATURES ND ACTUALLY
SUBMITTED ABOUT TWO POINT ONE
MILLION AT SEVEN DOLLARS PER
SIGNATURE THAT'S FIFTEEN
MILLION DOLLARS. THERE'S NO
QUESTION A QUALIFYING COST
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS IN ABOVE
WOULD BEAR SMALL CITIZEN ACTION
GROUPS REALLY. ANYONE WITHOUT
WHAT WEALTHY BACKERS. BOTTLING
A REASON SURGERY. IS LOOKING TO
SOMETHING SIX. AND MAKE IT
PROHIBITIVELY EXPENSIVE. THE
COST REALITY AFFECTS HOW WE
SHOULD VIEW CALIFORNIA RELATION
TO OTHER STATES CALIFORNIA
SEEMS LIKE IT HAS THE LITTLE
SIGNATURE PERCENTAGE OF 12%
THAT IS MY CALLING JUST
EXPLAINED MONTANA HAS ACTUALLY
WAS PERCENTAGE. AND BECAUSE IT
IS THE LARGEST OF OUR
POPULATION CALIFORNIA HAS THE
HIGHEST WIENER SIGNATURES
NUMBER REGARDLESS OF THE
QUALIFYING RULES TIED TO
ELIGILE VOTERS REGISTERED
VOTERS WERE TURNED OUT. WE WERE
ABOUT FOUR TIMES THE POPULATION
OF EITHER OF THE NEXT LARGEST
RECALL STATES BUTCHER ILLINOIS
IN GEORGIA. VIEW AS A PERCENT
OF POP. CALIFORNIA LOOKS LIKE
IT HAS THE LOWEST SIGNATURE
REQUIREMENT REGARDLESS OF THE
QUALIFYING RULE. HI WITH
MONTANA FISH BY ELIGIBLE VOTERS
WOULD USE A PERCENT OF
POPULATION IS POTENTIALLY
MISLEADING BECAUSE CALIFORNIA
HAS THE LARGEST INELIGIBLE
POPULATION AND THE LOWEST
ELIGIBLE AS PERCENT OF
POPULATION. JUST SIXTY FIVE
POINT 7% OF CALIFORNIANS ARE
ELIGIBLE TO VOTE. IN CALIFORNIA
ONLY HAS BY FR THE LARGEST
AFTER DEVIATION FROM THE MEDIAN
REAL SIGNATURE NUMBER
REGARDLESS OF THE WILL OF THE
RULE. MEMBERS OF OUR TRIP AND
BEDIENT IF IT'S BY. VOTERS IN
THE NEW TRIPLES BY. OR BY TWO.
MOVING CALIFORNIA CHAU CLOSE TO
THE AS A PERCENT OF POPULATION
WOULD REQUIRE DOUBLING THE
CURRENT SIGNATURE REQUIREMENT
225% REGARDLESS OF THE RULE.
DOING SO WOULD MAKE CALIFORNIA
DEVIATE KINGDOM FEATHER UPWARD
FROM THE MEDIAN REAL NUMBER.
FOR EXAMPLE INCOME THE PERCENT
OF TURNOUT. WHICH IS THE LOWEST
DENOMINATOR TRANSLATES TO HUGE
COST INCREASES. 20% OF TURNOUT
IS ABOUT THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION SIGNATURES AT SEVEN
DOLLARS PER SIGNATURE THAT'S
TWENTY FIVE MILLION DOLLARS.
25% OF TURNOUT IS ABOUT FOUR
POINT THREE MILLION SIGNATURES
AT SEVEN DOLLARS PER THIRTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS. THAT'S A FEW
YEARS TURNOUT WHICH AGAIN IS
THE LOWEST OF THE DENOMINATORS.
THERE IS AN ARGUMENT FIRST FOR
DIFFERENT REGISTRATIONS THE
MARKET BECAUSE IT'S LESS
VARIABLE THAN TURNOUT SO
SPECIAL TO REGISTER DOES HAVE
SOME ADVANTAGES BUT A PRODUCES
ONLY MINOR FACTS. TURNOUT IS
GENERALLY A LOWER NUMBER
SUBSCRIPTION TO REGISTER ROOM
INCREASE THE SIGNATURE NUMBER
BUT ONLY SLIGHTLY. 20% OF
REGISTERED VOTERS IS ABOUT
THIRTY THREE THOUSAND MORE
SENATORS AND SEVEN BASS PRO
THAT START ABOUT TWENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS. 25% OF
REGISTERED IS ABOUT FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND DOLLARS FIFTY FOUR
THOUSAND MORE SIGNATURES AGAIN
IT'S SEVEN DOLLARS PER BUT
STILL ABOUT THIRTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS. SO SWITCHING TO
REGISTER FROM TURNOUT IS THE
MARKER HAS ONLY MINOR EFFECTS
OF SLAVERY INCREASING
DIFFICULTY IN REDUCING
VARIATION SOMEWHAT. SO IT'S NOT
MUCH OF A REFORM. THAT'S THE
SIGNATURE. THE ANALYSIS GAS
TIME IS. COMPRESSOR INCREASED
DIFFICULTY AND RAISE COSTS
EXPANDING TO. MAKE IT EASIER
AND CAN LOWER COSTS. WHAT'S
IMPORTANT HERE TO CONSIDER THE
EFFECT OF CHANGING BERMAN
NUMBER AND THE TIME. IF YOU
COMBINE INCREASING RESEARCHERS
PRESSED COMPRESSING THE PERIOD
PLUS INCREASING THE COST THAT
IT WAS REQUESTED DIFFICULT TO
QUALIFY THAT NONE EVER WILL. IT
SEEMS UNNECESSARY TO PERMIT THE
INITIATIVE THE REQUEST AND WILL
BE USED MUCH LESS. MAKING IT
HARDER TO USE HE RECALL COULD
TAKE IT FROM A RARE BIRD TO AN
EXTINCT SPECIES. MISTER
WHITAKER FINALLY ISSUED OF
WHICH IS LOWER SIGNATURE
REQUIREMENTS FAR FEWER RECALLS
RATIFY. FROM NINETEEN TWELVE TO
TWENTY SEVENTEEN ONLY 19% OF
THEIR TIME IN THE NATION IS
QUALIFIED FOR THE BALLOT. STATE
OFFICER REQUIRES QUALIFYING
READ IN. THAT SAME TIME PERIOD
6% THE BOTTOM INE TEARS
QUESTION IS HOW DIFFERENT DO
YOU TO MAKE A TO QUALIFY STATE
ON. READ THE PRODUCT PRESS IS-
CALIFORNIAN. TO MAKE IT MORE
DIFFICULT TO QUALIFY THEM. IN A
HUNDRED AND TEN YEARS 94% OF
ESTATE OFFICER RECALLS FAILED
TO QUALIFY. FOR GOVERNOR
SPECIFICALLY 96% FAILED.
INCREASING THE DIFFICULTY AS
WITH MORE SIGNATURES LAST TIME
OR BOTH MR TO BE BACK IN FUTURE
RECALLS WITH SINGLE DIGIT
QUALIFYING RATES AND A HUNDRED
AND TEN YEARS QUESTION WHETHER
THIS IS NECESSARY. GIVEN
HERRERA CLOSER EVEN MODESTLY
INCREASING THE DIFFICULTY COULD
MAKE REQUEST PRACTICALLY
IMPOSSIBLE IN CALIFORNIA. IN
THAT CASE WE WILL BE UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES YOU WILL DISARM
FUTURE DEMOCRATS WHO MIGHT NEED
IT. FINALLY THE NEXT PANEL
CONSIDER CHANGING REPLACEMENT
CANDIDATE QUALIFYING PROCEDURE
AND CHANGING THE ELECTION
MODEL. THERE'S ISSUES POTENTIAL
CHAIRMAN PROVE THE RECALL THEY
ARE VERY IMPORTANT MARIN
MESSAGE IN WHICH SHE BETTER
RESULTS THAN THE ISSUES I HAVE
COVERED. BRIDGE WHERE THE
BROKEN WRIST BREAKING THE
RECALL. THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY. AND I'D BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. OKAY
WE'RE GONNA GUYS I MET
QUESTIONS AT THE END AND I KNOW
YOU HAVE A- HARD STOP AT THREE
SO I THINK WE'LL GET TO THAT
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ASK SOME
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS. THANK YOU
AND SO IT HAS TO STE. STAY
TUNED. NEXT UP WE HAVE BILL
RATE WHALEN. HE IS A VIRGINIA
HOBBS CARPENTER DISTINGUISHED
POLICY FELLOW IN JOURNALISM AND
A HOOVER INSTITUTION RESEARCH
FELLOW SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
NINE. HE WRITES AND COMMENTS ON
CAMPAIGNS ELECTIONS GOVERNANCE.
WITH AN EMPHASIS ON CALIFORNIA
IN AMERICA'S POLITICAL
LANDSCAPES. PRIOR TO JOINING
THE HOOVER INSTITUTION MR WILL
AND SERVED AS CHIEF SPEECH
WRITER AND DIRECTOR OF PUBLIC
AFFAIRS. FOR FORMER GOVERNOR
PETE WILSON. I ALSO AS A
POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT FOR
INSIGHT MAGAZINE AS A SPEECH
WRITER FOR THE BUSH QUAYLE.
REELECTION CAMPAIGN MR WHALEN
WE WELCOME YOU TO OUR HEARING.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN CAN
EVERYONE HEAR ME. WE HEAR YOU A
LITTLE- LIGHTS AND WE DON'T SEE
THERE YOU ARE WE SEE YOU WANT
TO SPEAK UP AGAIN WE CAN MAKE
SURE WE CAN HEAR YOU. CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YEAH YEAH. OKAY GOOD.
WELL THAK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TO
YOU- LET ME JUST KIND OF
QUICKLY JUMP THROUGH A COUPLE
OF THINGS HERE. BECAUSE I KNOW
TIME IS SHORT HERE- I WILL TO
THE SIGNATURE THRESHOLD
QUESTION MYSELF. AND THE
QUESTION I WOULD HAVE IS IF YOU
WANT TO PLAY AT THE THRESHOLD
DO YOU WANT TO CONSIDER MAYBE
RAISING IT TO THE SAME 20%
THRESHOLD THAT APPLIES TO.
STATE SENATORS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MEMBERS OF THE BOARD OF
EQUALIZATION AND APPEALS COURT.
JUDGES I KNOW THIS IS APPLES
AND ORANGES BECAUSE YOU'RE
TAKING A STATEWIDE OFFICE AND
TREATED THE SAME AS A LOCAL
REGIONAL OFFICE BUT- IF THE
IDEA IS TO MAKE THIS A LITTLE
MORE FOLKS POPULI THEN PERHAPS.
YOU WANT TO CONSIDER THE HIGHER
THRESHOLD I DID THE MATH BY THE
WAY IF YOU RAISE 220% YOU'RE
LOOKING AT TWO POINT FOUR NINE
THREE. MILLION SIGNATURES WHICH
MEANS THAT THE LAST RECALL WITH
A FOLLOW SHOT ABOUT SEVEN
DEGREES THIRTY FIVE THOUSAND
VOTES. OTHER OPTION IS TO. KEEP
THE 12% THRESHOLD APPLIED TO
REGISTERED VOTERS FROM WHICH IN
ABOUT TWENTY TWO MILLION THE
LAST TIME I CHECKED. THAT WOULD
REQUIRE TWO POINT SIX MILLION
SIGNATURES SO- AS DAVID
MENTIONED YOU WERE PRETTY MUCH
PUTTING THE RECALL PROCESS OUT
OF THE BUSINESS IF YOU DO
THOSE- I THINK A MUCH MORE
PRACTICAL APPROACH HERE MIGHT
BE ONE OF SIGNATURE GATHERING-
AS MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY I
APOLOGIZE IF I'M REPEATING
ANYTHING I JUMPED ON THIS ABOUT
TWENTY MINUTES AGO AND I. I
MEASURE BROKEN GOING GOOD IN
THE SAME THEMES MAYBE THAT'S
GOOD. THANKS TO A SUGGEST
CONSENSUS HERE. BOB CALIFORNIA
WITH A HUNDRED SIXTY DAYS I
WENT TO THE OTHER EIGHTEEN
RECALL STATE SO. OBVIOUSLY
NOBODY IS CALIFORNIA- BUT I DID
FIND SPREE THAT HAVE ABOUT A
THIRD OF OUR POPULATION THAT'S.
GEORGIA ILLINOIS MICHIGAN. YOUR
REQUIRES NINETY DAY CIRCUIT-
MICHIGAN NINETY DAYS ILLINOIS.
ONE HUNDRED AND FIFTY DAYS. I
WOULD NOT BE AVERSE TO THE IDEA
OF TAKING THE ONE HUNDRED SIXTY
DAY WINDOW UNTIL. YOU GET DOWN
TO LET STATE. ARGUMENT ONE
TWENTY. WHY WOULD THAT BE
BECAUSE I THINK CALIFORNIA
DESPITE THE SIZE A LARGER
POPULATION THE GREATER
GEOGRAPHY. HAS THREE ADVANTAGES
IS OTHER STATES DON'T NUMBER
ONE WE HAVE WELL THE LAST
WEEKEND- NOT INCLUDED. WE HAVE
BETTER WEATHER THAN MOST OTHER
STATES WE'RE NOT GONNA GET
KNOCKED DOWN. FOR A WEEK BY
SNOW STORM OR- OR HURRICANE- SO
IT'S EASIER PHYSICALLY TO GET
OUT AND COLLECT SIGNATURES.
SECONDLY WE SHOULD HAVE BETTER
TECHNOLOGY WHICH BEGS THE
QUESTION IF WE WANT TO EXPLORE
THE IDEA. OF DOING A SIGNATURE
GATHERING ONLINE FOR RECALLS.
AND THEN THIRDLY WE ALREADY
HAVE A BUILT IN PROCESS OF
INITIATIVES WE HAVE A VIBRANT
SIGNATURE GATHERING AT A STREET
IN. THE STATE- AS FOR UP NOW I
WANT TO TAKE YOU QUICKLY TO
AREAS I'LL TAKE YOUR QUESTIONS
HERE ONE. IS I THINK WE NEED TO
CONSIDER THE GROUNDS FOR RECALL
AND HERE I WOULD JOB. CONSIDER
THIS BOB WE WANT TO MAKE A
RECALL VOTE SIMPLY A VOTE OF NO
CONFIDENCE. WE WANT TO MAKE A
RECALL VOTE A CHANCE TO
RELITIGATE THE PAST LEFT AND WE
WANT TO MAKE RECALL SOMETHING
THAT A- LITTLE BIT TO. THE
PUBLIC'S IMPEACHING OF AN
OFFICER IF SO THEN THE QUESTION
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT PIECE
GOT WHICH IS HIGH CRIMES AND
MISDEMEANORS FOR PRESIDENT. I
HOPE WE DON'T GO DOWN THAT ROAD
WITH THAT TERM THAT'S A
TERRIBLE TERM HE WAS I THINK SO
MUCH OPEN SPECULATION ON THAT.
I WOULD REFER YOU TO GEORGIA.
WHICH HAS A VERY SPECIFIC-
FRAMEWORK FOR RECALL HERE'S
WHAT. IT SAYS AND I'M READY TO
VERBATIM QUOTE. I RECALL WAS
TRIGGERED BY QUOTE AN ACT MELFI.
OR MISCONDUCT. OFFICE VIOLATION
OF THE OATH OF OFFICE FAILURE
TO PERFORM DUTIES PRESCRIBED BY
LAW OR WILLFULLY MISUSING
CONVERTING ARE
MISAPPROPRIATING. WITHOUT
AUTHORITY PUBLIC PROPERTY OR
PUBLIC FUNDS ENTRUSTED TO
ASSOCIATED WITH THE ELECTIVE
OFFICE. TO WHICH THE OFFICIAL
HAS BEEN ELECTED OR APPOINTED.
IN OTHER WORDS THIS- POINTS
MORE TO ACTS IN OFFICE MORE
THAN JUST I DON'T LIKE THE WAY
THE GOVERNOR LOOKS I JUST DON'T
LIKE THE PARTY HERE SHE BELONGS
TO. AND PERHAPS YOU ALSO WANT
TO CONSIDER CREATING A YOU KNOW
A PANEL OF RETIRED JUDGES TO
VET THE CONSTITUTIONALITY.
RECALL EFFORT NUMBER TWO IF YOU
HAVE TO. EXPLAIN WHY THE
GOVERNOR SHOULD BE RECALLED
THEN PERHAPS A BODY INDEPENDENT
BODY SHOULD REVIEW WHETHER NOT
IS GOING TO BE CONSTITUTIONAL
AS IT BIGELOW JUDGE ANYWAY. AND
THEN THE OTHER AREA TRY TURN
YOU TO- IT WOULD BE THE TIMING.
MATTERS IF YOU LOOK A WITH ALL
SORTS **** CAME INTO OFFICE. IN
NOVEMBER TWO THOUSAND THREE HE
HAD THREE YEARS TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO RUN THE STATE. MAKE AN
ARGUMENT FOR RE ELECTION. IF
GOVERNOR NEWSOM HAD BEEN
RECALLED AND LARRY ELDER
WHOEVER WOULD HAVE STEPPED IN.
HE WOULD HAVE HAD JUST A FEW
MONTHS TO NUMBER ONE FIGURE OUT
HOW TO WRITE A BUDGET. NUMBER
TO INTRODUCE A LEGISLATIVE
AGENDA WHICH PROBABLY WOULD
HAVE BEEN DEAD ON ARRIVAL
LEGISLATURE. ENDS WITHIN A FEW
MONTHS OF TAKING OFFICE LOOKING
AT A PRIMARY AND IF YOU DIDN'T
FINISH AT LEAST SECOND IN THE
PRIMARY HE WAS A POLITICAL LAME
DUCK. SO I THINK WE NEED TO
CONSIDER THE TIMING OF UP. A
RECALL EFFORTS IN CALIFORNIA.
IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT'S HAPPENING
GOVERNOR NEWSOM- THREE RECALL
EFFORTS WERE FILED AGAINST IT
BEFORE THE BIRTHDAY OF HIS
FIRST YEAR IN OFFICE. STEP
RECALL EVER TO FALL AGAINST NOT
JUST NEWSOME BUT LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
THE SECRETARY OF STATE THE
TREASURE. THE INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER IN THE STATE
COMPTROLLER ALL MARCH FIFTEENTH
TWENTY NINETEEN- THESE TO ME
THE EQUIVALENT OF FRIVOLOUS
LAWSUITS BECAUSE HE REALLY JUST
GOING AFTER. THE PARTY MORE
THAN ANYTHING ELSE NEW JERSEY
HAS A PREVENTION IT WHICH ON
THE RECALL PROCESS MAY NOT
BEGIN UNTIL FIFTY DAYS BEFORE.
THE COMPLETION OF THE
INCUMBENTS FIRST YEAR. OF THE
CURRENT TERM IN OFFICE MAYBE
CAO. SHOULD CONSIDER THAT AS A
WAY TO KIND OF JUST. THE NATURE
RECALLED AND THEN MAYBE KILL.
NEEDS TO THINK ABOUT SOMETHING
ON THE BACK AND PERHAPS YOU
CANNOT HAVE A RECALL AFTER AN
INCUMBENT IS IT MIDWAY. THROUGH
THEIR TERM THAT WAY YOU GET
INTO THIS RATHER COMPRESSED.
UPCYCLED A TON. A WIN FOR THE
PAST RECALL WOULD HAVE BEEN
LOOKING AT. IF I SOUND LIKE A
TILT IN FAVOR THE EXECUTIVE I
PLEAD GUILTY I'VE WORKED FOR
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR- IT'S A
TOUGH ENOUGH JOB WITHOUT
DISTRACTIONS. IRRITANTS FOR
EXAMPLE I THINK WE SHOULD ALSO
CHANGE PROVISION WHICH
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR BECOMES THE
ACTING GOVERNOR. THE GOVERNOR
OF THE STATE- BUT THAT SAID
LET'S KEEP THE RECALL PROCESS
IT HONORS THE STATE'S LEGACY OF
THE POLITICAL CLASS BEING HELD
ACCOUNTABLE. BUT YES IT'S
CONSIDER WAYS TO MAKE THIS EVEN
MORE EXCEPTIONAL AND MORE RARE.
AND WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO THANK
YOU FOR THE INVITATION TO
PARTICIPATE THIS HEARING. ABOUT
COMMEND YOU FOR GIVING THIS THE
SERIOUS DELIBERATE OF THOUGHT
AS WE SHARE THE IDEAL OF
APPROVING CALIFORNIA EXPERIMENT
IN DIRECT DEMOCRACY. THANK YOU
GLAD TO TAKE ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE. THAT THANK YOU MISTER
WILL EXPAND BY IN- YOU KNOW WE
HAVE REALLY DIFFERENT-
PHILOSOPHICAL VIEWS ABOUT MANY
ASPECTS OF GOVERNMENT BUT I.
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE YOUR
THOUGHTFUL. EXAMINE OF WHERE
CAN. A FIND WAYS TO DO IT
BETTER- IN THIS SPACE AND MANY
OTHER SPACES BY THE WAY I AGREE
WITH YOU ABOUT THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR. JUST BECAUSE THE
GOVERNOR LEADS THE STATE IS
THAT. THERE'S NO PHONE PHONE
ACCESS I GUESS- PROCESS LIKE
WE'VE KIND OF GOTTEN A LITTLE
BETTER THERE. BUT SO I WANT TO
INVITE A COLLEAGUES TO ASK
QUESTIONS. OF THESE TWO
PANELISTS. TWO WEEKS. AT THE
CENTER NIELSEN. MISTER WHELAN
THE- BONTA TOUCH BUILT ON THE
GROUNDS FOR THE RECALL.
CALIFORNIA NOW IS IT WOULD BE
THE MORE ONEROUS STATE OR AT
LEAST LESSER AREN'T OWNER STATE
ON TERMS OF GROUNDS FOR RECALL.
IS CALIFORNIA RIGHT DON'T
LISTEN MORE OWNERS I DON'T
UNDERSTAND THE QUESTION OKAY.
DID THAT CALIPHATES CALIFORNIA
REALLY VERY. RESTRICTIVE IN
TERMS OF WHAT CAN BE CONSIDERED.
FOUR RECALLING OR ARE WE VERY
VERY GENEROUS MAKING IT MORE
MODESTY. WE'RE PRETTY WIDE OPEN
UNDERSTAND YOU CAN JUST PUT
YOUR COMPLAINTS ON THE BALLOT
IN A WHERE YOU GO AND IF YOU
LOOK AT THE YOU LOOK AT THE
LAST VEHICLE AGAINST GOVERNOR
NEWSOM WAS RATHER FAMILIAR LIST
OF COMPLAINTS BY THE PARTY THAT
OPPOSES HIM IN TERMS OF- HIS
ACTIONS ON THE DEATH PENALTY IN
TERMS OF IMMIGRATION POLICY. HM
SO. YOU KNOW THE DEEP SET SPEED
RIGHT THAT'S CONCERT IS
INTERPRETING THE GOVERNMENT'S
NOT DOING A GOOD JOB. I JUST
THINK THAT YOU NEED TO ADD A
COMPONENT TO IT WHICH REALLY
GETS TO THE IDEA OF MALFEASANCE
AND JUST NOT PERFORMING HER JOB
PROPERLY. BECAUSE WE CAN ALL
DISAGREE. ON POLICY CHOICES AND
FRANKLY I THINK THAT'S WHAT
REGULAR SCHEDULE ELECTIONS ARE
FOR. BUT ISN'T THAT. TO BE
LITIGATED HEAVILY MALFEASANCE
IT MEANS DIFFERENT THANKS.
RIGHT THAT'S WHY I THINK FIFTY.
RIGHT IT DOES BUT I THINK IT
REALLY GETS DOWN TO A QUESTION
OF CONDUCT UNBECOMING AN
OFFICE. AND WITH THE GOVERNOR
LET'S SAY DOES SOMETHING THAT
YOU OPPOSED TO PHILOSOPHICALLY
I'M NOT SURE THAT REALLY MEANS
OF THE GOVERNOR SHOULD BE
RECALLED FROM HIS OFFICE AGAIN
I THINK WE HAVE A SEAT GARDEN
THAT'S CALLED AN ELECTION.
REGULAR SCHEDULE H. WE DO WE DO
HAVE THAT FOR SURE. YES AND YOU
KNOW IN THIS PARTICULAR
ELECTION. THE PROPONENTS DID
NOT SPEND A LOT OF MONEY DID
NOT HAVE A LOT OF RESOURCES
EITHER TO QUALIFY AND MOST
CERTAINLY NOT TO CAMPAIGN FOR.
GOVERNOR HAD ALMOST UNLIMITED
RESOURCES THE NEW CAMPAIGN.
AGAIN RIGHT AND A LOT OF THEM
CAME FROM NONTRADITIONAL
DEMOCRATIC SOURCES FOR THEIR
OWN REASONS WHATEVER THOSE WERE
THEY CONTRIBUTED HEAVILY. TO
RELISH THE RECALL SHALL I BRING
THAT TO POINT TO BEAR JUST THAT
THERE'S A BALANCING OF FACTORS.
ASCENDED TO QUALIFY HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS TO QUALIFY HOW
DIFFICULT IT IS TO IN FACT
RECALL WHAT GROUNDS FOR THE
RECALL WOULD BE. THE REASON I
OFFER THOSE OBSERVATIONS IS I'M
I'M RGUING I DON'T THINK THAT
THERE'S ANYTHING O AGREE
JUSTLY BROKEN IN CALIFORNIA'S
SYSTEM RIGHT NOW. AND I THINK
IT MISTER CARILLO FURTHER
ALLUDED TO THAT WITH 96% DO NOT
EVEN QUALIFY- GRATEFUL THAT
SHOWS IT'S PRETTY TOUGH IN
CALIFORNIA TO DO A RECALL. AND
SAY WHATEVER YOU WILL ABOUT
HAVING THE OVER WHATEVER YEARS
BUT IT HAS NOT BEEN MUCH. SO I
WOULD SAY THAT OUR SYSTEM HAS
BEEN PRETTY RESPONSIBLE AND
REASONABLE OVER THE YEARS. BUT
IN ALL AREAS WE SPEND WAY TOO
MUCH MONEY IN ELECTIONS. AND
MAYBE. CAMPAIGN FINANCE
LIMITATIONS IN THE CAMPAIGN
PORTION. OF THIS WOULD BE IN
ORDER DO YOU SEE WHAT YOUR
RIGHTS ARE. YOU RESULTS IN
QUESTION PERHAPS WE NEED TO
CONSIDER RUNNING OUT THE
GOVERNOR EVEN IF HE OR SHE IS A
SUBJECT TO RECALL SHOULD HAVE
TO COMPLY BY. CALIFORNIA
CAMPAIGN DONATION LIMITS
BECAUSE IT DOES OPEN UP IN A
COUPLE QUESTION WHICH IS IF I
GIVE FIVE BILLION DOLLARS TO
THE GOVERNOR'S RE ELECTED
GOVERNORS ALL. QUID PRO QUO
POLITICS WHAT I'M EXPECTING IN
RETURN. WELL IF IT DID THERE
CERTAINLY. COULD BE ALLUDED TO
THAT INDEED AND I DO MAKE THE
POINT. THAT THE PROJECT THERE'S
A CHECK AND BALANCE THAT.
PROPONENTS USUALLY TO RECALL.
DO NOT HAVE MANY RESOURCES
TOGETHER SIGNATURES THEY
CERTAINLY DON'T HAVE UNLIMITED
AMOUNTS OF MONEY TO HIRE.
SIGNATURE GATHERERS. BUT IT
COULD BE VERY DIFFERENT IN THE
CAMPAIGN FOR ONE WHO IS AN
ELECTIVE OFFICE OF THE LEVERAGE
THEIR IN THE INHERENT- TO BE
ABLE TO RAISE MONEY. FOR THAT
RECALL EFFORT SHALL DIE I WILL
WHEN I'M TRYING TO GET AT IS
LET'S TAKE THESE THINGS ALL IN
CONTEXT AND WEIGH THEM AGAINST
EACH OTHER NOT JUST MAKE THE
EXCEPTION THAT DOESN'T AGREE
JUST PROBLEM HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK THERE'S CLEARLY NOT IN
THE GREGIS PROBLEM. THERE MAY
BE SOME FINE TUNING IN ORDER.
BUT NOT AN EGREGIOUS PROBLEM.
AN IMPORTANT THING IS TO
REMEMBER RATHER HOW THEY DID
NOT WORK CALYXT ORDINARILY WELL
IT HAS WORKED FOR THE DECADES
INSURING. THE CITIZENS THEIR
VOICE THROUGH THE INITIATIVE
THE REFERENDUM ON THE RECALL. I
KNOW THAT'S A GOOD. THANK YOU
CENTER NIELSEN. MISTER WHELAN-
YOU KNOW LET'S LET'S HAVE A
LITTLE FUN HERE FOR A MOMENT-
LET'S SAY THAT THE RECALL
HAPPEN AND GOVERNOR USES FIRST
YEAR VERSUS IS THIRTY YEAR. AND
OUT OF THE PROCESS THAT EXISTS
TODAY MISTER ELDER BECOMES THE
GOVERNOR. SO AND IT ONE OF THE
THINGS I FIND INTERESTING ABOUT
THIS DISCUSSION A RECALL REFORM
IS THAT IT'S ONCE AGAIN PUT IN
A POLITICAL PRISM OF THE
MOMENT. BUT LET'S SAY UNDER
THIS SCENARIO- THE GET NOW
GOVERNOR ELDER. HAD STRONG
VIEWS ABOUT TO ISSUES OF-
CHOICE. OF GUNS RIGHT. OF
OFFSHORE OIL OF CLIMATE CHANGE.
HOW HARD DO YOU THINK IT WOULD
HAVE BEEN FOR THE DEMOCRATS TO
TAKE A LESS THAN A YEAR'S WORTH
OF DECISIONS ARE EXECUTIVE
ACTIONS. THAT THEY DIFFERED
WITH TO THEN QUALIFY RECALL
AGAINST NOW REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR
ELDER- WELL AGAIN IT WITHOUT A
STANDARD OF MALFEASANCE. AS WE
AS YOU HAVE ALLUDED TO. THERE
WOULD BE NO THERE IS NO REASON
WHY THE DEMOCRATS WOULD WANT TO.
REVISIT THAT ELECTION AGAIN
WHEN YOU SUGGEST GIVEN. HIS
ELECTION IN A RECALL THAT MIGHT
HAVE BEEN MUCH LESS THAN A
MAJORITY VOTE. THERE WOULD BE
MULTIPLE RECALL EFFORTS AGAINST
REGARDLESS BECAUSE I THINK THIS
IS THE WAY THAT CALIFORNIA
POLITICS ARE RIGHT NOW- PETE
WILSON HAD EIGHT RECALL
ATTEMPTS AGAINST HIM CHORE TO
BEIJING HAD ELEVEN. JERRY BROWN
HAD FIVE GAVIN NEWSOM'S HAD SIX
SO FOR AN AVERAGE OF TWO YEARS
SO HE MY SHATTER THE RECORD
SO. I WOULD ARGUE THAT IF LARRY
ELDER WERE IN OFFICE YOU WOULD
SEE MULTIPLE RECALL EFFORTS THE
QUESTION WOULD BE. HOW MANY
HELP IF ANY OF THEM WOULD
ACTUALLY REACH THE THRESHOLD OF
GETTING ON THE BALLOT THAT
SUGGESTS THE GIVEN HOW MANY
MILLIONS OF DEMOCRATS ARE IN
CALIFORNIA. WOULD NOT BE HARD
TO QUALIFY. THE RECALL EFFORT
IF YOU JUST HAVE THE TIME IN
THE MUSCLE TO PUT BEHIND IT AND
THERE'S ENOUGH MUSCLE
CALIFORNIA DO THAT SO. I THINK
WE WOULD LOOK AT A SITUATION
WHERE THE PROBABLY WOULD'VE
BEEN A RECALL ELECTION THE
FOLLOWING YEAR AND JUST YOU
KNOW THIS IS NOT A LOT OF WHAT
GOOD WAY TO RUN A REAL WORLD IS
NOT A GOOD. WAY TO RUN
GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU FOR A- AT.
ABOUT HYPE OF. BUT NOT SO FAR
OFF HYPOTHETICAL UNDER THAT. IN
THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES I WANT TO
BRING BACK UP FOR A- PROFESSOR
CARILLO. A PROFESSOR CARILLO.
USED AS THE BASIS FOR YOUR
CONCERNS ABOUT A SIGNATURE
CHANGE THE ISSUE OF THE COST
PER SIGNATURE. BASED ON I GUESS
I'LL STARKELDATA. THAT YOU
HAVE LOOKED AT IN THAT SPACE.
BUT I WANT TO BRING YOU TO THE
TWO RECALLS THAT WE HAVE JUST
EXPERIENCED IN THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS- DO YOU KNOW WHAT THE
COST PER- PER SIGNATURE WAS ON
THE RECALL THAT WE JUST WENT
THROUGH. IN- IN TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. YES I BELIEVE IT WAS IN
THE FIVE TO SEVEN DOLLAR RANGE
AND FOR TWO THOUSAND THREE
HISTORICALLY AND BELIEVES IN
THE TO THE THREE DOLLAR RANGE.
RIGHT BUT THAT WOULD MEAN THAT
THE PRO RECALL SUPPORTERS SPENT
OVER TEN MILLION DOLLARS T
QUALIFY THAT MEASURE FOR THE
BALLOT. IN ONE. AND THIS IS
BASED ON PUBLIC ACCOUNTS MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT IT WAS AN
ALL VOLUNTEER EFFORT UP UNTIL
THE POINT THAT THEY GOT AN
EXTENSION OF TIME. AND AT THAT
POINT THEY GOT AN INFUSION OF
CASH IN IT I THINK IF YOU LOOK
AT THE RULING COUNT OF
SIGNATURES. IT'S PRETTY CLEAR
THAT DURING THE VOLUNTEER
PERIOD ABSENT THE EXTENSION
THEY WERE NOT ON PACE TO
QUALIFY. IT WAS THE FACT THAT
THE EXTENSION HAPPENED AND THEN
THE MOMENT CAME IN THOSE TWO
THINGS COMBINED. ALLOWED THEM
TOGETHER ENOUGH SIGNATURES.
RIGHT BUT WHAT IS THE RECORD
SHALL AND HOW MUCH THEY REYES
TO QUALIFY THE RECALL FOR THE
BALLOT WHAT ARE THE FACTS SHOW
THEIR- THAT I DON'T KNOW I
DON'T KNOW WHAT IT WITH THE
ULTIMATE REYES WAS. OKAY
BECAUSE I WOULD WELCOME THAT-
THAT INFORMATION TO THE
COMMITTEE BECAUSE I BELIEVE IT
WAS SUBSTANTIALLY LESS. SO THE
PROGRESS. YEAH WITHOUT BUT
BECAUSE THE PREMISE OF YOUR
CONCERNS IS THAT IT'S SEVEN
DOLLARS A SIGNATUREYET. IN
THIS LATEST RECALL WAS EVEN
CLOSE TO SEVEN DOLLARS A
SIGNATUR THAT I'M JUST KIND
OF. TRY TO GET THE FACTS ON ON
THE PREMISE THAT YOU'RE SETTING
THE FOUNDATION FOR WHY YOU'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT. RAISING THAT
SIGNATURE LIMIT. IT'S NOT A ONE
TO ONE COMPARISON BECAUSE AS I
SAID THIS THIS RECALL EFFORT
WAS SPLIT YOU KNOW IT'S A
HYBRID OF WHAT WILL BE TAKE
WHICH HERE IS THAT. THE COST
INVOLVED IT'S VERY IS
PROHIBITIVELY DIFFICULT FOR
EVERYONE TO HEAR SIGNATURE
GATHERING EFFORT. TO SUCCEED IN
QUALIFYING A RECALL FOR THE
BALLOT AND EVEN REMOTELY
QUALIFIED TO THINK THIS TWENTY
TWENTY ONE RECALL IT IS AN
EXAMPLE OF THAT APPROVED A
POINT BECAUSE THEY WERE NOT ON
PACE. ABSENT THE EXTENSION OF
TIME WHICH THEN BROUGHT IN
NATIONAL MONEY THAT ALLOWED
THEM TO PAY SIGNATURE GATHERERS
SO THAT'S. OPPOSED TO THINGS
THAT THEY WERE TO FAIL. YEAH SO
I. THAT AND LOOK FORWARD TO
GETTING THE FACTS ON EXACTLY
HOW MUCH WAS. SPENT TO QUALIFY
THE SIGNATURES BECAUSE IT DOES
GO TO THE HEART THE PREMISE OF.
THE TESTIMONY THAT YOU PROVIDED
TO US TODAY JERRY BERMAN OF A
FOLLOW UP QUESTION YES SO. THE
COUPLE THOUGHTS REALLY
APPRECIATE BOTH PRESENTATIONS I
MEAN I DON'T YOU THAT THE FOR
THE FACT THAT IT WAS NOT ON.
PACE TO QUALIFY. WHAT WAS
REALLY JUST. A KIND OF A- THE
SIGNAL OF WHAT WE EVENTUALLY
SAW. WHICH IS THAT IT FAILED
SPECTACULARLY RIGHT IT GOT 38%
OF THE VOTE WE SPENT THE STATE
SPENT ALMOST THREEHUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS- AND HAVE A
MASSIVEAMOUNT OF DISTRACTION.
TO OUR OUR GOVERNING PROCESS
FOR SOMETHING THAT CLEARLY DID
NOT HAVE A MAJORITY SUPPORT- OF
CALIFORNIANS AND SO WHAT I
WOULD LOVE TO DO IS FIGURE OUT
A PROCESS. BY WHERE YOU NEED
THE PROCESS TO QUALIFY. SHOW
SOME SORT OF CERTAINTY THAT
YOU'RE AT LEAST GOING TO GET
CLOSE. YOU KNOW IT DOES HAVE
THE GUARANTEE THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO GET A MAJORITY OF THE VOTE.
TO RECALL THE GOVERNOR- OR THE
ELECTED OFFICIAL BUT IT SHOWS
THAT. YOU'RE AT LEAST GOING TO
BE COMPETITIVE I AM TRYING TO
MAKE THAT ARGUMENT AND THAT
THERE IS A CLOSE TO A MAJORITY
OFPEOPLE IN A JURISDICTION TO
AGREE WITH YOU- A ABOUT IT. I
ALSO WONDER YOU KNOW WHENEVER
YOU RECALL PROCESS WAS
ESTABLISHED. IN ADDITION
WITHOUT A DIRECT DEMOCRACY
POLICIES BY. YOU KNOW- THE
FUTURE GOVERNOR JEB- HIRAM
JOHNSON. THE HUNDRED TEN YEARS
AGO. I CAN'T IMAGINE HE WAS.
FIGURE YOU KNOW DETERMINING THE
POLICIES BASED ON PAID
SIGNATURE GATHERERS FOREIGN
EFFORT. I THINK THE IDEA IS
THAT THERE'S A POPULAR
UPRISING- AND THAT THEREFORE.
WITH DIFFERENT GROUPS ACROSS
THE STATE HAVE THE ABILITY TO
HAVE THE- URGENCY AND ENERGY
AND INTEREST- TO VOLUNTEER
THEIR TIME TO COLLECT
SIGNATURES IN YOUR AYE I
TOTALLY AGREE THAT THAT MIGHT
NOT BE. THAT MIGHT NOT GET TO A
100% OF THE WAY THERE. BUT
THAT'S TO BE A SIGNIFICANT.
PART OF THE SIGNATURE GAHERING
PROCESS AND THEN IF YOU NEED TO
CAP IT OFF WITH PAID
SIGNATURES- TO GET OVER THE
HUMP. YOU KNOW THEN THEN THEN
THAT'S VALID BUT I DON'T
NECESSARILY THINK WE SHOULD DO
AN ANALYSIS THAT ASSUMES. THAT
EVERY SIGNATURE THAT IS
GATHERED NEEDS TO BE DONE BY.
BY PAID SIGNATURE GATHERERS. SO
THAT'S THAT'S A LITTLE MORE OF
A- APPOINTED A HAPPY THAT TO
HAVE FOLKS COMMENTS- BUT WAS
REALLY ALSO. KIND OF IMPRESSED
BY. SOME OF THE COMMENTS FROM
ISRAEL AND- THAT WERE VERY
SIMILAR MISTER WILL YOU DON'T
KNOW THIS BECAUSE BECAUSE YOU
CAN GET A CHANCE TO JUMP ON
INTO A LITTLE BIT AGO- BUT WERE
VERY SIMILAR TO COMMENTS ARE
MADE BY CENTER SQUISHY. ESCU
TIA- IN IN A PRIOR PANEL. WHERE
SHE ALSO POINTED US TO GEORGIA-
IN THAT EXACT LANGUAGE THAT YOU
MENTIONED- IN GEORGIA'S RECALL
PROCESS AND HAVING SOME
DEFINITION AROUND MALFEASANCE-
AND DIFFERENT WAYS THAT
CALIFORNIA MIGHT DEFINE THAT.
IF THAT'S A- A WAY THAT WE WANT
TO GO SO YOU KNOW THAT WAS
THAT. YOU KNOW THAT PLUS. THE
POINTS AROUND THE DISTRACTION
AND YOU'RE A TENSE THAT THAT
RECALL. LAW CREATES- WERE VERY
SIMILAR TO COMMENTS MADE BY.
FORMER ASSEMBLYMEMBER JIM CAN
MEAN- SO WE'RE SEEING SOME SOME
KIND OF. COMMON THREADS HERE-
BUT THAT'S THAT'S- YOU KNOW MY
QUICK COMMENTS I KNOW. OF THE
MR CHRIS GOT TO GO SOON. YES
NUMBER. COMPOUND THANK YOU
THANK YOU. OUR REAL QUICK THE
COST THAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT
PER SIGNATURE I WANT TO MAKE
THIS REALLY CLEAR IS NOT BORNE
BY THE STATE IT IS BORN BY HOME.
THAT'S MY TO PROPONENTS SO THEY
HAVE TO GO OUT THEY HAVE TO
RAISE MONEY THEY HAVE TO GET
PEOPLE TO DONATE SO THAT THEY
CAN GET. A SIGNATURE EFFORT IN
PLACE- WE KEEP GOING BACK TO
OUR LAST. EFFORT AND TALKING
ABOUT THE EXTENSION THE
EXTENSION OF TIME ONCE IN A
PARTISAN THING IT WAS GIVEN BY
JUDGE BECAUSE OF COVERT. AND
COVERT AFFECTED A LOT OF THINGS
AND YOU'RE RIGHT AND ALL IT
DOES IS KIND OF PROVE. THAT
THIS IS A VERY DIFFICULT
PROCESS AND EVEN THIS PROCESS
THAT DO WE JUST WENT THROUGH
WOULD NOT HAVE QUALIFIED. IF
THE JUDGE HAD GIVEN THEM MORE
TIME TO GO GET SIGNATURES. SO
TO ME WHEN WE TALK ABOUT A
BROKEN PROCESS. WELL WASN'T
BROKEN WE WILL KNOW SPENT THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS OF
WHICH AFTER REMIND US SOME OF
THAT IS OUR OWN DOING. WHEN WE
WHEN WE CHOOSE. TO TAKE 50% OF
THE BALANCE THAT WE MAIL OUT
AND THROW THOSE AWAY THAT'S
THREE BUCKS A PIECE IN THIS
PARTICULAR ELECTION. YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS. TWENTY TO THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS GOING INTO THE
TRASH. OKAY SO WHEN WE TALK
ABOUT COSTS. THAT'S THE PART
WHERE WE HAVE TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT COST NOT THIS PART. THIS
PART IS THE PEOPLE THAT ARE MAD
ENOUGH. AND ANGRY ENOUGH TO GO
AHEAD AND DO THAT- SO- ONE OF
THE OTHER. POINTS I WANTED TO
MAKE WEB I'D LOST IT NOW SO.
ANYWAY BUT THAT'S ALL I HAVE
FOR YOU MISTER COREY I KNOW YOU
HAVE TO DO IT GET GOING SO- I
APPRECIATE THE YOUR ANALYSIS
AND YOUR EXPLANATIONS. OF
SOMETHING THAT WAS IN MY HEAD
AND I WAS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO ARTICULATED AND YOU
ARTICULATED VERY WELL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY NUMBER. OKAY I WANT TO
THANK POSTUP PROFESSOR CARILLO
AND MR WHELAN. FOR YOUR
TESTIMONY CARE. BERMAN AND I WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT. IMPORTANT
VOICES THE THOUGHTFUL VOICES TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THIS THE DEBATE.
IT WASN'T ABOUT ONE POINT OF
VIEW OR ANOTHER BUT A BROAD
RANGE OF PERSPECTIVES AND WE
AND YOU YOU BUT YOU BOTH HAVE
BROUGHT THAT TO OUR-
CONVERSATION TODAY I WOULD NOTE
THAT PROFESSOR CREO THAT YOU-
PUT FORWARD A UP. A BROADER
THOUGHT PIECE ON THIS WHOLE
SUBJECT AREA WE DIDN'T GET THE
CHANCE TO TALK ABOUT ALL THOSE
L. EXTRA AREAS BUT- IT'S A PART
OF OUR RECORD WILL HAVE MAKE IT
AVAILABLE ON OUR WEBSITE FOR
OTHERS WHO ARE INTERESTED IN
IT. I SEAT UP THE CENTER
NIELSEN HAS COME FORWARD WITH
IT I THINK OF ALL OF. MORE OF
AN OBSERVATION. GERMAN AND
COLLEAGUES THAT. THIS PART.
RECALL WAS I THANK MORE A
PRODUCT. OF CITIZEN
DISSATISFACTION WITH THE
EXERCISE OF GOVERNORS OF
FLORIDA E. THAT REALLY EXCEEDED
HIS AUTHORITY NOW. IN PART THAT
IS A PART OF THE LEGISLATURE
BECAUSE FOR DECADES. MOST
RECENTLY THE LAST TEN YEARS
THAT I'VE BEEN BACK. THE
LEGISLATURE REGULARLY HAS SHE
AND THE PEOPLE'S AUTHORITY TO
THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT TO MAKE UNILATERAL
DECISIONS. MOST RECENTLY IN THE
LAST BUDGET. A PROVISION
FORTUNATELY THAT WAS REMOVED
THAT SAID MONIES THAT COULD BE
EXPANDED FOR FORCED A WILDLAND
PROTECTION WOULD BE SUBJECT TO
THE APPROVAL OF THE DEBATE THAT
THE DETERMINATION OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THAT IT
WAS QUOTE NEEDED. NOW THAT'S
CLEARLY. USURPING AUTHORITY BUT
THE LEGISLATURE IS EXPRESSLY
BEEN GIVEN MORE AUTHORITY TO
GOVERNORS AND GOVERNORS AND
PRESIDENTS BOTH PARTIES. HAVE
EXERCISED THEIR AUTHORITY I
THINK BEYOND WHAT THEY SHOULD.
IT'S RIGHT LET AT THE IMPROPER
THAT THE CITIZENS SHOULD BE
UPSET ABOUT THAT I THINK THAT
WAS A BIGGER FACTORED IN THE
NUMBERS OF SIGNATURES THAT WERE
REQUIRED. THAN ANYTHING ELSE
THE POLICY. THERE PROBABLY WERE
PLENTY OF THE OCEAN BUT I THINK
THE PUBLIC IS GETTING PRETTY
FED UP. WITH THE LEGISLATURE
GIVEN MORE AUTHORITY JACQUI
BRANCH AND THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
THROUGH THE ADMINISTRATIVE
AGENCIES USURPING THEIR POWER
OR STARTING THEIR POWER.
THROUGH UNDERGROUND REGULATIONS
AND THEY GET AWAY WITH THANK
YOU MR CENTER NIELSEN THANK YOU
FOR YOUR YOUR YOUR THOUGHTS. I
WOULD NOTE THAT. THERE ARE SOME
EXAMPLES EVEN THE ONES THAT YOU
ARE CITING IN WHICH THE REMEDY
WAS THROUGH THE COURTS TO
CHALLENGE THOSE DECISIONS AND
IN SOME CASES THEY WERE. THEY
WERE REVERSED SO THERE WAS
REMEDIES WITHIN THE LAW ABSENT
THE RECALL TO TRY TO. GET THE-
THE RESULTS THAT YOU DESIRED-
AND I THINK THAT WHAT UP.
THROUGH A GROUP THAT MR WHELAN
HAS EVER WAITED ON AS HAVE
OTHERS IS THAT IS A POLICY
DISAGREEMENT EVEN OLD LEGAL
DISAGREEMENT- THE STANDARD IN
WHICH WE SHOULD USE TODAY- OR
SHOULD THERE BE A HIGHER
STANDARD THAT SHOULD BE- IN
PLACE AND THAT'S THAT WERE THE
DEBATE THAT WILL CONTINUE TO
HAPPEN. SO PROFESSOR CREEL
THANK YOU MISTER WHELAN THANK
YOU FOR. YOUR CONTINUED
ENGAGEMENT ON THIS IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION AND WITH THAT
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THIS PANEL
AND- TURN IT OVER TO CHAIR. A
BERMAN TO CONTINUE THANK YOU
CHAIR GLAZER AROUND A BRIEF
INTERLUDE TO- GO BACK TO-
SUPERVISOR MCPHERSON IF
SUPERVISOR MCPHERSON. IS STILL
THERE I BELIEVE YOU HAVE A
COMMENT THAT HE WANTED TO MAKE-
IN REGARDS TO ONE OF THE PRIOR
PANELISTS. MISTER MCPHERSON
AGAINST. YEAH ARE YOU HERE I
I'M SORRY OPEN NOT A DOING THIS
BUT NOT ALL. MR MORGAN SAID
THERE WERE FIVE STATE WHO
REPLACED BY I WAS JUST CURIOUS.
WHO MADE REAP MUCH- AND- WAS
THERE ANY RIGHT YOU'RE HERE.
ARE THEY MAKING THEIR THE
QUALIFICATIONS THAT REQUIRE.
ALL GOOD QUESTIONS THAT WE WILL
IN TO I DON'T THINK MISTER
WILLIAMS IS STILL STILL ONLINE-
BUT BUT IT'S A GREAT QUESTION-
SO SOMETHING THAT WILL LOOK AT
INTO- BETWEEN NOW IN THE NEXT
HEARING. THANK YOU FOR RAISING
THAT. SO WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
THE FINAL PANEL OF TODAY'S
HEARING- THIS PANEL WILL
DISCUSS VARIOUS PROPOSALS FOR
CHANGING THE PROCESS. FOR
REPLACING A RECALLED OFFICIAL
SO MAYBE THIS IS- EXECUTIVE
MISTER MCPHERSON'S POINT I
DON'T KNOW IF ANY OF OUR
PANELISTS- HAVE- THE ANSWERS
MISTER MCPHERSON'S QUESTION.
STARTING US OFF IS JESSICA A.
LEVINSON A PROFESSOR AT LOYOLA
LOYOLA LAW SCHOOL WERE FISH
WHERE SHE FOCUSES ON
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW. AND
ELECTIONLAW. SHE'S ALSO THE
DIRECTOR OF LOYOLA'S PUBLIC
SERVICE INSTITUTE. AND THE
ASSOCIATE DIRECTOR OF THE
JOURNALISTS LAW SCHOOL AND
PROFESSOR LEVINSON PREVIOUSLY
SERVED AS THE PRESIDENT. OF THE
LOS ANGELES ETHICS COMMISSION-
THE PROFESSOR LEVINSON- AND
WHEN WE WHAT WE'LL TAKE THEM
ONE AT A TIME. R. AND IT IS ONE
OF THE AVAILABLE IS DOWN THE
WHOLE TIME TO THINK. SO ABOUT
CERTAINLY NOT BEYOND GOT IT- SO
HOPEFULLY- WE CAN HAVE
EVERYBODY PARTICIPATE IN THE
MAYBE ASK WESTON'S. AT THE END-
BUT IF ANYBODY IF ANY OF MY OF
MY COLLEAGUES. YEAH REALLY HAVE
A BURNING QUESTION THEY WANT TO
ASK A SPECIFIC PANELIST
IMMEDIATELY LET ME KNOW- SO
PROFESSOR LEVINSON. PLEASE
PLEASE BEGIN. ALL RIGHT WELL
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING
ME- I CAN'T STAY ON PASSED
ABOUT THREE FORTY SO I DON'T
KNOW IF THAT AFFECTS HOW YOU
WANNA TAKE THE QUESTIONS SO YOU
ASK ME OF COURSE TO SPEAK ABOUT
SOMETHING PRETTY NARROW WHICH
IS JUST THE REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE REPLACEMENT CANDIDATES AND
I'M GONNA START BY SAYING
SOMETHING MAYBE KIND OF
SUBVERSIVE ANYTHING TO MISTER
MCPHERSON'S POINT ARTIST
QUESTION WHICH IS I ACTUALLY
DON'T THINK WE SHOULD HAVE
REPLACEMENT CANDIDATES I THINK
THAT WE IF WE HAVE A RECALL AND
IT TO BE A LOT HARDER HARDER TO
HAVE A RECALLS THEN WE SHOULD
GO THROUGH AN APPOINTMENT
PROCESS OR IN THE CASE. OF A
GOVERNOR BEING RECALLED WE
SHOULD GO THROUGH THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR AND I'LL
MAKE MY POINTS REALLY BRIEF
AFTER THIS BUT I'LL JUST SAY
YOU KNOW I LISTEN TO A LOT OF
THE TESTIMONY SO FAR OBVIOUSLY
REALLY USEFUL AND- I WOULD SAY
IS THE RECALL. YOU KNOW A
REALLY SCREWED UP SYSTEM TO USE
A LEGAL TERM ABSOLUTELY IS IT
WORTH FIXING I'M NOT ENTIRELY
CLEAR ON THAT IF YOU JUST LOOK
AT THE NUMBERS OF HOW OFTEN WE
USE IT AND HOW OFTEN IT
SUCCESSFUL SO IS THIS THE
SYSTEM YOU WOULD EVER WANT TO
USE AND DESIGN IN A MILLION
YEARS NOW IS THIS THE SYSTEM
THAT WE SHOULD REALLY SPEND A
LOT OF TIME TRYING TO REFORM
BECAUSE WE THINK THERE'S A
CHANCE OF THIS ACTUALLY PASSING
ON THE BALLOT. PROBABLY NOT
LET'S REMEMBER IF THERE'S ONE
THING THAT TENDS TO UNITE OUR
VOTERS NOT JUST DEMOCRATS NOT
JUST REPUBLICANS FOR ALL VOTERS
IT'S THE WHIFF OF ANYTHING THAT
WOULD LOOK LIKE TAKING POWER
AWAY FROM THEM SO I WOULD JUST
CAUTION YOU TO YOU KNOW THE BIG
REFORMS I DON'T THINK YOU'RE
GOING TO BE POPULAR SO. ONE
THING TO THINK ABOUT YOU ASKED
ME TO SPEAK VERY BRIEFLY ABOUT
BASICALLY HOW COULD WE CHANGE
THE- WELL LET'S BE BLUNT HOW
CAN WE GET RID OF THE SO CALLED
CLOWN CAR RATE HOW CAN WE MAKE
THAT AREN'T FORTY SIX
CANDIDATES RUNNING AND THAT YOU
KNOW THREE OF THEM ARE
COMPETITIVE. AND THE- ANSWER IS.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
CALIFORNIA ELECTIONS CODE AND
REALIZE WHAT YOU ALL KNOW WHICH
IS THAT THE WAY WE DETERMINE
THE QUALIFICATIONS FOR THE
RECALL CANDIDATES IS THE SAME
WAY WE DETERMINE QUALIFICATIONS
FOR. CANDIDATES FOR THAT OFFICE
IN A REGULAR ELECTION SO THE
THRESHOLD QUESTION THAT YOU
HAVE TO ANSWER FOR YOURSELVES
IS BASICALLY. DO YOU WANT TO
CHANGE THE LAW SO THAT'S NO
LONGER THE CASE. SO THAT THE
WAY YOU DETERMINE THE
QUALIFICATIONS TO BE GOVERNOR
IS DIFFERENT FROM THE WAY YOU
DETERMINE THE QUALIFICATIONS TO
BE. A REPLACEMENT CANDIDATE IN
A GUBERNATORIAL RECALL- OR DO
YOU WANT TO CHANGE THE
QUALIFICATIONS FOR. CANDIDATES
PERIOD SO THAT'S JUST SOMETHING
THAT YOU SHOULD CONSIDER AND BE
AWARE OUR FRIEND. SECOND THING
IS OF COURSE THERE'S REALLY TWO
LEVERS TO PULL HERE RIGHT
THERE'S THE FILING FEE
WHATEVER. AND THEN THERE'S THE
SIGNATURE GATHERING LAST LEVER
AND YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD A LOT
ABOUT THIS. TO SAY DOES IT MAKE
SENSE TO MAKE IT HARDER. AND
THE ANSWER IS YES IT MAKES
SENSE TO MAKE IT HARDER BECAUSE
WE'VE JUST LIVED THROUGH. A
RECALL ELECTION WHERE. I MEAN
SHOW OF HANDS FOR PEOPLE WHO
WORK ON THE BALLOT AND BEING A
LITTLE FACETIOUS HERE BUT-
THERE WERE A LOT OF PEOPLE ON
THE BALLOT IN. MOST OF THEM HAD
NO CHANCE OF BEING THE NEXT
GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA. AND
THEN. THE LAST AND WE CAN TALK
MORE ABOUT THAT BUT I WOULD SAY
SHOULD WE MAKE IT HARDER GAS.
WHAT'S THE BEST NUMBER. YOU
KNOW IT. I DON'T AND I DON'T
KNOW EXCEPT TO SAY THAT YOU
CERTAINLY DON'T WANT TO MAKE IT
SO THAT THERE'S ONLY TWO PEOPLE
WHO CAN AFFORD THE FILING FEE-
YOU ALSO WANT TO MAKE IT SO
THAT YOU GET THE SIRIUS CANADA
THE LAST THING I WOULD SAY IS
WHEN YOU'RE THINKING ABOUT THE
RECALL CANDIDATES LET'S ALWAYS
HAVE IN MIND THE VOTERS THE
VOTERS HAVE A SMALL PERIOD OF
TIME TO TRY AND READ UP ON
SOMEBODY WHO MIGHT BE THEIR
NEXT GOVERNOR LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR STATE LAWMAKER. AND SO
IF THERE'S ANYTHING IN THAT
BUCKET OF QUALIFICATIONS FOR
THE NEXT- QUALIFICATIONS FOR
THE RECALL CANDIDATES THAT YOU
CAN THINK OF THAT WOULD PROVIDE
THE VOTERS OF MORE INFORMATION
MAYBE IT YOU HAVE TO RESPOND TO
A BIPARTISAN QUESTIONNAIRE
MAYBE IT'S A ROOT MORE ROBUST
STATEMENT OF ECONOMIC INTERESTS
I WOULD OFFER FOR YOU IT'S
PROBABLY NOT AND I YOU KNOW
RELEASE YOUR TAXES WE CAN FAX
OBVIOUSLY BEEN AN ISSUE WE CAN
LEAVE THAT TO THE SIDE FOR A
SECOND BUT WHENEVER YOU'RE
THINKING ABOUT ANY OF THESE
REFORMS TO THE RECALL I WOULD
ENCOURAGE YOU TO CONTINUE DOING
WHAT YOU'RE ALREADY DOING.
WHICH IS THINK ABOUT HOW TO
SERVE THE VOTERS YOU DO NOT
WANT ME VOTING FOR ALL OF MY
FRIENDS ALL OF MY PARENTS
FRIENDS BECAUSE THEY ALL SAY TO
ME JESSICA WHO'S A GOOD
CANDIDATE WHO WHAT SHOULD WE
VOTE FOR WHAT WE NEED TO NOW
OKAY LET'S NOT RELY ON ME LET'S
ALLOW THE VOTERS TO RELY ON
THEIR OWN JUDGMENT. AND WITH
THAT IT'S PROBABLY WELL OVER
FIVE MINUTES NO THAT'S THAT
THAT'S GREAT AND DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR BLUNTNESS
ON THE LIST OF X. SO WELL I
THINK WE SHOULD WHAT WILL KEEP
IN MIND THE THREE FORTY- TIME
LIMIT BUT LET'S TRY TO GO ON
THE ASSEMBLY OTHER PRESENTERS
AND THEN COME BACK FOR BROAD
QUESTIONS THE NEXUS- FACT
CAL'S- PROFESSOR OF POLITICAL.
AND COTERA. I'M NOT READ OUT MY
RIGHT- TALKING POINTS WE WILL
NOW HEAR. FROM FACT HAUSER THE
PROFESSOR POLITICAL SCIENCE AND
CO DIRECTOR OF THE YANKELOVICH
CENTER FOR SOCIAL SCIENCE
RESEARCH AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA SAN DIEGO DOCTOR
CAL'S- JOIN THE POLITICAL
SCIENCE DEPARTMENT. AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA SAN
DIEGO IN TWO THOUSAND THREE AND
IT SERVED AS CHAIR SINCE TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN HE SAID HIS
AMERICAN STATE AND NATIONAL
POLITICS VOTING REFORMS. DIRECT
DEMOCRACY AND HOW LIKE IT
OFFICIALS USE SOCIAL MEDIA-
PROFESSOR CAL'S- READY WHEN YOU
ARE. THANK WELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND I WANT TO BE. I'M JUST
SHARING MY INDIVIDUAL VIEW
TODAY- AND IN NO WAY REFLECT
THOSE HE SEES AS A WHOLE SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH TEARS GLAZER
AND BERMAN AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. COURT IN TWO WAYS THAT
WE- CALL MORE EVIDENCE OF THE
WILL OF THE PEOPLE. SO THE
THERE ARE MANY IDEAS THAT I
DESERVE USE YOUR CENSORSHIP BUT
TO MY MIND THE SINGLE BIGGEST
AND MOST IN FACT IMPACTFUL
CHANGE WOULD BE TO SEPARATE THE
PROCESS OF HOLDING A RECALL
ELECTION FROM THE PROCESS OF
SELECTING A REPLACEMENT CAN. BY
KEEPING A SEPARATE WE CAN HAVE
THE RECALL PROPERLY FOCUSED ON
WHETHER THE OFFICE HOLDERS SUCH
AS THE GOVERNOR IS TRULY FIT
FOR OFFICE AND THEN IF IT
SUCCEEDS YOU COULD HAVE STRONG
CANDIDATES FROM BOTH PARTIES
FREE TO ENTER THE REPLACEMENT
CONTEST AND THEY WOULD COMPETE
FOR THE VOTES OF A LARGE AND
REPRESENTATIVE ELECTRIC. BY
CONTRAST DOING THINGS THE WAY
WE DO NOW IN CALIFORNIA FUSING
THESE INTO A SINGLE BALLOT
SOMETHING THEY WERE AN OUT LIAR
ON THERE'S ONLY ONE OTHER STATE
DOES THAT IT POSES TWO
FUNDAMENTAL CHALLENGES FOR
DEMOCRACY IN THE RECALL
PROCESS. THE FIRST IS IT
CREATES AN IRRESISTIBLE
INVITATION FOR THE INCUMBENT
PARTY TO MANIPULATE THE
ELECTION BY CLEARING THE FIELD
OF CANDIDATES IN AND ALSO BY
CLEARING THE FIELD OF VOTERS SO
THIS IS BECAUSE THESE TWO
QUESTIONS REFUSE. ANY CANDIDATE
FACING THE THREAT OF A RECALL
KNOWS THAT THE KIDS AVAILABLE
REPLACEMENT CONTEST WILL HAVE A
HUGE EFFECT ON WEATHER HERE SHE
SURVIVES THE RECALL OR NOT. SO
WHAT DOES THAT EXPIRE
POLITICIAN DO WHAT THEY DO WHAT
WE SAW IN THIS RECALL WHICH BY
THE WAY BECAUSE IT WAS SO
SUCCESSFUL THIS WILL BE THE
PLAYBOOK FOR THE NEXT RECALLS
THAT WE SEEN CALIFORNIA WHETHER
THEY'RE ANOTHER EIGHTEEN THIRTY
SIX OR SEVENTY TWO YEARS AWAY.
RIGHT. WHAT DID WHAT DOES IT.
WE CALL THE FISH OKAY WORK. THE
FIELD TO ENSURE THE PERTAINING
PRECOCIAL AND- AND SCRIPTER AND
REPLACING THEM WITH A- WITH A
MEMBER OF THE OTHER PARTY RIGHT
SO VOTERS FACED THIS DIFFICULT
CHOICE AND- AND THAT HELPS THE
RECALLED OFFICIAL THIS WAS
SUCCESSFUL STUNNINGLY
SUCCESSFUL THIS YEAR IN THE
RECALL CONTEST IT WILL BE
EMULATED IN FUTURE ELECTIONS IT
HELPED THE PARTY OF THE
GOVERNOR WIN. BUT VOTERS LOST
RIGHT THIS WASN'T A DECISION
VOTERS MADE THEY DIDN'T NARROW
THE FIELD AND THE FIELD WAS
NARROWED FOR THEM- IT WAS
SOMETHING WHERE IT WAS HELPFUL
FOR THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY BUT
BUT DEEPLY UNHEALTHY THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS NOT TAPPED
STRONG CANDIDATES ON EACH SIDE.
THE SECOND THING THAT WAS A BIG
REPRESENTATION A PROBLEM WITH
THIS RECALL WAS THAT AS PART OF
THIS STRATEGY OF HELPING TO
PROTECT THE INCOMING ON THE
FIRST QUESTION. THE INCUMBENT
AND HIS PARTY URGED VOTERS TO
STAY OUT OF THE SECOND QUESTION
THIS LED TO SOMETHING I'VE
NEVER SEEN BEFORE IN CALIFORNIA
WE HAD FIVE MILLION PEOPLE
PARTICIPATE IN THE SELECTION
AND TAYING FOR HALF OF THAT
NOT HAVE THEIR VOICES HEARD IN
THIS THIS WAS BOTH A MUCH
SMALLER ELECTRIC. BUT ALSO A
LESS REPRESENTATIVE ELECTED TO
THE UC SAN DIEGO YANKELOVICH
SURVEY CANTAT LOOKED AT THE
DEMOGRAPHICS OF THOSE WHO WERE
PARTICIPATING IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ELECTION THE TWENTY AT
THE RECALL ELECTION IN THE
REPLACEMENT CONTEST WE FOUND
TRACKING OUR SAMPLE THOSE WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE IN THE VERY
FEW PEOPLE WHO PARTICIPATE IN
THE RECOLOR PLACEMENT CONTEST-
WHO WERE MORE LIKELY TO. TO BE
RICHER BUT MORE AFFLUENT VOTERS
IN FAR FEWER VOTERS MAKING
FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS OR LESS
MORE LIKELY BE WHITE VOTERS FAR
FEWER BLACK AND AAPI VOTERS AND
ALSO THAT THIS WAS NOT
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE IDEOLOGY
OF CALIFORNIA SELECTED SO.
REACHED TWO PROBLEMS RIGHT
HAVING FEWER CANDIDATES AND
FEWER VOTERS IN THE POOL WE'RE
ALL A FUNCTION OF A POLITICAL
REACTION TO DEFUSE THE BALLOT.
TO HOW DO YOU SOLVE THAT YOU
SEPARATE THE TWO BALLOTS. YOU
HAVE RECALL CONTEST AND THEN IF
ONLY IF IT IF IT IS SUCCESSFUL.
A MONTH OR TWO LATER YOU
REPLACED YOU HAVE A REPLACEMENT
RACE. BOB THIS IS SOME OF THE
VOTERS SUPPORTED THAT
YANKELOVICH SURVEY BY. 4937%
MARK DEFENDERS WERE SUPPORT.
PROPOSAL I DO SOMETHING THAT
DOES HAVE ONE POLITICAL
DRAWBACK RIGHT TO POTENTIAL
COST OF THIS YOU WOULD HAVE TO
RUN. A STACK ALEXION. FIRST
THAT COST WOULD ONLY BE BORN IF
THE RECALL IS SUCCESSFUL RIGHT
REALITIES OF THE DEAD DID IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THERE'S NO
REPLACEMENT CONTEST NO
ADDITIONAL STATE COSTS MUCH OF
THE CRITICISM. OF THE COST OF
RECALL IS THAT IT WAS COST IT
WAS ACOSTA BURKE FOR AN
ELECTION IT DIDN'T HAVE POPULAR
SUPPORT THIS WOULD ONLY TRIGGER
THAT THAT COST IF THERE IS
POPULAR SUPPORT. IN SECOND
ANOTHER WAY TO ADDRESS THE COST
ARGUMENT BEING ALTERNATIVE
VERSION OF THIS WHICH IS THE
HOLDER BECAUSE- A CONTEST ON
YEAH. SO ELEMENT CANADA. AND IF
IT IS SUCCESSFUL YOU HAVE A
REPLACE CONTEST INITIALLY
SCHEDULED STATEWIDE ELECTION
WITH AN APPOINTEE I SERVING AS
A CARETAKER IN TELL THEM. SO
THANKS VERY MUCH AFTER
CONSIDERING THAT IDEA WHICH I
THINK IS THE ONE THAT WOULD
RESTORE THE MOST OUT THE
FULLEST VOICE OF THE ELECTRIC.
IN THE FOURTH CHIU BUSES FOR
VOTERS TO OUR RECALL PROCESS.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU A
PROFESSOR CAL SIR AND IT LOOKS
LIKE WE SHOULD BE ON TIME TO
GET THE QUESTIONS FOR EVERYBODY
WANTS OUR BIGGEST CHANCE TO
PRESENT TO NEXT WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON. AND HEAR FROM KARTHICK
RAMAKRISHNAN. A PROFESSOR OF
PUBLIC POLICY AT THE UNIVERSITY
AT THAT UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE. HE FOUNDED THE
CENTER FOR SOCIAL INNOVATION AT
UC RIVERSIDE. INSURES THE
CALIFORNIA COMMISSION ON ASIAN
AMERICANS AND PACIFIC
ISLANDERS. DOCTOROW KRISHNAN-
BLEASE PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU I THINK IT'S A
MEMBER BERMAN AND CO CHAIR- SO
AB I THINK A LOT OF BEEN SAID
AND I'LL I DON'T FOCUS ON ONE-
ASPECT OF IT BUT PT IT IN THE
CONTEXT OF A LARGER THEME WHICH
IS THAT THE RECALL THE WAITERS
CURRENTLY DESIGNED MAKES A
MOCKERY OF MAJORITY RULE- NARAL
WILL BE SOLVED IT'S TEMPTING TO
ONLY THINK ABOUT THE MOST
RECENT EXPERIENCE OF THE
GUBERNATORIAL RECALL AND TO NOT
SEE HOW- MAJORITY RULE IS
THREATENED IN A MORE GENERAL
WAY. SO I JUST SAID I MIX SOME
A FEW KEY POINTS AND TO TALK
ABOUT WHY THE SOLUTION I WAS
HAVING A SINGLE BALLOT WHERE
THE GOVERNOR CHEERS AMONG
ALTERNATES AND TO HAVE A SYSTEM
LIKE AN INSTANT RUNOFF OR
SINGLE TRANSFERABLE VOTE. CAN
HELP PRESERVE MAJORITY WILL- SO
JUST KEY POINTS IS THAT THE
CURRENT SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE IT
WAS DESIGNED OVER A HUNDRED
YEARS AGO. AND WHILE IT HAS
BEEN RARELY USED- AS WE SEE
SIGNS THAT IT MAY BE USED MORE
FREQUENTLY MOVING FORWARD. I
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE
ENVIRONMENT OF DEEP PARTY
POLARIZATION AS WELL AS SOCIAL
MEDIA ECHO CHAMBERS OF RAMPANT
MISINFORMATION. SECOND MAJOR
POINT IS THAT FUTURE RECALL
ELECTIONS PARTICULARLY IN STATE
LEGISLATIVE ELECTIONS COULD
HAVE SIGNIFICANT EQUITY
CONCERNS AMONG VOTERS OF COLOR
AND LOW INCOME VOTERS YOUNGER
VOTERS. WE DO HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO INNOVATE AND
I'LL TALK ABOUT A FEW WAYS IN
WHICH WE CAN DO THAT. TWO WEEKS
BLAME CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP
WHEN IT COMES TO INNOVATION AND
GOVERNANCE OUR NATION. MY
APOLOGIES FOR ANY NOISE YOU
MIGHT HEAR IN THE BACK MY KIDS
ARE COMING BACK WITH SCHOOL
RECORD. NO WORRIES SO- FIRST
WHEN IT COMES TO SIGNATURE
GATHERING WE SHOULD IF WE
CONSIDER IF WE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE HEALTH OF OUR
DEMOCRACY IT IS NOT THE NUMBER
OF SIGNATURES WE NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION TO BUT THE PROPORTION
I KNOW THERE'S BEEN TALKED
ABOUT IN THE PAST IT BIT BY
PREVIOUS SPEAKER. WHEN YOU HAVE
A SITUATION WHERE YOU HAVE 12%
OF ELIGIBLE VOTERS THAT CAN
ESSENTIALLY FORCE AN ELECTION
ON THE REST OF CALIFORNIA- THAT
THREATENS THE WILL OF THE
MAJORITY AND ITS ABILITY TO
GOVERN BASED ON THE KIND OF
MANDATE THAT IT PUT IN PLACE IN
THE PART OF MUCH. WHAT ALSO
MAKES A MOCKERY OF MAJORITY
RULE IS OUR CURRENT SYSTEM
WHERE IT IS POSSIBLE FOR AN
INCUMBENT. WITH 452409% IN FACT
JUST ONE VOTE SHY FIFTY
PERCENT. TO LOSE. AND TO BE
REPLACED BY SOMEONE WITH
SUPPORT BELOW 30% THEY'RE ALSO
EQUITY CONCERNS ABOUT IT WE
DIDN'T WE DIDN'T SEE MUCH OF A
DROP OFF IN THE GUBERNATORIAL
RECALL IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
WE HAVE TWELVE POINT FIVE
MILLION VOTERS. TWENTY TWENTY
ONE TWELVE POINT NINE MILLION.
BUT IN THE CASE OF THE RECALL
OF SENATOR NEWMAN. YOU HAD AN
ELECTRIC OF THREE HUNDRED
EIGHTEEN THOUSAND VOTES IN TWO
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND LESS THAN
HALF OF THAT HUNDRED FIFTY
EIGHT THOUSAND VOTES. IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN SO WE SHOULD BE VERY
MINDFUL WHEN YOU HAVE LOW
TURNOUT ELECTIONS. VOTERS OF
COLOR YOUNG VOTERS LOW INCOME
VOTERS TEND TO VOTE AT A
DISPROPORTIONATELY LOWER RATE.
OUR CURRENT SYSTEM IS ALSO
ARCHAIC IN THE CURRENT SYSTEM
BECAUSE IT DOES NOT INCORPORATE
OUR TOP TWO PROCESS WHICH ARE
CALIFORNIANS HAVE. HAVE ENJOYED
OVER THE PAST DECADE AND THAT
ITSELF WAS AN INNOVATION THAT
WAS IMPLEMENTED THROUGH THE
BALLOT NOR DOES IT INCORPORATE
INSTANT RUNOFF. ALL RIGHT SO
YOU EITHER HAVE THE IF YOU WANT
AN INSURER MAJORITY WILL YOU
EITHER HAVE A TWO STAGE
ELECTION MARK PROFESSOR
GALLAGHER IS TALKING ABOUT-
BOARDING INSTANT RUN OFF OF ITS
A SINGLE ELECTION SO THAT YOU
GET A SENSE OF WHAT THE
MAJORITY ISN'T THERE IS A KIND
OF MAJORITY. MANDATE THAT THE
INCUMBENT HAD ENJOYED IN THE
PRIOR ELECTION THE CARD SYSTEM
AS IT'S DESIGNED DOES NOT DO
THAT AND IT NEEDS TO BE REVISED.
FINALLY IN THE END MY TO I
WOULD SAY PERHAPS MY MOST
IMPORTANT POINTS. AND ADVICE TO
THE LEGISLATURE THIS IS
SOMETHING I TESTIFIED THE
LITTLE HOOVER COMMISSION
EARLIER TODAY. IS THAT. THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONSIDER IF
IT DOES PUT SOMETHING BEFORE
THE VOTERS NOT TO PACKAGE
EVERYTHING INTO ONE MEASURE AND
TO GUESS WHAT THE VOTERS WILL
SUPPORT SEVERAL MONTHS DOWN THE
LINE. DARLIN MEASURES AND TO
GIVE VOTERS THE ABILITY TO
CHOOSE THERE ARE SEVERAL
ADVANTAGES FIRST OF ALL THERE
IS UNCERTAINTY IN PUBLIC
OPINION ON THOSE PROVISIONS
EVEN NOW LET ALONE HEADING
TOWARDS ELECTION DAY. VOTERS
HATE ONE. ASIAN OR THERE'S A
MISINFORMATION CAMPAIGN ON ONE
PARTICULAR PIECE OF THAT REFORM
U. REST SINKING THE ENTIRE
EFFORT. SPLITTING IT UP ALSO
GIVES VOTERS MORE OPPORTUNITIES
TO DELIBERATE AND DECIDE WHICH
ASPECTS SEEM TO MAKE THE MOST
SENSE SALES SIGNATURE
REQUIREMENTS OR WHETHER IT
SHOULD BE ONE- BALLOT OR TO
BALANCE. AND FINALLY IN THE
SPIRIT OF NINETEEN ELEVEN WHERE
YOU HAVE TWENTY THREE
PROVISIONS PUT TOWARDS IT IN
FRONT OF VOTERS AND TWENTY TWO
OUT OF THOSE TWENTY THREE
REFORMS PASSED IF INDEED THERE
IS. AN APPETITE FOR REFORM IN
CALIFORNIA. WE WILL LIKELY SEE
SEVERAL OF THOSE PROVISIONS
PASS AND NOT BE SUBJECT TO
SOME- ONE ONE SMALL PIECE OF
WITHIN A PACKAGE- THAT VOTERS.
OPPOSE AN END UP SINKING THE
WHOLE MEASURE. FINALLY WE CAN
ALSO INUNDATED BY CONSIDERING
SUNSET PROVISIONS TO EITHER
SOME OR ALL OF THAT IS PUT IN
FRONT OF VOTERS. CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATURE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. WATCHES CALIFORNIA
HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO. WITH
PROPOSITION THIRTY TO HAVE-SUNSET PROVISIONS IN A
STATUTORY MEASURE AND THAT
APPEALS TO A LOT OF VOTERS TO
KNOW THAT THEY'RE TRYING
SOMETHING NEW AND YET THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO BURDEN ALL FUTURE
GENERATIONS OF CALIFORNIANS
WITH SOMETHING THAT WAS EITHER
BADLY DESIGNED OR UNINTENDED
CONSEQUENCES OR CHANGED
CIRCUMSTANCES- THAT CALL FOR A
DIFFERENT SYSTEM. SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THEY ARE THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD CONSIDER NOT
IN THE SPIRIT OF INNOVATION TO
NOT EXPERIMENT IN A WAY- THAT
SADDLES FUTURE GENERATIONS WITH
SOMETHING THAT IS ARCHAIC MUCH
AS OUR CURRENT RECALL THIS
ARCHAIC NOW. AND TO PERHAPS
THINK OF SOMETHING LIKE A TEN
YEAR OR TWENTY YEAR WINDOW AT
WHICH TIME VOTERS WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE IT MORE
PERMANENT OR MODIFIED IT
ANOTHER WAY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I LOOK FOR TO
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU PROFESSOR
LAWMAKERS MEN AND FINALLY WE'LL
HEAR FROM BOB STERN- WHO IS THE
PAST PRESIDENT OF THE CENTER
FOR GOVERNMENTAL STUDIES. A LOS
ANGELES BASED GROUP THAT
STUDIED THE GOVERNMENT PROCESS
FOR NEARLY THIRTY YEARS MR
STERN WAS A PRINCIPAL CO AUTHOR
OF THE POLITICAL REFORM ACT OF
NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR. PROP
NINE WHICH WAS PASSED BY 70% OF
CALIFORNIA VOTERS AND ALSO
PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS THE FIRST
GENERAL COUNSEL OF THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION.
ELECTIONS COUNSEL TO THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AND
COMMITTEE COUNSEL TO THE
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY ELECTIONS
AND REAFFIRM REAPPORTIONMENT
COMMITTEE. MR STERN READY WHEN
YOU ARE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR INVITING ME TODAY IN FOR
ACCOMMODATING MY SCHEDULE TO
ALLOW ME TO FINISH TEACHING MY
CLASS THIS AFTERNOON. CALL
POLITICAL POPERY AT UCLA
EXTENSION. FOR FIFTY STUDENT
SEVERAL OF WHOM ARE MEMBERS OF
THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS. I
PREVIEW MY REMARKS TO MY CLASS
AND RECEIVED SEVERAL COMMENTS
AND FEEDBACK FROM MY STUDENTS-
I WOULD LIKE TO COME TO
SACRAMENTO TO JOIN YOU IN
PERSON BUT WAS UNABLE TO DO SO
OBVIOUSLY. WELL YOU KNOW LIKE
OUR PHONES. WE NEED TO UPDATE
OUR CALIFORNIA'S STATE
CONSTITUTION. WHEN SOME OF
THESE PROVISIONS NO LONGER MAKE
ANY SENSE SOMETIMES WE NEED TO
SCRAP OR PHONE AND- NEWMAN. BUT
I'M NOT URGING A NEW STATE
CONSTITUTION JUSTIN UP TO DATE
ONE. I WOULD THINK AND I HOPE
WE WERE ALL ALL OF US AGREE.
THAT THE SECOND PART OF THE
CURRENT RECALL PROCESS NEEDS TO
BE DELETED OR SCRAPPED. IN THE
NEW PROVISION IS NEEDED. BOB
REFER TO THE PART THE CALL FOR
ANOTHER. TO REPLACE AGO THAT
HAS BEEN RECALLED. RIGHT NOW
THIS PROVISION SAYS THAT
WHOEVER GETS THE MOST VOTES IN
THIS SECTION ELECTION BECOMES
GOVERNOR. EVEN IF THAT PERSON
RECEIVES FAR LESS MAJORITY. FOR
EXAMPLE THE ELECTION HELD IN
SEPTEMBER FOURTEENTH THE
GOVERNOR NEWSOM BEEN RECALLED.
LARRY ELDER WOULD BECOME
GOVERNOR EVEN THOUGH HE ONLY
RECEIVED TWENTY EIGHT PERCENT.
OF THE TOTAL VOTES CAST IN THE
ELECTION OR FORTY EIGHT
PERCENT. OF THE VOTES CAST BY
PEOPLE VOTING IN THE SECOND
PART OF THE ELECTION. SO THE
GOVERNOR'S AND COULD BE SEEN
49% OF THE VOTE AND BEEN
RECALLED. WELL I ONLY GOT. 28%
OF THE VOTE IN BECOME GOVERNOR.
MY RECOMMENDATION HAVE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR BECOME
GOVERNOR IF THE GOVERNOR'S
RECALL. THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION ALREADY HAS
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR ASSUMING
THE GOVERNORSHIP IF THE
GOVERNOR DIES IN OFFICE RESIGNS
OR OTHERWISE VACATES HIS HER
OFF HER OFFICE. MY REFORM WOULD
MEAN THAT WE MOST LIKELY ONLY
HAVE A GUBERNATORIAL RECALL
WHEN THE GOVERNOR IS CORRUPT
SENILE OR INCOMPETENT BECAUSE
WHY WOULD PEOPLE OBJECTING TO
THE GOVERNOR'S POLICIES BOTHER
TO RECALL THE GOVERNOR IF THE
TENANT GOVERNOR WAS GOING TO
TAKE OVER. BY THE WAY
CALIFORNIA ALSO HIS IMPEACHMENT
PROVISIONS WHICH APPARENTLY
HAVE NEVER BEEN USED THAT LAYS
OUT THE FOLLOWING UPON THE
ASSEMBLY IMPEACHING THE
GOVERNOR EVEN WHILE AWAITING
TRIAL IN THE STATE SENATE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR BECOMES
GOVERNOR UPON CONVICTION IN THE
SENATE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
BECOMES PART OF THE GOVERNOR.
YEAH THERE IS ONE PROBLEM WITH
MY RECOMMENDATION THAT YOU
SHOULD KEEP IN MIND WHAT IF WE
TELL THE GOVERNOR IS A MEMBER
OF THE OTHER PARTY THAT COULD
ENCOURAGE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR'S
PARTY TO PROMOTE RECALL YOU
MIGHT SAY DON'T WORRY ABOUT IT
BUT LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR HAS
BEEN A MEMBER OF THE OTHER
PARTY FIVE TIMES IN THE LAST
FORTY YEARS AS RECENTLY AS ONE
ARNOLD SCHWARZENEGGER WAS
GOVERNOR. WE HAD MY CARBON
REPUBLICAN WHO IS- WHO TENDED
TO JERRY BROWN WAS A GOVERNOR
IN THE SEVENTIES WE HAVE YOUR
CAR KEYS DEMOCRAT JANET
GOVERNOR GEORGE DEUKMEJIAN WAS
GOVERNOR OF THE EIGHTIES WE HAD
GRAY DAVIS LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
WHO'S A DEMOCRAT WAS WELL GOOD
WILSON WAS GOVERNOR IN THE
NINETIES AND THEN WE HAD. THE
TALENT GOVERNOR JOHN GARAMENDI
THE DEMOCRAT WHO WAS ELECTED
GOVERNOR ONE SHORTS **** FROM
200-032-0009 WHEN GARAMENDI
RESIGNED TO BECOME A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS SCHWARZENEGGER THEN
SHOWS ABEL MALDONADO TO BE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR. SOME SORT
OF TAKE CARE OF THIS PROBLEM I
RECOMMEND THAT THE GOVERNOR
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR RUN
TOGETHER AS A TEAM JUST AS THE
PRESIDENT AND VICE PRESIDENT DO
WHAT IF YOU DON'T ACCEPT MY
PROPOSAL PLEASE COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION THAT STOPS. THE
CANDIDATE WITH LESS IT'S THE
MAJORITY OF BECAUSE GOVERNOR.
IF THEY DON'T HAVE. BUT PEOPLE
WOULD WRITE BE VERY UPSET WITH
HIS WORK PROCESS THE CA HAVE
BEEN PER BUT WHY YOU SEE I HOPE
THEY YOU WILL TAKE A LOOK AT
THESE PER I HOPE YOU DO SOME.
BECAUSE IT'S VERY IMPORTANT I
THINK THAT WE RESTORE IN THE
SYSTEM AND MAKE SURE NOTHING
WACKY HAPPENS IN THE FUTURE
THANKS SO MUCH. THANK YOU MR
STERN REALLY APPRECIATE THAT SO
LET'S OPEN UP TO QUESTIONS. AND
COMMENTS AND COLLEAGUES WITH A
REMINDER THAT I BELIEVE IT'S-
PROFESSOR LEVINSON AND
PROFESSOR RAMAKRISHNAN WHO HAVE
TO LEAVE AT HAVE A HEART STOP
pPREFERENCE TO THEM- ON ON
QUICKLY REPLYING AND FOR THE
PANELISTS I DON'T HAVE A LAPTOP
IN FRONT OF ME I CAN'T SEE
REYES HANDS OF SORT OF KIND OF
CHIME IN- IF YOU WANT TO ANSWER
TO A QUESTION AND WE'LL FIND A
WAY TO KIND OF KEEP IT ORDERLY-
BUT ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM MY COLLEAGUES INVESTORS
HERE DON'T. I DO HAVE. SEVERAL
OF CHINA ORGANIZE AND BECAUSE
THERE'S SO MUCH INFORMATION
THAT CAME OUT HERE- FIRST FOR
DOCTOR COME A CHRISTIAN MAN
THANK YOU FOR POINTING OUT THE
IF WE DO DO AN ACA. YOU KNOW
THERE'S GONNA BE SEVERAL
DIFFERENT ASPECTS TO WHAT
PEOPLE ARE TRYING TO PACKAGE AS
A- AS AN AMENDMENT. AND PEOPLE
NEED THE OPPORTUNITY BECAUSE
THEY MADE LIKE A COUPLE OF
PROVISIONS BUT NOT THE OTHER
TWO. AND BE PUT BACK INTO THIS
POSITION OF VOTING FOR
SOMETHING THEY DON'T WANT JUST
BECAUSE THERE'S A COUPLE THINGS
THEY DO WANT. AND WE WIND UP
WITH A ANOTHER PROCESS THAT
PEOPLE ARE NOT NOT HAPPY WITH-
DOCTORS. TURNED THAT SEE WE-
HAVE COME BACK TO YOU IN A
MINUTE. THE MS LEVINSON.
QUALIFICATIONS THIS LEVINSON
STILL ON. YEP OKAY SO YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT QUALIFICATIONS
AND I THINK. IN THE LAST
GOVERNOR GOVERNOR'S RACE IN THE
PRIMARY WE HAD WITH THIRTY ONE
CANDIDATES. TO CHOOSE FROM WHAT
ARE THE QUALIFICATIONS FOR
BEING IT'S A GOVERNOR. YEAH HOW
DO WE DETERMINE QUALIFICATIONS.
SO WE DETERMINE QUALIFICATIONS
IT'S A ON THE SECRETARY OF
STATE WEBSITE I CAN SEND IT
AROUND IT'S BASICALLY BE A U.
S. CITIZEN BE A REGISTERED
VOTER I DON'T BE CONVICTED OF
CERTAIN FELONIES- AND DON'T BE
TURNED OUT BASICALLY DON'T HAVE
ALREADY SERVED TWO TERMS IN
OFFICE AND THEN THERE ARE SOME
REQUIREMENTS ABOUT CAMPAIGN
FILINGS FILING FEES- AT BALLOT
DESIGNATION STATEMENT OF
ECONOMIC INTEREST- AND THOSE
ARE THE QUALIFICATIONS RIGHT IN
NONE OF THOSE AND OTHER PEOPLE
SIGNED UP FOR EITHER THE
GOVERNOR'S RACE IN THE ORIGINAL
TWO THOUSAND AND EIGHTEEN.
ELECTION OR OR THIS RECALL RACE
LACKED THOSE QUALIFICATIONS
OTHERWISE IT WOULDN'T EVEN BE
ON THE BALLOT CORRECT. RIGHT
THEY'LL BE KICKED OFF THE BAT
RIGHT SO YOU KNOW WHEN I
HESITATE TO SAY THAT WE NEED TO
HAVE QUALIFICATIONS FOR ONE.
AND NOT QUALIFICATIONS FOR THE
OTHER IF LIKE YOU HAD SAID IT
WOULD HAVE TO BE FOR EVERYBODY.
AND AND I DON'T KNOW THAT
THAT'S A THAT'S A REAL. THING-
THE MAJORITY RULE VERSUS
SUPERMAJORITY RULES ANOTHER
DOCTOR COMIC CHRIS DEMAND.
THING I'M A CHRISTIAN THANK YOU.
SO DO YOU THINK THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE IN GOVERNANCE WHEN
YOU HAVE YEAH AND I YOU KNOW
WHAT IN THE INTEREST OF BLOOD
ESSENCE EVERYBODY'S BEING BLACK
ALL RIGHT I'M NOT ONE OF
NINETEEN REPUBLICANS IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND- IN THE SENATE I
BELIEVE. MISTAKE CENTER TO
NIELSEN IS ONE OF NINE SENATORS
BOTH OF THOSE ARE 75%
SUPERMAJORITY- WHEN YOU'RE
LOOKING AT. WHETHER THAT'S AN
EFFECTIVE. CHECKS AND BALANCES
WHEN THE GOVERNOR IS SUPER
ALIGNED WITH THE SUPER
MAJORITIES. AND THEN THE.
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR IS MOST
MORE THAN LIKELY THIS THE SAME
DO YOU THINK THAT MIGHT PLAY
INTO WHY PEOPLE ARE ASKING FOR
A CHANGE BECAUSE A LOT OF TIMES
SUPERMAJORITIES THAT I'VE FOUND
DON'T GOVERN THE SAME WAY AS A
SIMPLE MAJORITY AND I LOOK TO
OUR PURPLE DISTRICTS IN THE
STATE AND WHAT THOSE CANDIDATES
GO THROUGH DURING THEIR
ELECTION PROCESS AS OPPOSED TO
NON PURPLE DISTRICTS. AND IT
BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO. DAY IN
THE PURPLE DISTRICTS ACTUALLY
HAVE TO. ANSWER TO THE PEOPLE
THAT DON'T NECESSARILY ALIGN
WITH ALL OF THEIR- THERE ARE
BELIEVED THEY CAN'T JUST
DISREGARD THEM. IN A
SUPERMAJORITY CASE A LOT OF
TIMES LOT OF THE ELECTORATE IS
JUST SIMPLY DISREGARDED. AND
WHEN YOU DISREGARD THEM YEAH
THEY'RE GOING TO BE UNHAPPY AND
THEY'RE GONNA WANT TO EXPRESS
THAT ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY'RE
TOLD THINGS DURING AN ELECTION.
AND THEN AFTER THE ELECTION
EXACTLY THE OPPOSITE HAPPENS
WITH THE CANDIDATE THEY SAID
HEY YOU KNOW YOU TOLD US YOU
WERE GOING TO OVERTURN THE
DEATH PENALTY AND THEN DESPITE
TWO INITIATIVES THAT SAID.
WE'RE GOOD WE ARE WE AS A STATE
ARE GOOD WITH THE DEATH PENALTY.
YOU DON'T WANT TO FIRST THANK
YOU DO IS GET EXECUTIVE POWER
TO OVERTURN THEDEATH PENALTY.
SO WHEN YOU HAVE THAT KIND OF
SITUATION. THE ONLY THING LEFT
IS THIS. IS OUR OUR CITIZENS
ABILITY TO DO A RECALL. AND
THAT'S WHAT I THINK YOU KNOW
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE AND
MAJORITY RULE VERSUS
SUPERMAJORITY RULE. AND SORRY
MY QUESTION TO THAT THE DOCTOR
WAS. DO YOU SEE THAT OR DO YOU
FEEL LIKE THAT'S INVALID. THANK
YOU- YOU KNOW WITH RESPECT TO.
AB DE VOTERS HAVING A CHOICE
FOR PUNISHING ELECTED OFFICIALS
THAT'S THAT'S USUALLY WHAT
REELECTIONS ARE FOR- IN THE
CASE OF THE ASSEMBLY EVERY TWO
YEARS IN THE SENATE EVERY EVERY
FOUR YEARS- IT IS. IN A
MAJORITIES DO HAVE. NOT ONLY
THE RIGHT BUT THE OBLIGATION TO
GOVERN- AND I DON'T THINK
ANYONE INTENDED THE RECALL
PROVISION TO BE A SUBSTITUTE
FOR OR WHATEVER- VOTING RULES
WITHIN THE LEGISLATURE THAT'S
NOT THAT'S NOT WHAT THE RECALL
IS THEREFORE- AND IF CALIFORNIA
VOTERS WANTED TO. CREATE SOME
OTHER MECHANISM TO ENSURE- THAT
MINORITY INTERESTS ARE
REPRESENTED- THERE ARE OTHER
WAYS. OF DOING IT GIVING I
WOULD SAY IS AS YOU THINK ABOUT
THE KIND OF REFORMS TO BE MADE.
TO REALLY TAKE THE LONG VIEW
RIGHT- SO ARE RECALL SYSTEM WAS
DESIGNED IN NINETEEN ELEVEN
IT'S STILL IN PLACE AND THERE'S
ANXIETY THAT IS BEING USED FOR
DIFFERENT KINDS OF PURPOSES
THAT. WILL REGIONALLY INVISION
AND WHATEVER REFORMS WE DO
SHOULD NOT TAKE INTO ACCOUNT.
THE PARTY OF THE GOVERNOR OF
THE PARTY THE LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR THE PARTY IF THE
LEGISLATURE. WITH RESPECT TO
THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR-
AUTOMATICALLY GOING INTO A
PROCESS AUTOMATICALLY. FILLING
A VACANCY ON THE GOVERNOR'S
RECALLED. I WOULD URGE CAUTION.
AGAIN RIGHT NOW YOU HAVE TO
FROM THE SAME PARTY. IMAGINE A
SCENARIO MABILLE FACTIONS
WITHIN PARTIES WE HAVE A
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR THATCOMES
FROM THE PARTICULARLY VOCAL
FACTION WITHIN THE SAME PARTY.
AND IS ABLE TO KEEP THEIR HANDS
CLEAN AND LET OTHER PEOPLE DO
THE DIRTY WORK OF JUST GETTING
12% OF SIGNATURE TO THE
ENFORCEMENT ACTION AND TO HAVE
A VERY PASSIONATE MINORITY NOT
A MINORITY PARTY. BUT APASSIONATE MINORITY WITHIN A
MAJORITY PARTY. TO GET THAT
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR GOVERNOR
INSTALLED. SO THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT I. WE HAVE TO BE THINKING
NOT ONLY ABOUT OUR CURRENT
POLITICAL LANDSCAPE BUT THE
LANDSCAPE I MEAN WE DON'T HAVE
A SUNSET PROVISION AND IF YOU
HAVE A SUCH A PROVISION. YOU
pPARTICULAR ARRANGEMENT MAYBE
FOR THE NEXT DECADE. WE'RE
GONNA BE DOING SOMETHING THAT
CALIFORNIANS WILL HAVE TO LIVE
WITH FOR THE NEXT FIFTY YEARS
SEVENTY YEARS HUNDRED YEARS- WE
NEED TO THINK ABOUT REFORMS
THAT WILL STAND THE TEST OF
TIME AND NOT BASED ON. WHAT THE
WHAT THE PARTIES LOOK LIKE OR
EVEN WHAT OUR CURRENT ASSET OF
ELECTED OFFICIALS LOOK LIKE.
THANK YOU I WISH WE COULD DO
THAT BUT I DON'T I DON'T KNOW
THAT THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
HERE- AND WHAT I SEE IS A VERY
POLITICALLY DIVIDED NOT JUST
TO. CALIFORNIA BUT ALSO IN THE
NATION SO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR ANSWERS TO THOSE AND
YOUR OPINION ON THAT THANK.
EVA'S RESTAURANT- CENTER
HERTZBERG. JUST FOR PURPOSES
QUESTION ON A FOLLOW UP IN YOUR
COMMENTS YOU KNOW TO JUST YOU
KNOW WHEN I RAN FOR THIS OFFICE
IN YOUR HOUSE THE OTHER PARTY
WAS IN POWER- WE TEND TO LOOK
AT HISTORY IN THE SHORTEST
PERIOD OF TIME AT ONE POINT
SEVENTY TWO MEMBERS OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSEMBLY WERE OF ONE
PARTY THOSE ARE THE REPUBLICANS
AGAINST EIGHT MEMBERS OF THE
DEMOCRATS. THESE THINGS SHIFT
WE TEND TO WATCH SO I JUST ALL
I COULD YOU SHARE WITH YOU IS
THAT I THANK GOODNESS YOU BY
TAKING THE LONG VIEW I JUST
WANTED TO CHECK A COUPLE OF
THOUGHTS ON THE- BOB STERN
WHO'S ON OF THIS CLOSE MISTER
CHAIRMAN BOTH GERMANIZED TO SIT
ON HIS BOARD WE WORKED TOGETHER
MANY TIMES HONDURAS ISSUES. BUT
BUT TERM. LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
ISSUE IS SOMETHING THAT. IF YOU
THINK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS IN IN
IN IN PARLIAMENTARY SYSTEMS
LOOK WHAT HAPPENED THE
PRESIDENT I'D STATES LOOK AT
THE EARLY. HISTORY OF CAL OF
UNITED STATES. WHERE THE VICE
FOR THE SECOND RUNNER UP BECAME
THE VICE PRESIDENT. AND YOU DO
HAVE THOSE CHALLENGESAND I
DON'T KNOW. B. SO INSIDIOUS
THAT THEIR MOTIVATION WOULD BE
TO TAKE OUT THE GOVERNOR. BUT
I'M I'M NOT SOMEONE WHO THINKS
THAT THE IDEA THAT THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR SHOULD TAKE
OVER I THINK IS A SERIES OF
POLITICAL ISSUES AS TO WHY THAT
SHOULD BE THE CASE. I DO AGREE
WITH WHAT STERN SAID. PROFESSOR
STERN SAID ABOUT. ALL OF THE
OTHER INDICIA OF THE
CONSTITUTION AS TO WHERE THIS
DUE TO THE GOVERNOR STEPS IN
BUT I THINK OF THE RECALL
SITUATION IS SO FRAUGHT. THAT
IT'S PROBLEMATIC AND- AND IN IN
MY SENSE. I APOLOGIZE I WASN'T
HERE FOR YOUR TESTIMONY. BUT
CLEARLY THE IDEA OF TRYING TO
MERGE INTO ONE ELECTION. RATHER
THAN THE TWO SEPARATE EECTIONS
SOLVES A LOT OF THAT BIG PART
OF THE PROBLEM BUT I JUST
WANTED TO MAKE THE POINT. FOR
THOSE OF US WHO'VE BEEN AROUND
FOR DECADES THAT IS NOT ALWAYS
ONE PARTY THAT'S IN CONTROL.
THAT THAT THESE THINGS TO SHIFT
OVER TIME- AND THAT I DO AGREE
WITH YOU AS WE GRAPPLE WITH
THIS SUCH THAT. OF BOTH
COMMITTEE CHAIRS. THAT WE DO
TAKE THE LONG VIEW. AND AND
TRYING TO PUT TOGETHER A LONG
TERM FIX ON SOMETHING THAT HAS-
EARLY NOT IN NOT ACHIEVED ITS-
PURPOSE WHEN IT WAS- PROPOSED
IN NINETEEN ELEVEN ALONG WITH
THE OTHER SERIES OF REFORMS IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU CENTER
HERTZBERG. MR NELSON J. GLAZER-
NO QUESTIONS I DID I'VE GOT A
LOT OF NOTES AND A LOT OF
THOUGHTS THESE ARE IS REALLY I
THINK FASCINATING IDEAS SOME OF
THEM CONTRADICTORY SO THANKS
FOR- DUMPING THAT INTELLECTUAL
EXERCISE ON US- BUT BUT THAT'S
REALLY THE PURPOSE OF THIS
EFFORT- IS TO YEAH WE HEAR FROM
EXPERTS ON WHO HAVE VERY
DIFFERENT IDEAS AND OPINIONS-
ON ON WHAT'S IMPOSSIBLE REFORM
SHOULD BE AND THEN WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO- KIND OF HASH THEM
OUT AND- FIGURE OUT WHAT MIGHT
BE PALATABLE AS SOME PEOPLE
HAVE MENTIONED TWO. OF THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC AND I
DEFINITELY AGREE THAT WE CAN'T
PACKAGE THIS ALL INTO ONE
MEASURE- OR ELSEWHERE WILL
PROBABLY GUARANTEED TO TAKE THE
WHOLE THING- SO APPRECIATE
EVERYBODY'S COMMENTS- AND WITH
THAT WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT- PART OF THE AGENDA. SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- EVERYBODY
FOR THE- THE PANELISTS FOR
PARTICIPATING. WE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO PUBLIC TESTIMONY. AS A
REMINDER WE HAVE SET ASIDE ONE
HOUR FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
STARTING WITH MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC CORE HERE IN THE ROOM.
EACH PERSON WILL HAVE ONE
MINUTE TO MAKE YOUR REMARKS
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WHO ARE
UNABLE TO PARTICIPATE DURING
THIS PORTION OF THE AGENDA OR
WHO HAVE. LENGTHIER THOUGHTS TO
SHARE WITH THE COMMITTEE ARE
ENCOURAGED TO SUBMIT WRITTEN
TESTIMONY TO THE COMMITTEES
WHICH WILL BECOME PART OF THE
OFFICIAL RECORD OF THE HEARING.
IF YOU WISH TO TESTIFIED BY
PHONE THE CALL IN NUMBER IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE EIGHT FIVE
SEVEN AGAIN THE CALL IN NUMBER
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO EIGHT NINE EIGHT FIVE SEVEN
AND THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
THREE ONE FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO
TWO. AGAIN THAT IS THE ACCESS
CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE FIVE
FOUR TWO ZERO TWO WILL STAR IN
THE COMMITTEE ROOM IS THERE
ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO WISHES
TO TESTIFY YES PLEASE COME UP
YOU'VE GOT ONE MINUTE. TO
TESTIFY PLEASE GO RIGHT AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS NOT.
ON ONE OF THE MAIN PROPONENT TO
KEEP PEOPLE START A NEW POLICY
ALLEN IS THE- THEY HAVE. THAT
MUST SAY- YOUR PEOPLE EMERALD
APPALLED AT. WENT BACK. DO THE
PEOPLE THAT STARTED RECALL ONLY
THAT'LL. THEY WE OBSERVE. WHY
ARE YOU THE HAVE A COMPLICATED.
LOT OF MRS SOME SHINS TODAY THE-
THAT WHAT THE BECAUSE HOW IT
WAS DONE AND THE REASON IT WAS
STAR IN THE- ABOUT IT I WOULD
REALLY THE K. TO HAVE US BACK
TO. HAVE A DISK WITH THE WHAT
REALLY FROM THE PEAK POINT OF
VIEW FIRST THE PLEDGE POINTS OF
VIEW THAT I'VE HEARD DISCUSSED
TODAY. ALSO LIKE TO REMIND YOU
THAT THE MORE PEOPLE VOTE THE
HIGHER THE BAR GOES ANYWAY SO
WHAT'S 12% OF THE PEOPLE THAT
VOTED FOR GOVERNOR LAST TIME.
THE OBJECTIVE SHOULD BE TO GET
MORE PEOPLE TO COME OUT AND
VOTE ALSO PER WHAT. THE
ESTIMATE- DOCTOR WEBER SAID
EARLIER SHE DID HAVE A SHORTER
TIME TO PREPARE FOR THE
ELECTION THAT WAS THANKS TO THE
LEGISLATURE CHANGING THE RULES.
SO IT'S KIND OF A LITTLE BIT OF
SELF INFLICTED. LET'S OPEN UP
THE DIALOGUE AND GET THE
PROPONENTS BACK IN TO TALK. TO
THE EXPERTS WILL PROBABLY NEVER
ACTUALLY CONDUCTED A RECALL AS
WE DID IN COLLECTING TWO POINT
ONE MILLION SIGNATURES. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I BELIEVE. WE ARE CAN YOU
COME BACK FOR JUST ONE SECOND.
SIR WE DESERVE IT- CHAIR GLAZER
HAS A QUICK QUESTION FOR YOU I
KNOW IT'S NOT A PRACTICE TO ASK
QUESTIONS IN THIS POINT ABOUT
K. LOOK AT I WANTED JUST TO
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE. I
THINK THE PURPOSE OF OUR
HEARING WASN'T TO TALK ABOUT
THE JUSTIFICATION FOR THE
RECALL THAT REALLY WASN'T WHERE
WE'RE GOING. IS REALLY MORE OF
A STRUCTURAL ISSUE OF FAIRNESS
IN THAT REGARD BUT I LET ME ASK
YOU ONE QUESTION. YOU WERE
SUCCESSFUL IN COLLECTING. TWO
POINT ONE MILLION SIGNATURES IS
THAT RIGHT. YES ONE POINT SEVEN
MILLION OF THEM COLLECTED BY
VOLUNTEERS. AND WELL UNDER A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND
COLLECTED BY PAID PETITIONERS
RIGHT NOW I APPRECIATE YOU
PUTTING THAT ON THE RECORD
BECAUSE THERE WAS A QUESTION
EARLIER. IN TERMS OF WHAT
ACTUALLY DID HAPPEN. IN THE
RECALL IT WAS SUGGESTED THAT
THE CURE COSTS FOR SEVEN
DOLLARS A SIGNATURE SIR COULD
YOU. CLARIFY WHAT YOU FELT THAT
COSTSWERE COMBINED VOLUNTEERS
AND PAID PER SIGNATURE FOR THE
ENCOUNTERS WERE NOT PAID ALL
THE HAPPY TO CLARIFY THE LATER
DATE I'M HAVING TROUBLE
UNDERSTANDING ACTUALLY RIGHT
NOW. WHAT YOUR QUESTION IS OKAY
NO PROBLEM THANK YOU SIR THANKS
FOR COMING IN. IT IS VERY
HELPFUL THAT TO THANK YOU.
BRIDGETTE WILL BE HAPPY TO
CLARIFY THAT LATER I WOULD
APPRECIATE THE DIALOGUE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- AND- NEXT BIGGER
PLEASE. YES YES. MY NAME IS
OREN HEATLEY ON THE LEAD
PROPONENT I'M THE ONE THAT PUT
THE TEAM TOGETHER THAT BROUGHT
THE RECALL TO THE BALLOT FOR
THE RECALLING GOVERNOR GAVIN
NEWSOM THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
TALK TODAY ABOUT. THE BECAUSE-
AND THE REASONS- TO- SHOW YOU
KNOW. TO PUT THAT TOWARDS THE
END RECALLING THE GOVERNOR. AND
I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT THE
CAUSE OR THE REASONS FOR
RECALLING THE GOVERNOR IS
LISTED ON EVERY PETITION THAT
CIRCULATED THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
IT'S NOT YOUR DECISION WHETHER
OR NOT THAT IS APPLICABLE TO
THE RECALL OR WHETHER OR NOT
IT'S SUBSTANTIAL ENOUGH. TO
GIVE BECAUSE TO THE RECALL IT'S
UP TO THE PEOPLE THERE'S A
REASON IT'S ON THE PETITION
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO LOOK
IT OVER THEY HAVE THE ABILITY.
TO REVIEW THE CAUSE AND THE
REASONS BEHIND IT THE RECALL
AND IT'S UP TO THEM TO DECIDE
IN THE FIELD AND YOU HAVE TO
FORGIVE ME I'M NOT A I'M NOT A
POLITICIAN I'M NOT A PUBLIC
SPEAKER. I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS I
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH IN FRONT OF YOU
TODAY BUT ARTICLE TWO SECTION
FOURTEEN OF THE CALIFORNIA
CONSTITUTION SAYS THAT THE
REASONS FOR THE RECALL ARE
LISTED ON EVERY PETITION. AND
IT'S UP TO THE PUBLIC TO DECIDE
THE SUFFICIENCY OF THE RECALL
IS NOT REVIEW OF ALL FOR A
REASON BECAUSE THEY WANT YOUR
HANDS. OUT OF THE PROCESS THIS
IS A PROCESS OF THE PEOPLE BY
THE PEOPLE AND FOR THE PEOPLE
THIS IS A PEOPLE'S INITIATIVE
TO RECALL GOVERNMENT GOVERNOR
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU APPRECIATE
IT. NEXT BIGGER. MY NAME IS
ERIC EARLY AS THE LEAD LAWYER
FOR THE RECALL IN ONE OF THE
CANDIDATES FOR CALIFORNIA
ATTORNEY GENERAL BE QUICK. ONE
OF THE CO CHAIR SAID THIS
PROCESS WAS UNDEMOCRATIC THIS
WAS ACTUALLY ONE THE FINEST
EXAMPLES OF DEMOCRACY IN ACTION.
SAID THAT THIS WAS A
FUNDAMENTALLY SMALL THRESHOLD
OF VOTES YOU NEED TO SIT DOWN
WITH THOSE TWO GENTLEMEN AND
FIND OUT WHAT A HERCULEAN
EFFORT IT WAS. THERE'S A REASON
WHY THIS WAS ONLY THE FOURTH
STATEWIDE RECALL ELECTION THEY
GOT THIS FAR AND ONLY TWO OF
THOSE. HAVE ENDED EVER ENDED UP
ON THE BALLOT SOMEBODY SAID.
ABOUT THE TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLAR COST WE
WON'T MAKE LIGHT OF THAT COST
BUT THE OUTRAGE SHOULD BE
SAVED. FOR THE STOLEN THIRTY
ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN THE D.
D. FUNDS BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
NO BID CONTRACTS PART OF THE
REASON WHY THIS RECALL GOT.
CERTIFIED SOMEBODY SAID THEY
SHOULD NOT BE A PARTISAN ISSUE.
RIGHT NOW IN THIS IN THIS DAY
AND ARE CALIFORNIA'S HISTORY
ONE PARTY RULE SHOULD NOT BE
WORKING TO CHANGE THIS
PROVISION THAT PROTECTS THE
PEOPLE. IN CALIFORNIA'S
CONSTITUTION. SOMEBODY SAID IT
FAILED SPECTACULARLY. LOOK AT
THE SEVENTY MILLION DOLLARS
RAISED BY NEWS INVERSE THE TEN
MILLION DOLLARS RAISED BY
EVERYBODY ELSE THAT WAS THE
REASON FOR THE FAILURE. THE
LINE OF SUCCESSION ISSUE. THAT
WOULD COMPLETELY UNDERCUT THIS
RECALL BECAUSE NOBODY WOULD
HAVE GONE THROUGH THIS
HERCULEAN EFFORT THESE
SIGNATURES NEVER WOULD HAVE
BEEN OBTAINED IF A MOUTH PIECE
LIKE THE PRESENT LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR. WOULD HAVE BEEN THE
ONE THAT WOULD HAVE GOTTEN THE
JOB NEXT- ON AND ON. LISTEN TO
VICE CHAIR NIELSEN AND LISTEN
TO EXPERT AT CARILLO HUNDRED
TEN YEARS THIS IS VERY SACRED.
THIS IS DIMMITT DIRECT
DEMOCRACY IN ACTION AND AS FAR
AS THE MAJORITY VOTE ISSUE IT
TAKES A MAJORITY OF YESES ON
QUESTION NUMBER ONE TO FIRE THE
ELECTED OFFICIAL. SO THIS IS
ABSOLUTELY A MAJORITY VOTE YOU
NEED A MAJORITY OF YESS OVER
THE NUMBER OF NODES THANK YOU
FOR NOT BE TOUCHING THIS THIS
SECTION FONG. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FIVE MORE SECONDS BEFORE
FOR ONE THING A QUICK QUICK
FIVE SECONDS I'M I I'M THE ONE
THAT FILED THE RECALL PAPERWORK
I FILED TWO. ATTEMPTS TO RECALL
THE GOVERNOR ONE WAS WAS
DISMISSED DUE TO A PROCEDURAL
ERROR. BUT THAT'S STILL LISTED.
AS A RECALL ATTEMPT I WAS LOOKS
NOW I'D LIKE WE GET WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT HOW MANY ATTEMPTS
HAVE BEEN MADE TO RECALL
GOVERNOR HE- CONTINUALLY SAYS
THERE'S BEEN SIX ATTEMPTS
AGAINST HIM. THERE'S ONLY BEEN
THREE ATTEMPTS AND I JUST WANNA
PUT IT ON RECORD. I TOLD IN
THREE ATTEMPTS THAT HAVE
ACTUALLY BEEN APPROVED BY THE
SECRETARY OF STATE TO CIRCULATE
PETITIONS IN CALIFORNIA. MY
NAME'S WARREN HE LEAVE I
SUBMITTED A WRITTEN TESTIMONY
AND I'D LIKE AT RISK READ INTO
RECORD PLACE TO FIGURE OUT WHO
THE WRITTEN TESTIMONY- IT WILL
BE A PART OF THE RECORD IS
AVAILABLE I BELIEVE ON THE
WEBSITE- WELL IT'S. IT'S A PART
OF THE RECORD FOR THE HEARING
ABSOLUTELY. NEXT BEAKER DO YOU
HAVE ANY AYE- PEOPLE WHO WANT
TO SPEAK. IN THE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. YEAH I. OKAY COME ON COME
ON DOWN WE GOT WE GOT A BUNCH
OF FOLKS ON THE PHONE LINE SO I
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE DOES RESPECTFUL AS
POSSIBLE- ONCE I'M HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON OR GOOD EVENING
COMMITTEE I WAS- SACRAMENTO
COUNTIES SAW COORDINATOR I'M
THE ONE WHO GOT ALL THE
VOLUNTEERS AND I CAN TELL YOU
NOT ONE PAID PETITION I WAS ON
MY VOLUNTEER OKAY. MATTER FACT
EVERYTHING CAME OUT OF OUR OWN
POCKET THIS IS MY
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT AND IF YOU
TAKE IT AWAY AND I JUST LOOKED
AT MONTANA WHAT YOU KNOW I WAS
LISTENING TO THE SECRETARY OF
STATE NAY ALL THE COMPARISON
THAT YOU GOT THEY HAVE ONLY
LESS THAN ONE POINT ONE MILLION
PEOPLE AND YOU TALK ABOUT
SEASONS OKAY THEN THE FILE THE
RECALL WHENEVER THEY WANT OKAY.
THEY'RE GOING TO GET IT THE
FILE AND ENTER SPRING OR SUMMER
MONTHS YOU GUYS ARE MAKING ALL
THIS ALL CHAOS I DON'T
UNDERSTAND IT WHAT'S WE THE
PEOPLE WE VOTED FOR THIS
HONORED TEN YEARS AGO IF THAT'S
THE CASE THEN WE SHOULD BE ABLE
TO DO IT WE ARE IN THE BIG
STATE THIS IS FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES THE DISTANCE BETWEEN
WHAT MONTANA'S MILEAGE HAS
SACRAMENTO ALONE IS A HUNDRED
MILE RADIUS OKAY I DON'T KNOW
IF ANY OF YOU ACTUALLY KNOW
THAT. HUNDRED MILE RADIUS SO I
THINK YOU ALSO NEED TO START
LOOKING AT WHAT THE MILEAGES OF
THE AROUND AND HOW IT'S
INCONVENIENT CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUTE AND THE HIGH SPEED
RAILWAY WAS NINETY EIGHT
BILLION DOLLARS. THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND CAN WE
CAN BRING UP NEXT BIG PLEASE.
THE NEXT BIGGER COME ON COME ON
DOWN PLEASE. MMHM. MY NAME DR
MIKE YOU DO MY NAME IS ANDREA
HAD STRUM AND I HAVE BEEN IN
THIS BUILDING TWO HUNDRED TIMES
AND I KNOW EVERY SINGLE ONE OF
YOU YOU KNOW MY CHILDREN
THEY'VE GIVEN THIS THEY'VE
GIVEN TESTIMONY AT THIS VERY
MICROPHONE IN THIS ROOM ABOUT
WHAT IT WAS LIKE FOR THEIR CITY
TO BE ON FIRE AND TO HAVE US
RUN. IN FLAMES. BUT APPARENTLY
YOU'RE TEARING THE ANNEX DOWN
SO THIS MAY WELL BE MY LAST
TIME AT THIS MICROPHONE. SO I
WILL LEAVE YOU WITH THIS. THOSE
WHO ALREADY WALK SUBMISSIVE LEE
WILL SAY THERE IS NO CAUSE FOR
ALARM. BUT SUBMISSIVENESS IS
NOT OUR HERITAGE. THE FIRST
AMENDMENT WAS DESIGNED TO ALLOW
REBELLION TO REMAIN AS OUR
HERITAGE THE CONSTITUTION WAS
DESIGNED TO KEEP GOVERNMENT OFF
THE BACKS OF THE PEOPLE. THE
BILL OF RIGHTS WAS ADDED TO
KEEP THE PRECINCTS OF BELIEF
AND EXPRESSION THE PRESS. OF
POLITICAL AND SOCIAL ACTIVITIES
FREE FROM SURVEILLANCE. THE
BILL OF RIGHTS WAS DESIGNED TO
KEEP AGENTS OF GOVERNMENT AN
OFFICIAL EAVESDROPPERS AWAY
FROM THE ASSEMBLIES OF PEOPLE.
THE AIM WAS TO ALLOW MEN TO BE
FREE AND INDEPENDENT. AND TO
ASSERT THEIR RIGHTS AGAINST
CORRUPT GOVERNMENT. LAYERED IN
TATUM FORO EIGHT U. S. ONE
NINETEEN SEVENTY TWO. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. DO YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL PEOPLE- IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN PERSON. SEEING NONE
WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO THE PHONE
LINES- EIGHTEEN T. OPERATOR.
PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES-
FOR FOLKS TO BE ABLE TO- I
APOLOGIZE I'M I'M SKIPPING A
STEP- EACH ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION AND I KNOW IT
MIGHT TAKE NO WE HAVE NO
WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY SESSION NOW WE WILL
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES FOR
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC TESTIMONY-
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANYBODY ON
THE LINE WHO WISHES TO TESTIFY.
HANDLEY'S JUDGMENT ON THE PHONE
LINES IF YOU'D LIKE TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENTS PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. AGAIN
ONE ZERO FOR PUBLIC COMMENTS.
AND AT THIS TIME SURE WE DO
HAVE ABOUT SEVEN IN OUR QUEUE.
GREAT LET'S THAT START WITH THE
FIRST ONE. ABSOLUTELY WILL
SERVE A NUMBER THIRTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
THIS IS YOUR ROSE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR WITH THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA. SO
WE DO BELIEVE IN USING DIRECT
DEMOCRACY THE ACCOUNTABILITY
ASSEMBLY. WHEN YOUR SMALL
MINORITY FORCING ALSO ALEXION
WITH A VERY LOW TURNOUT AMONG
UNDERREPRESENTED GROUPS
ASSEMBLY EXACERBATE
CALIFORNIA'S PRE EXISTING
CRISIS OF REPRESENTATION. FOR A
FEW OBSERVATIONS FROM THIS BILL
THE PROCESS IS VERY CONFUSING
VOTERS WEREN'T SURE IF THEY
WERE ALLOWED TO CHOOSE A
REPLACEMENT CANDIDATE IF THEY
VOTED NO ON THE FIRST QUESTION.
WE THINK THAT THIS CONGESTION
ALONG WITH THE NO CAMPAIGN
STRATEGY REALLY CONTRIBUTED. TO
THE QUESTION SHE WONDERED.
WHICH IS NO BAD. WE HEARD DEEP.
ABOUT BEING NOT BEING ON THE
COUPLED WITH FACT THAT IT'S
CLEAR TO MAJORITY. THAT COULD
BE WHY BY A VERY SMALL OUT THAT
WOULD VERY DISTURBING. AND IN
OUR COMMENTS WE HAVE TO
CONSIDER AMONG THINGS. OUR
HEARTS IN THE PHARMACIST.
PORTION VOTERS. THANK HARD.
ACTUALLY SOMETHING RIGHT IN A
CAO MARK MATTERS BECAUSE- BUT
WE HAVE HEARD OF ABOUT GEN.
THAT CAN HELP ENSURE PARTY
ISN'T TO RECALL TO THE- SECTION
I CAN. YOU KNOW OTHERWISE
DEFEAT. I WOULD URGE YOU TO SEE
ABOUT HIS TO ROCK. TO THINK
ABOUT RIGHT CHOICE VOTING TO
ADDRESS A PLAYER PROBLEMS AND
ALSO TO AVOID NEED FOR COSTLY
AND YOU MOTHER IN LAW TO TOP
TWO. THANK FOR THE UP TO CALL.
THANK YOU VERY- THEN LET'S MOVE
ON TO THE- CALLER PLEASE. NEXT
WILL BE THIRTY FOUR THE GO
AHEAD. YES- AMONG IS RICHARD BE
ACT NEARLY YES WE CAN HEAR.
OKAY HELLO SPEAK ABOUT THE-
WELL LIBERTY AND- THIS RECALL.
THE COST FOR LIBERTY TRUE EVERY
AS NAY. NOR SHOULD BE
MEASURABLE. YOU WANT TO MEASURE
IT TRY THIS MARKET EVER WOULD.
BECAUSE THIS SINCE. TO EVERY.
THIS AND ASSEMBLY HAS DONE AWAY
TWO HAS BEEN A COULD POWER GRAB
WITHOUT REGARD LIBERTIES WELL
ESTABLISHED CREDIT PEOPLE. TO
US THAT THIS IS NOT A CONTINUED
POWER GRABBED BY BOATS IN POWER
WE CALL OUR WHITE FINISHERS THE
POWER OF THE PEOPLE. TO APPOINT
A REPLACEMENT LIEUTENANT
GOVERNOR KNOCK IS JOKE TWICE IN
THE FACE OF THE PURPOSE OF THE
RECALL. THE SECOND LARGEST MOLD
IN THE PREVIOUS ELECTION SHOULD
BE A COST EFFECTIVE SOLUTION.
AND AT THE- END OF THE PEOPLE
KNOWINGLY CHOOSE THIS FORM
RECALL. IN THE MAJORITY VOTE IS
REPRESENTATIVE. I WANT YOU TO
DO SOMETHING. WRONG POLICE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT
CALLER PLEASE. EXHIBIT NUMBER
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR BERMAN
SENATOR GLAZER OTHER CHURCH
MEMBERS MY NAME IS SHERRY ALL
ACTION I'M CALLING IN
REPRESENTING FASTER COUNTY
MOMS. I HOPE YOU ARE HEARING
THE CONCERNED INSIDE AND
OUTSIDE THE CAPITOL TODAY
CALIFORNIANS ARE VERY ANGRY. I
WOULD HOPE YOU WOULD ACTUALLY
LISTEN TO THE RECALL EXPOSED
ACTUALLY WORKED THE RECALLS AND
OTHER PROCESS VERSUS ONE THAT
ONLY THREE OR JUST TALK ABOUT
IT. AND BY THE WAY I DRESS AND
WEBER. MOST VOLUNTEERS BUT I
KNOW. DO NOT GET PAID. TO GET
SIGNATURES WE VOLUNTEERED OUR
TIME OUR MONEY THEY RESORTED TO
SAVE COSTS. LET'S TAKE A WALK
DOWN MEMORY LANE CALIFORNIA
PROPOSITION EIGHT RECALL
ELECTED OFFICIALS AMENDMENT-
OCTOBER NINETEEN ELEVEN.
GOVERNOR ARE HER MANAGER
JONATHAN REPORTER THE
COMPETITION AMENDMENT SAYING
THAT ALL BEST BE ARMED THE
PEOPLE TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
CHARACTER. WE CAN GIVE TO THE
PEOPLE THE MEANS BY WHICH THEY
PREVENT THE MISUSE OF POWER.
THE FIRST STEP IN ARE DESIGNED
TO PRESERVE AND PERPETUAL.
POPULAR GOVERNMENT.SHALL BE
THE DOBSON THAT INITIATIVE THE
FIRST REFERRED- AND THE RECALL
PLEASE GO AHEAD AND WRAP ANY
RECALL. OKAY ANY RECALL IS THE
PEOPLE TO CHECK AND BALANCES TO
ENSURE THAT WE ARE ELECTED
OFFICIALS AREN'T ROUTE WE'RE
HOLDING OUR ELECTED OFFICIALS
ACCOUNTABLE THE GOVERNOR OR
ELECTED OFFICIAL IS NOT
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA RIGHT
THE YEAH OR- YES WE SHOULD
FIRE. OKAY ARE NOT REPRESENTING
US THANK YOU AND THAT IS OUR
RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU VERY MUCH WHEN I MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT CALLER. TEXAS NUMBER
FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY- AND CALL ME FROM FOSTER-
THE GREEK IS NOT SHOULD NOT BE
CONSIDERED IN- THE ACTION AFTER
SIXTEEN MONTHS OF GATHERING
SIGNATURES I CAN ASSURE YOU
THAT ALL THE THIS WAS NOT JUST
A REPUBLICAN RECALLS HIS FIRST
DEGREE CALL OF THE PEOPLE EVERY
PERSON OF EVERY NATIONALITY AND
EVERY POLITICAL WILL BE SIGNED
THIS RECALL. WE'VE RECEIVED TWO
POINT ONE SEVEN NINE MILLION
SIGNATURES AND EVERY ONE OF
THOSE SIGNATURES WERE SIGNED UP
BY PEOPLE WHO NEGATIVELY
IMPACTED BY THE ILLEGAL
EXECUTIVE ORDERS THAT GOVERN
BOX. THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. IT. OKAY NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. X. WILL GO TO NUMBER
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS SHANNON HEIL I WOULD
BELIEVE HER SACRAMENTO COUNTY
AND I WOULD JUST LIKE TO SAY
THAT I'M PROUD OF EVERYONE WHO
STOOD UP TO ALL OF YOU AGAINST
ALL ODDS. WE WANTED TO MAKE OUR
VOICES HEARD BECAUSE YOU WERE
NOT LISTENING AND I CAN
GUARANTEE HOW MUCH MONEY WAS IT
FOR US HOW MUCH DID IT COST.
THE TIME AWAY FROM OUR
FAMILIES. THE TIME THAT WE TOOK
TO GO OUT IN THE RAIN THE
SMOKE. TIRES THE SNOW. TO GET
SIGNATURES. THIS WHOLE ENTIRE
HEARING IS COMPLETELY
UNDERSTOOD UNDERSTATING WHAT WE
DID AS A MOVEMENT IN
CALIFORNIA. THE PEOPLE CAME
TOGETHER BECAUSE YOU ARE NOT
LISTENING. AGAIN YOUR TRYING TO
MAKE OUR VOICES SMASHED IN ON
HURT. BUT WE ARE NOT GOING TO
KEEP LETTING YOU DO THAT. WE
ARE STANDING FIRM OF
CALIFORNIANS BECAUSE WE LOVE
THIS STATE. PLEASE STAND FIRM
WITH US. UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
HEARING IS TAKING AWAY FROM THE
PEOPLE WHO SAID. THEY DO NOT
WANT TO BE HARASSED THEY WANT
YOU TO HEAR THEM. THIS THE COST
OF THE RECALL WOULD HAVE NEVER
HAPPENED HAVE YOU WOULD THINK
YOU UP IN THE FIRST PLACE. WE
DEMANDED YOU LOOK THANK YOU ARE
YOU LISTENING NOW. THANK YOU
AND HAVE A GREAT DAY. THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH MOVE ON THE NEXT CALL.
NEXT THE NUMBER FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU ARE
CHAIRMAN BERMAN INTERMINGLING
TO PROPPING UP OPPORTUNITY- FOR
THE PUBLIC AND ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE OURS YOU GAUGE ON THIS WHO
RECALL REFORM MY NAME IS
HEATHER NOT DEPEND ON THE LEGAL
AND POLICY DIRECTOR AT
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE A
NONPARTISAN ORGANIZATION
DEDICATED TO UPHOLDING THE CORE
VALUES OF AMERICAN BOXY. IT IS
ARGUED THAT ANY CHANGE THE
RECALL SAID VANCE DEMOCRATIC
VALUES TOWARDS MAKING ELECTIONS
MORE REPRESENTATIVE.
STRENGTHENING THE INTEGRITY OF
OUR DEMOCRATIC INSTITUTIONS AND
DECENT MANNER AND MAKES
RESPONSIBLE USED AT THE TIME OF
VOTERS AND RESOURCES THAT THE
STATE. THAT SAID THERE ARE
THREE GOLD. WE BELIEVE YOU
SHOULD PURSUE INTER
DELIBERATIONS. ONE IS AFTER
SUCCESSFUL RECALL ELECTION OUR
RULES TO ENSURE THAT ANY
REPLACEMENT CANDIDATE IS
ELECTED. WHAT BROUGHT IN
MAJORITY SUPPORT. TO RECALL
ELECTION SHOULD BE ADMINISTERED
IN A WAY THAT INSPIRES
CONFIDENCE FOR ELECTORAL SYSTEM
AND DE ESCALATE RESPONSIBLE.
AND THE THIRD IT IS WE THINK
THE JUSTIFICATIONS FOR RECALL
OF AN OFFICER SHOULD BE
CLEARER- IN THAT ADDRESS THESE
CONCERNS WE RECOMMEND THE
EXPLORATION OF THE PHONE
PROPOSAL. WITH RESPECT TO THE
CORE RECALL THEM THAT IS TO
ELIMINATE THE SECOND QUESTION
ON THE RECALL BALLOT IN HAVE
THE LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
SIXTEEN. ANY RECALL GOVERNOR
AND CALL THE REPLACEMENT
ELECTION AT THE NEXT STATEWIDE
ELECTION. THIS OPTION WOULD
ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF THE
REPLACEMENT FOR GOVERNOR PM
SELECT IT AT A LOW TURNOUT
SPECIAL ELECTION. AND IT WOULD
STRENGTHENED ILLEGITIMACY
INTEGRITY OF OUR DEMOCRATIC
OFFICE BUT ENHANCE- THANK YOU
TO YOU A OF GOVERNOR. FROM
THANK YOU LIEUTENANT IN A
DEMOCRAT A- OFFICE HOLD WITH.
BUT PLEASE GO AHEAD AND WRAP UP
AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE THANKS.
OKAY WITH AUSTER REFORM WITH
THE INCREASE THE SNEAKER
THRESHOLD- YOU KNOW WE THINK IT
WOULD DEFINITELY REYES CAUGHT
AND MAKING THIS A TOOL FOR ONLY
THOSE WITH RESOURCES TO PURSUE
OKAY THANK YOU FOR THE
CONNECTICUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE IT THANKS SO MUCH
LET'S MOVE ON THE NEXT CALLER.
THREE NUMBER FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HEY CAN YOU HEAR ME.
YES WE CAN HELLO YEAH WE CAN
HEAR YOU OKAY GREAT THANKS HI
MY NAME IS LAURIE M. GOOD
AFTERNOON HONORABLE CHAIRS AND
VICE CHAIRS I'M HERE TODAY IN
MY PERSONAL CAPACITY HOWEVER I
DO SERVE MY COMMUNITY AS AN
ELECTED TRUSTEE FOR CUPERTINO
UNION SCHOOL DISTRICT. I HAVE
ALSO FACED CHIU SERIAL RECALL
ATTEMPTS THIS YEAR I BELIEVE IN
THE RIGHTS OF THE PEOPLE TO USE
RECALL ELECTED TO REDRESS
GRIEVANCES BUT IT IS A VOTER
RIGHTS ISSUE THAT THE BROAD
DEFINITION OF RECALL FOR ANY
REASON RIGHT NOW. MEANS THAT
THE PETITIONS THAT ARMENIAN
COMPLIED AND BLATANTLY FALSE
AND MISLEADING INFORMATION TO
VOTERS ALL OF MY NEEDS BECAUSE
SHE ISN'T THE ONLY INTENT
FILING IN WEAPONIZING ONE IS
LOCAL RECALL TO BECOME TOOLS IN
THE ARSENAL USED BY SOME TO
DESTRUCTIVE. DISRUPT STRICT
BUSINESS BLUDGEON REPUTATION OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND PUBLIC
EDUCATION IN THE COMMUNITY AND
INTIMIDATE AND HARASS THE
ELECTED TRUSTEES WHO ARE I'D
REFER YOU TO ARTICLE TWO
SECTION ONE OF THE STATE
CONSTITUTION STATING THAT
SUFFICIENT THE REASON FOR
RECALL IS NOT WORTH THE OVERALL
AND ELECTION CODE ELEVEN- TO
FOR THAT SUBSTANCE COULD NOT
AFFECT THE VALIDITY OF A RECALL
PETITION. SO WHAT ALTHOUGH
OTHER BALLOT AND VOTER
INFORMATION POINTS IN THE
SYSTEM PROVIDED TO VOTERS- THEY
ARE PROTECTED FROM FALSE AND
MISLEADING INFORMATION RECALL
IS NOT PROPONENTS CAN SAY
LITERALLY ANYTHING THEY WANT
AND IT WILL BE LEGITIMIZED
APPEARING BOTH ON THE OFFICIAL
PETITION AND INFORMATION MAILED
TO VOTERS WITH A BALLOT. GREAT
IF WE CAN ELEVATE RECALL TO THE
TRUE MEASURE OF MALFEASANCE IF
NOT WE STARTED A MINIMUM OF
PROTECTING VOTERS AND OUR
DEMOCRACY BY ADDRESSING FALSE
INFORMATION IN THE. REFORM
pTHANK YOU VERY MUCH. LET'S MOVE
ON TO THE COLOR. NEXT TO NUMBER
TWENTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME RICHARD BY AND I
AM A- I IN CLASS COUNTY- I JUST
WANTTO TOUCH ON A CO THINGS IT
WAS THAT- ONE- THERE WAS A WORD
USUALLY GUYS WERE OUR- WHETHER
IT WAS LEGAL OR YOU KNOW MORAL
WHAT IS IT THAT THE- DID THAT
PERSON. THAT STATUS IS WITH
WHAT WHAT WHAT WOULD THEY BE
RECALLED FOR AND- I DON'T
REALLY CARE WHAT WAS ON THE
BALLOT WHEN THE BALLOT WENT
THROUGH BECAUSE WHERE WE'RE AT
NOW. THERE IS SO MUCH MORE THAT
COULD BE ADDED THAT BALLOT- BUT
I DO BELIEVE IT YOU KNOW
MORALLY IF YOU'RE DOING
SOMETHING THAT'S AGAINST THE
PEOPLE'S WELL WE'RE ALLOWED TO
POINT THAT OUT- SCHOOL TEACHER
AND SHE DOES A NATIVE AMERICAN
DANCE. AS A REFERENCE OR THE
KIDS SHE COULD GET CAN- THERE
FOR THE PEOPLE IN POWER SHOULD
SHOULD WATCH WHAT THEY DO IT
THEY'RE GONNA ASK PEOPLE TO
CLOSE THEIR BUSINESSES DOWN OR
CLOSE THEIR COUNTING DOWN. THEY
SHOULDN'T. IT SHOULDN'T KEEP
THEIR- OPEN SO REGARD IF IT'S
LEAGUE OR NOT WHEN YOU'RE-
EVERYTHING THAT WE HAVE IN YOUR
AND YOU CAN KEEP PUSHING AND
PUSHING. I THINK THERE COMES A
POINT THAT YEAH. YOU'RE
REGARDLESS IF IT'S LEGAL OR
ILLEGAL. YOU SHOULD BE RECALL
THAT'S THE ONLY THING WE GOT
THAT'S THE ONLY THING WE HAVE
AND LIKE I SAID. IF WE DID A
RECALL TODAY IF WE WERE NOT
TODAY THERE WOULD BE SO MUCH
MORE TO PUT ON THAT BALLOT.
FROM INJECTING WANTING TO
INJECT YOUR KIDS. WITH ATTACHED
DRUGS PLEASE PLEASE GO AHEAD MY
OPPONENT. PLEASE GO AHEAD RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT I'M A WRAP UP RIGHT
NOW LIKE I SAID IF WE GET IT
RIGHT NOW THERE'D BE A LOT MORE
SO I DON'T CARE IF IT'S LEGALLY
OR ILLEGAL THAT'S IT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. LET'S MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT CALLER PLEASE. NEXT WOULD
ALIGN FORTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HI MY NAME IS HENRY FONG- I'M A
LIBERAL DEMOCRAT I FIND A
RECALL PETITION I ALSO WORK AT
THE LECTERN WORKER- IN THE LA
AREA WHERE I LIVE ALTHOUGH
OBVIOUSLY I'M NOT SPEAKING FOR
THEM- IN REGARDS TO SOME OF THE
AT THE RECALL OF THE VOTE OF NO
CONFIDENCE. I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'RE LOOKING AT THE
MALFEASANCE ISSUE AND ALSO IF
YOU REALLY WANT JUDGES TO
DETERMINE WHETHER RECALL COULD
QUALIFY IF IT ENDS UP YOU KNOW
CREATING MORE ISSUES THAT NOT
SO I LOOK AT IT LET'S MAKE IT A
VOTE OF NO CONFIDENCE LET THE-
HAVE. YOU KNOW MAYBE SHORTEN
THE PERIOD I THINK THAT THE
GOOD POINT NINETY DAYS I THINK
IT'S FINE HOW LIKE A REFERENDUM
BECAUSE REFERENDUMS THAT
REQUIRED NINETY DAYS QUALIFY
ONLY NINETY DAYS AND I THINK I
RECALL NINETY DAYS THAT THEY
COULD FIND- I LIKE A PROFESSOR
ROBERT CHRISTIAN ON THE IDEA.
WITH HAVING WON THE ELECTION
AND THEN DOING A RUN OFF
AFTERWARDS BUT UNFORTUNATELY IT
TAKES A LONG FOR HELPING TO
SERVE BY ELECTIONS AND THEN YOU
HAVE TO PREPARE FOR NEXT
ELECTION CO THAT GAP. IT MIGHT
BE A LITTLE TOO LONG NINETY
DAYS MIGHT BE A LITTLE TOO LONG
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN DO A
STATEWIDE SPECIAL IN THE RUN
OFF- SO QUICKLY- LIKE BECAUSE
SOME PEOPLE THINK THEY CAN DO
AND ALSO- ONE IDEA THAT I HAVE
A PART THAT MIGHT BE OUT OF THE
BOXES WITH THE RECALL WHETHER
IT THE OLDER PASSES IN EXTENT
SOMEBODY'S TERM TWO YEARS. SO
THAT YOU KNOW YOU DON'T HAVE A
SITUATION WHERE SOMEBODY JUST
STARTED OUT THE NEW GOVERNOR
AND THEY HAVE TO GO ELECTION IN
LIKE EIGHT OR NINE MONTHS THEY
HAVE TWO YEARS TO DO ANY OLD
GREW UP PEOPLE LIKE WILL IT
MIGHT YOU KNOW MESSED UP WITH
THE CYCLE OF ELECTION BUT I
THINK GIVING THEM A MINIMUM
TERM OF TWO YEARS WOULD BE
GOOD. OKAY REGARDLESS OF
WHETHER IT HAPPENS OR FAIL.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE- CALLER
PLEASE. WE NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY IS AB I AM IN FACT COUNTY I
WAS ONE OF THE VOLUNTEERS FOR
THE RECALL AND IN ONE OF THE
RESPONSES I BOUGHT MY OWN
SUPPLIES ME PAGES TRANSLATE
FINE CANTONESE VIETNAMESE AND
INDIAN THREE TAX AMENITY I
PAPER BABYSITTER. SO I COULD
VOLUNTEER TO WORK ON THE RECALL
IT MEANT THAT MUCH TO ME- SO
THERE WAS NOT MONEY FLOATING
OUT PASSED AND I WAS A DEMOCRAT
REGISTERED DEMOCRATS UP UNTIL
ABOUT A YEAR AND A HALF AGO
USED TO WATCHING THIS
LEGISLATURE THE SUPERMAJORITY
IN THE ECHO CHAMBER WITH IN
THAT BUILDING THAT IS NOT
LISTENING TO THE PEOPLE THE
PARTY LAST NAME. I THAT LEAD
MAJORITY OF THE STATE BY
COLLECTED WHERE PEOPLE WHO
VOTED FOR NEWS THEM SO THIS
HEARING ALLOWING. YOU'RE A PEAK
MOMENT BECAUSE IT FURTHER SHOWS
HOW FAR YOU HAVE HAS DEVIATED
FROM LISTENING TO THE PEOPLE
THIS IS ABOUT CHECKS AND
BALANCES- YOU STILL HAVE A DUTY
TO LISTEN TO THE CONSTITUENTS
WHO VOTED FOR YOU WHETHER THEY
ALIGN WITH YOUR PARTY OR NOT-
THE ONLY THING THAT IS PARTISAN
IS THIS PROCESS NOT TO RECALL.
AT SO I'M ASKING YOU TO LEAVE
IT ALONE YOU KNOW RECALL REFORM
IF AND THE WAY YOU ARE
REPRESENTING IT WHEN WE'RE
GOING INTO MONTANA LOOKING AT
MILEAGE- YEAH YOU GUYS ARE
GOING A BIT OVER THE TOP THERE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
THAT ARE THERE ANY ADDITIONAL.
WHO WISH TO TEST. AND IF YOU
LIKE TO PROVIDE PUBLIC PLEASE
PRESS. ONE TO. IT LOOKS LIKE WE
DO HAVE TWO MORE IN THE QUEUE
IT'LL JUST BE A MOMENT OKAY
WE'RE GONNA WAIT FOR TO WE'VE
GOT TO MORE CALLERS-
I WILL GO
TO. OF MINE FORTY EIGHT FORTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME YES. HI MY NAME IS
PETER AND I LIVE IN SAN
FRANCISCO I WANNA BRING UP ONE
POINT THAT AND GOT LOST EARLIER
WHEN WITNESSES WERE TALKING
ABOUT THE SIGNATURE THRESHOLD
IN CALIFORNIA VERSUS THAT IN
OTHER STATES SOME OF THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE WERE
BRINGING UP THAT THE WRONG
NUMBER IS HIGHER IN CALIFORNIA
BECAUSE OF OUR LARGER
POPULATION. I POINT OUT THAT
OUR LARGER POPULATION ALSO
MEANS PROPONENTS WOULD HAVE
MORE POTENTIAL SIGNATURE
GATHERERS WHICH BALANCES OUT
THE HIGHER NUMBER OF SIGNATURES
TO GATHER. THE THRESHOLD SHOULD
BE BASED ON PERCENTAGE AND IT
SHOULD BE INCREASED TO BE
SIMILAR TO OTHER STATES WE CALL
IT IS AN IMPORTANT TOOL FOR
WHEN SOMEONE'S PRESENTLY IN
OFFICE IS AN EMERGENCY IN THAT
SITUATION THE PEOPLE SHOULD
HAVE NO PROBLEM FINDING ONE
QUARTER OF VOTERS IN NINETY
DAYS TO SUPPORTER RECALL RECALL
IS NOT FOR POLICY DIFFERENCES
THAT SHOULD BE ADDRESSED IN THE
NEXT REGULAR ELECTION. I ALSO
SUPPORT OTHER REFORMS SUCH AS
SENATOR ALAN S. C. H. THREE
WHICH WOULD ALLOW THE INCUMBENT
TO APPEAR AMONG THE CANDIDATES
FOR REPLACEMENT AS WELL AS
RANKED CHOICE WHICH WE USE IN
SAN FRANCISCO FOR MUNICIPAL
ELECTIONS AND HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL AT ENABLING. THE
PEOPLE TO EXPRESS THEIR WILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
LET'S MOVE ON TO THE NEXT-
COLOR. NEXT TO AN OLD NUMBER
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY
NAME IS JENNIFER AND I'M A
CONCERNED CITIZEN OF CALIFORNIA
I POSED THE CHANGING OF THE
RECALL LAW AND THEY FEEL IT
WOULD MAKE THE FUTURE RECALLS
ACCOUNTABLE TO THE PUBLIC WHEN
THEY'RE NOT SATISFIED WITH THE
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL ACTION. I
UNDERSTAND ALREADY IT'S HARD
ENOUGH TO OBTAIN A RECALL BUT
IF YOU MAKE IT HADER YOU ARE
ESSENTIALLY TAKING AWAY PUBLIC
FOR. I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO GIVE
CREDIT WHERE CREDIT IS DUE
THANK YOU TO THE GROUP.
ORGANIZED THREE CALL TWO POINT
ONE MILLION SIGNATURES. ARE YOU
KIDDING ME. AND ONE POINT SEVEN
OF THEM BEING FROM VOLUNTEERS
THAT'S AMAZING. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. DO YOU
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL CALLERS.
BUT THIS TIME THERE ARE NO
OTHERS IN THE QUEUE PLEASE
CONTINUE GREAT SO WE'RE GOING
TO CLOSE DOWN AT THE- IT
TELEPHONE TESTIMONY PART OF
TODAY'S HEARING WE DO HAVE A-
AN ADDITIONAL A MEMBER OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE ROOM WHO
WOULDLIKE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SIR- GO RIGHT AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON THANK YOU FOR BEING
GRACIOUS TO ALLOW ME THIS TIME.
MY NAME IS CAROL WEBER AND I'M
A FORMER CONGRESSIONAL
CANDIDATE DOWN IN LOS ANGELES-
AS A DOCUMENTARY FILMMAKER I'VE
SEEN FIRST HAND. WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS WHO
ARE DRUNK ON POWER FOR SIX
THEIR OWN PEOPLE. WHAT HAPPENS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA IS THAT WE
HAVE A STATE LEGISLATURE HAS A
VETO PROOF 75% DEMOCRATS
SUPERMAJORITY. IN BOTH THE
ASSEMBLY ON THE STATE SENATE AS
WELL AS DEMOCRATS HOLDING ALL
SIX STATE SEATS FROM GOVERNOR
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO INSURANCE
COMMISSIONER. WHAT ENDS UP
HAPPENING IS THAT. ANYTIME THAT
YOU HAND OFF EXECUTIVE POWER TO
SEE THE GOVERNOR FOR THEM TO
RULE BY EXECUTIVE ORDER. YOU
ARE NOW CREATING A SITUATION OF
ENABLEMENT. AND WE'VE SEEN THIS
HAPPEN ACROSS THE WORLD WHAT
WERE YOU CENTRALIZE POWER. THAT
CENTRALIZED POWER CAN BE ABUSED
WHEN THAT CENTRALIZED POWER IS
ABUSED IT'S IMPORTANT FOR THE
CITIZENS LIVING WITHIN THAT
AREA THAT IS BEING GOVERNED. TO
BE ABLE TO HOLD THEIR ELECTED
OFFICIALS ACCOUNTABLE. BECAUSE
THERE IS NO REPUBLICAN
REPRESENTATION THAT CAN PUSH
BACK AGAINST ALL ODDS ARE
AGAINST EXECUTIVE ORDERS THAT
HAPPENED IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IT IS IMPORTANT
THAT WE HAVE SOME MECHANISM TO
MAKE SURE THAT WHOEVER IS THE
ELECTED EXECUTIVE IN.
CALIFORNIA THAT THEY KNOW THAT
THEIR JOB IS ALWAYS UNDER
THREAT AND THEY WILL ALWAYS BE
THREATENED OF LOSING THEIR JOB.
BECAUSE THE MOMENT THAT NO ONE
FEELS SCARED ABOUT LOSING THEIR
JOB. THEY WILL CONTINUE TO
TERRORIZE THEIR OWN PEOPLE
PLEASE ROUTE YOUR TESTIMONY
THANK. YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. SO CONCLUDES THE
PUBLIC COMMENT PART OF THE OF
THE HEARING- VICE OUT CHAIR
GLAZER. YEAH LET'S MOVE ON A
CLOSING COMMENTS RIGHT AT YOUR
BERMAN THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO
SAY A COUPLE THINGS ONE I WANT
TO THANK THE STAFF YOUR STAFF
AND OUR STAFF IN THE SENATE FOR
THE GREAT- HISTORICAL- ANALYSIS
OF THE FACTS THAT HAVE REALLY
CREATED THE BASIS FOR THIS
IMPORTANT. CONVERSATION
SECONDLY I WANT TO THANK TO
TEACHER BERMAN YOUR WORK- TO
BRING A REAL BREATH OF- OF
FOLKS TO THIS HEARING ROOM
TODAY THROUGH THEM FOR THE MOST
PART- TO ACTING TO BRING
EXPERTISE FROM REPUBLICANS FROM
DEMOCRATS FROM- INDEPENDENCE
FROM NO PARTY PREFERENCE I MEAN
WE REALLY TRIED TO STRETCH. AND
NOT JUST GET ONE POINT OF VIEW
I THINK WE ALL RECOGNIZE THAT.
THAT THE WORK THAT WE ARE DOING
AT THE END OF THE DAY- IT'S
GOING TO BE THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA WHO WILL DECIDE OF
THAT SO WHILE THERE HAS BEEN.
SOME SUGGESTION THAT A
SUPERMAJORITY OF ONE PARTY IS
GOING TO JAM THROUGH ONE REFORM
OR ANOTHER OR ONE CHANGE
ANOTHER IS SIMPLY NOT TRUE. I
THINK YOUR GOALS IN MIND OR TO
PROVIDE A BROAD. CONSENSUS
POINT OF CHANGE IF IT'S NEEDED-
AND I THINK THAT IS AN
IMPORTANT POINT THAT WAS MADE
EARLIER. IS THAT IT'S REALLY
FOR THE LONG TERM IT'S NOT FOR
SOME INSTANT. CHANGE ONE THING
OR ANOTHER THAT. PROTECTS OUR
DEMOCRACY PROTECTS
ACCOUNTABILITY. OF OUR ELECTED
LEADERS- BUT- HAS- ONE OF THE
WITNESSES THAT TESTIFIED
EARLIER. I KIND OF AVOIDED THE
CLOWN CAR ELEMENTS THAT HAVE
FOUND THEIR WAY INTO THIS
PROCESS SO WITH THAT I THINK
IT'S YOUR BERMAN FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP ON THIS AND LOOK FOR
TO WORKING WITH YOU- IN THE
MONTHS AHEAD. THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SIR GLAZER AND
ADVISERS HERE TO- ONE IF YOU
HAVE ANY CLOSING COMMENTS SURE
THANK YOU. I FIRST OF ALL THANK
YOU EVERYBODY FOR PARTICIPATING
IN THIS- THIS IS A VERY GOOD
CONVERSATION TO HAVE. BECAUSE
THERE ARE QUESTIONS OUT THERE
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO SEE SOME CHANGES- BUT
AT THE SAME TIME YOU KNOW THE
INITIAL TEST.OF WHEN THIS
PROCESS WAS A DILEMMA DEPT YEAH
DEVELOPED IN NINETEEN ELEVEN.
WE'RE SIMPLY A MISUSE OF POWER.
IT WAS TO CHECK THE MISUSE OF
POWER. AND YOU KNOW I'VE HEARD
SOME THINGS IN HERE LIKE THE
NOTION THAT OUR CITIZENS ARE
INCAPABLE OF DETERMINING FOR
THEMSELVES WHAT CONSTITUTES
EITHER MALFEASANCE OR A MISUSE
OF POWER- YOU KNOW WHAT I THINK
ONE POINT FIVE TO TWO MILLION
PEOPLE. ARE ARE. AYE I WOULD
HESITATE TO TRY TO CATEGORIZE
THEM LIKE THAT- I THINK OUR
CITIZENS ARE PERFECTLY CAPABLE
OF DETERMINING WHAT CONSTITUTES
MALFEASANCE OR AN ABUSE OF
POWER. YOU KNOW IT'S SIGNATURE
GATHERING IT APPEARS TO BE
EFFECTIVE AS IT IS- WE'VE HEARD
SOME TESTIMONY FROM SOME PEOPLE
THAT CRUNCH NUMBERS AND ARE
PRETTY MUCH EXPERTS. THAT IF WE
MESS WITH THIS WE ARE MAKING
THE PROCESS WE'RE TAKING IT
FROM A PROCESS IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT RIGHT NOW TO NEARLY
IMPOSSIBLE. AND THAT WILL NOT
BE LOOKED ON KINDLY BY OUR
CITIZENS AND VOTERS- NO AND
LASTLY YOU KNOW I HEARD A
COUPLE OF TIMES OUR OUR PROCESS
IS AN OUT LIAR IN THE UNITED
STATES. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
I'VE HEARD ALL YEAR IS THAT
CALIFORNIA IS INDEED AN OUT
LIAR IN DOING THE RIGHT THING
TRYING TO LEAD THE NATION AND
WHAT WE SHOULD BE DOING. AND IN
MAYBE OUR SYSTEM IS GOOD TO
MAYBE OTHER PEOPLE NEED TO
ASSIMILATE TO OUR SYSTEM
INSTEAD- BUT ANYWAY- THE
EXPERTS WERE VERY USEFUL AND I
APPRECIATE THEIRTIME THAT THEY
TOOK TODAY AND THE TIME OF MY
COLLEAGUES TO PUT TOGETHER.
WHAT WE DIG PUT TOGETHER A
PANEL CAN GIVE US DIVERSE-
OPINIONS ON THIS SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU OF ICRC
ARE JOE AND REALLY WANT TO
THANK YOU KNOW YOU- VICE OR
NIELSEN- FOR YOUR-
PARTICIPATION IN IN TODAY'S
HEARING- AND- YOU KNOW
HOPEFULLY YEAH I'M SURE YOUNG
GROUP PARTICIPATION MOVING
FORWARD- AS WE HAVE FUTURE
HEARINGS. REALLY WANT TO THANK-
MY COLLEAGUES AT YOUR GLAZER-
AND HIS STAFF- FOR ALL THE WORK
THAT YOU'VE DONE IT FOR LIKE A
WEEK THIS IS CENTER GLAZER AND
I AT YOUR GLAZER AND I'VE GOT A
LOT OF CONVERSATIONS. LEADING
UP TO TODAY'S HEARING- AND I
THINK WE ENDED UP IN A GREAT
PLACE. WITH A VERY DIVERSE SET
OF YOU POINTS AND PERSPECTIVES-
I POLITICAL VIEWPOINTS-
PARTICIPATING IN TODAY'S
HEARING IN OFFERING A BROAD
SPECTRUM OF SUGGESTIONS. FOR
HOW WE MIGHT BE ABLE TO WORK
FOR EIGHT DO WE EVEN NEED TO
REFORM OUR RECALL PROCESS OR
NOT THERE WAS DISAGREEMENT ON
THAT. BYE BYE TODAY'S WITNESSES
AND THEN IF SO HOW- AND THERE'S
PLENTY OF IDEAS. FOR US TO
FLUSH OUT. OVER THE COMING
MONTHS AS WE DECIDE WHETHER OR
NOT TO REFORM THE RECALL
PROCESS I THINK WE ALL STRONGLY
BELIEVE- THAT THAT CALIFORNIA
MUST MAINTAIN A RECALL PROCESS.
I THINK THE QUESTION IS HOW CAN
WE DEVELOP A SYSTEM WHERE THE
END RESULT IS IN THE EXACT SAME
VOTE THAT HAPPENED THREE YEARS
BEFORE. AND IT TWENTY FOUR
PERCENT- YOU KNOW VICTORY I
GUESS YOU WILL FOR THE
INCUMBENT. BECAUSE I THINK THAT
SHOWS THAT THE RECALL PROCESS
IS. TOO EASY TO INITIATE AND
DOESN'T PROPERLY REPRESENT
CLOSE TO MAJORITY OF THE
PEOPLE- IF WE BELIEVE IN A
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS WE SHOULD
HAVE A PROCESS THAT THAT. AT
LEAST- CREATES SORT OF LIKE.
THAT THE RECALL WILL BE
COMPETITIVE- AND THAT IS WHAT
WE SAW IN THIS INSTANCE AND SO
WE SAW WAS. AN EXPENDITURE OF
TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE THREE
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS. A
DISTRACTION OF GOVERNANCE FOR
ALMOST A YEAR- AND THAT'S THE
ADDED TIME WHEN THEY WERE
MAXIMUM CHALLENGES ALREADY THAT
WERE FACING- AND THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING I BELIEVE THAT'S GOOD
FOR GOVERNANCE SO- I THINK
THERE'S- A LOT MORE
CONVERSATIONS TO BE HAD I KNOW
WE'LL HAVE ANOTHER HEARING-
HOPEFULLY PROBABLY THIS YEAR-
WALL WALL MOUNTS THOSE DETAILS
AS WE GET CLOSER- AS WE DIVE A
LITTLE DEEPER. THE ISSUE OF
LOCAL RECALLS I THINK IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND ONE THAT WE PLAN.
TO DIVE DEEPER INTO- AT THE
NEXT HEARING BECAUSE I KNOW
THAT. IS MUCH MORE THAN JUST
THE GUBERNATORIAL RECALL BUT
BUT IT'S LIKE WE HEARD FROM A
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER- THEN AND A
LOT OF LOCAL. ELECTED OFFICIALS
WHO WERE EITHER BEING RECALLED
OR UNDER THREAT OF RECALL AND
EVEN BEING NDER THREAT OF
RECALL. JUST HAVING SOMEBODY
PULL PAPERS TO INITIATE A
RECALL PROCESS. IS VERY
DISTRACTING- AND VERY BAD I
THINK FOR GOVERNANCE-
ESPECIALLY IF THEY HAVE NO
INTENTION OF ACTUALLY
QUALIFYING IT SO. THERE'S A LOT
TO UNPACK- BUT LOOK FOR TO
CONVERSATIONS WITH MY
COLLEAGUES FROM ACROSS THE
AISLE. THANK YOU TO MY STAFF
ALSO FOR ALL THE WORK THEY DID
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF MONTHS.
A VERY GRATEFUL- TO IT TO
EVERYBODY FOR REALLY PUTTING A
LOT OF TIME AND EFFORT TO THIS
HEARING- ONE THING THE
SERGEANTS FOR ALL THE WORK THEY
DID- AS WELL- AND WITH THAT-
THIS HEARINGS ADJOURNED.